foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah yeah
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
it was a fantastic day filled with
action-packed Chess at the Cairns Cup in
St Louis if you're searching for
compelling clashes featuring The Game's
best female players then wish granted
with a draw in hand tournament leader
Anna satonski could have coasted into
the final round with a narrow lead
hoping things fell her way but the
four-time U.S women's champion chose her
own fate grinding out the victory to win
the 2023 Cairns cup earning her first
Grandmaster Norm in the process the cup
has been claimed but there are still
plenty of prize money up for grabs who
will bear down and finish strong day
nine of amazing chess coming up next
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone welcome back to round
nine of the Karen's cup it's been an
exciting tournament so far but it all
comes down to this let's go to the
studio and get this party started
welcome to San Luis the home of Chess in
America and the third edition of the
Karens cup one of the richest women's
tournaments in chess we come to you live
from the San Luis chess club
foreign
[Music]
thank you for joining us I'm
International Master nazify kids and I'm
here with Grandmaster yeah see I can't
believe it the tournament's coming to an
end oh it's been wonderful though it
really has it really has hello everyone
and Welcome to our Championship round
guess what we already have a winner and
here she is Anna satonski in her moment
of Glory yesterday as she won the
tournament with one round spare let's
have a look
[Music]
wow she almost ready to burst into tears
I think uh happiness as
E5 I don't think she has realized yet
that the other games went her way as
well right and that she is a few moves
away from winning the championship
because irina's games going to be a draw
right and I don't know if you realize it
yet but you are about to well you won
the tournament wow
when I was living I was thinking here I
was not smiling I was thinking that if
it's dropped because like um like
slightly misplaced and she had to find a
couple little exact moves wow so you're
very happy unbelievable
I cannot believe that so this is
probably you and there she is Anna
zatanski the Cairns cup 2023 Champion 45
000 richer our congratulations Anna
while you win first the fight for second
is quite intense and Nasi do the honors
and tell us our current standings as we
go into our Championship round let's
take a look come again congratulations
to our winner and as a chance key but
for second place there's still four
players in the mix right Alexandra Bella
Hotel Nashville Irena crush and it was
Elizabeth pets we'll all be fighting
today for that second place absolutely
and tell us about the format we have a
nine player round robin no drawers
allowed and the time control is
classical 90 minutes for first 40 moves
30 minutes rest of the game and 30
second increment from move one wonderful
and uh Mara tell us about Anna's
incredible road to Victory A Cinderella
Story the fight for second in bonjour
well Anna is first of all she's the
first American player to win the Karen
scuff so this is a historic event indeed
she is leading the event
um one point and a half ahead the field
before the last round so let's have a
look at there at her road to Victory so
she won four games she Drew three games
she scored five and a half points out of
eight games out of seven games yes and
there is one more round today so she's
our champion but the first place might
be decided we will still have the second
place which is up for grabs let's have a
look at the pairings
Elizabeth pets is facing Alexandra
Castillo
their head-to-head score is the
following so Elizabeth 1-4 games
Alexander won nine games and they drew
seven games and they know each other for
such a long time they started to play in
the youth World Championship
but there are actually four players
which can fight for the second place and
today we have the Ultimate Clash of
American heavyweights uh the greatest
rivalry I think of the American women's
chess Grandmaster Arena crash is playing
against Anna zatonskick so Irina has to
win 12 wins nine losses and 10 draws and
it reminds me of the greatest rivalry
between
um Sanford speaks Sampras and Andrea
Garcia and I was always looking forward
to those matches anticipating the
intensity of the battle and I wanted
also to point out that Bello Hotel
Nashville is in the fight for the second
place as well yes
great rivalries bring out the best in
the players as well as do the honors and
tell our audience what to expect from
the pairings for this all-important
Championship round take a look this is
our final round pairings Irina crash
playing Anna zatonsky
match-up game right there
against harika dronavali and Elizabeth
pets playing Alexandra Costa new seems
like all the games are in a fight per
second but not quite the second round
the second table does it uh lots of
fighting what are they fighting for
they're fighting for a lot of money
there's total of hundred and eighty
thousand dollars in prizes and Anna
already won the first prize forty five
thousand dollars so that's off the table
but there's four players fighting for
the 35 25 and 20 000 got it too and if
there is a tie do they play a playoff
for this money over the first places no
there would be a tie break only happens
for the first place but Anna already won
that if there's a tie for the second
place players will split them on gotcha
and a very generous price pound all the
way down to 10th and final place of six
thousand as we see Dr Jeannie sinfield
uh the Karen's cup is her maiden name
and Elizabeth at the board she's already
here the bearing down I like that by the
way I liked writing early before the
game and getting myself in that I want
to say headspace yeah the combative mood
that zone and I tell you uh when I could
get into that zone I felt so good I mean
no butterflies nothing all the players
are getting they're getting scanned and
having a little chat before the round
they're all friendly until they sit down
exactly then the nights come out
and how what do you think how is it
going to be hard for Anna to play today
since she already won the tournament
yes and so I think first of all it
there's this great sense of relief she's
accomplished uh her Mission winning the
first place that's that's the first
thing but the second thing is she's a
competitor just look at the interview
that Alexandra gave if you don't think
that these women are competitors uh-uh
you got it wrong they're competitors and
you get to the board and that
competitive spirit I don't care it comes
out it Wells up out of somewhere and no
and she doesn't want to lose she wants
to win she wants to have a great result
her Grandmaster Norman hand and Anna has
technically speaking nothing to lose
today but her opponent Irina has to win
in order to fight for that second place
potentially win it clear and for arena
she doesn't want to go over like like
you know it's it's a winner Bust or
something like that a draw gets her a
nice
prize but just this idea of a win as we
see Bella what a tournament she's had by
the way
I was about to say undefeated
uh for Anna but drawless
for Bella and Almera jumped right in uh
talk about Anna's mood sometimes you you
think that she might have a letdown that
she's already won the tournament uh well
I don't think so when we actually had a
very long walk yesterday we discussed a
lot of things and she is ready for the
fight today and she knows that it is not
going to be a walk in the park like
yesterday right so and I also saw it
about David Bernstein when you were
pointing out that Elizabeth is already
sitting at the board fully concentrated
David Bernstein always arrived 10
minutes early in order to achieve this
state of concentration
yes and we just heard the uh just heard
the Bell there is Arena
he's just slightly ever so slightly late
arrives at the board and is ready his
players have played each other in the
last round for the titles so many times
right
um
obviously Anna's in a state of euphoria
could you be could that you know like
you you come to the board and you're
nervous
but could it be the opposite as well
that you come to the board and your
overconfidence is stands in the way
I mean how strange that uh feeling is as
the championship round is underway round
nine
uh Irina D4 and D5 uh arena for sure
would expect Anna to play her Queen's
Gambit Queen's Gambit declined uh
positions that and there you go D5 E6 no
surprises thus far I'm curious to see
what Irina has prepared in the opening
right
how how to get it and get an edge and
again four players in the mix per second
plays uh Elizabeth and Alexandra in that
in their head-to-head match that we saw
uh four wins nine wins for Alexandra and
Alexandra has been having also a roller
coaster event
yes most definitely and um
I think
she mentioned the yesterday that she
also got a little bit sick Alexandra so
that affected her tournament as well
right
B5 and once again just to write and
remind you of their head Dad they you
were mentioning Almera these two players
have been playing each other since
they're youth days of Youth since there
were kids and actually I wanted to offer
poker players perspective on this game
because I think if you take the prizes
into account uh they give a plus
decision for Elizabeth would be to play
for a win today because it's it makes a
huge difference she's a half a point
behind a victory over Alexander where to
allow her to LeapFrog and then she would
like to see Bella finally making a draw
and she would like to see Arena also
making a draw Bishop by the way I
noticed in the game between Elizabeth
and Alexandra Alexandra offered a
marshall Gambit like approach c2c3 D7
she already had one game in this
tournament it was against
and the anti-martial of the so-called
anti-martial a2a4 was played by
Elizabeth so I'm for sure thinking that
Elizabeth came to this game very
compared Bishop B7 on the board as they
these two ladies enter a very
theoretically charted game a game where
you're probably not going to speak too
much about is the game between Nana and
gunai so let's just take a look at it
right out of the opening and uh the
ready if you will G3 Bishop G2 Bishop G4
B2 B3 here a kind of a double fear and
Shadow usually when you're playing B3 in
G3 these lead to lines where you end up
playing D3 and E4 mostly for that reason
I always like playing my knight to F6 my
Bishop to F5 and playing a London to
fight over the control of the E2 E4
squared Bishop G4 on the board question
for you yes here it comes ready
you're black do you take on F3
right away so if I commit to playing
Bishop G4 then yes right because after
Bishop takes the difference is that you
can immediately grab the center at the
cost of two Bishops now some players
wouldn't do that they would say you know
like uh the the the loss of the two
Bishops is too great uh other players
like grabbing the center and that was
really what the question was about I
also prefer Knight F6 Bishop F5 lines
that you mentioned right but Bishop
takes F3 and E5 would you'd find you'd
find that attractive it is interesting
yes yeah okay and Almera surprise game
the opening we have a Terrace defense
whoa okay so a clear indication that
Anna wasn't interested in in finding out
what arena had prepared but the C C5
tires without Knight F6
uh that's a big surprise C takes D5 e
takes D5 and there was a period of in
his life where
Gary Kasparov had become a real
proponent of the tarash and it was only
in the first world championship match
between Kasparov and karpov way way back
in 1984 that Gary stopped playing guitar
rash it was uh it was a heavy
theoretical Minefield that the players
did and today bataresh defense is is
considered still
completely viable but at the highest
levels the players aren't doing it h7h6
Bishop E3 this was karpas treatment that
stopped and made Gary play The King's
Indian and everybody was upset at carpa
for forcing Gary to the king's NBA
India where he started beating people
but this was the reason why the atarash
became less of a frequent guess do you
think on the highest level they don't
play tennis often just because white has
so many ways they can play and it's to
know just so much Theory exactly that
that is exactly the case which is why
today when the the players of today play
the Taurus what they like to do
is include
a capture of the knights so this today
has become a real uh theoretical
Battleground this position you take a
couple of swap off a couple of minor
pieces and uh you narrow the path of
where white is going so this is what I
might call a modern tarash and what uh
what Anna has is let's say the old
tarash
and they certain no strangers to one
another they've played 31 games while
wins for Irena nine for Anna and tendros
and 12 U.S chess championship titles
between them too that's amazing those
wins and losses uh trust me they decided
a lot of women's championships so we'll
keep an eye on the tarash and over to
you Almera what uh has caught your eye
well I've been thinking about the game
between Irina crash and um
anesthetonskik and I wanted to know
which line Anna prepared for this game
because as you already said this
position is highly theoretical Irina
just played G3 and this is a very well
known setup so
if you play Knight F6 and Bishop G2 of
course you have a lot of theoretical
moves Bishop E7 is one of the main lines
here but I was thinking if she's going
for this line then she's probably going
for something concrete so one of the
most concrete moves here is to take on
D4 immediately and you have a lot of uh
players top players who use this
variation recently and no other than
Magnus Carlsen so after 94
black place
Bishop C5 then Knight B3 Bishop B6 okay
here you can Castle but white can also
play Knight A4
castle and then
take on B6 and
play this position risk free I think for
white but maybe Anna wants
to well here after Knight Bishop B6
after Castle she wants to achieve this
position so and here you go for D4 so
I'm trying to understand her state of
mind so probably she prepared this line
so after D4 what can you do here you can
play Knight E4 once again then Newcastle
this could also transpose and Bishop G5
yes this position is evaluated is a bit
it's slightly better for
for white but I think that after Rook 8
black has comfortable play
nice uh reminds me that specifically
position reminds me of a Karo Khan
reversed
panoff uh but then it Karo Khan I want
to draw our attention to the game of
Bella for just a moment because even
though it's a theoretical move it's a
move that's always kind of caught me a
little bit of scans okay what we have is
Catalan G2 G3 uh Bella with white Bishop
B4 check Bishop D2 A5 okay so we kind of
think that with this move A5 we're
probably not going to go into uh open
Catalan Bishop G2 castles Queen C2 we're
probably going to play a closed Catalan
with something like C6
uh Knight b87 but this move C7 C5 with
the inclusion of Bishop B4 check really
has me scratching my head because a
question for you if I take on B4 aren't
you afraid that I might capture this
Pawn on C5 maybe black wants to take
with the sequence exactly and then
you're sitting there going well look at
your weird Pawn structure you you've
kind of voluntarily doubled your pawns
on the V4 and B7 squares uh I so if I
take with the a pawn right and you take
on C5 right maybe I push D4 just to make
those pawns look funny or do queen A5 or
D4 D4 Queen A5
I have this nice trick for you yes
you're gonna love it are you ready Queen
A5 I'm a pawn Grabber right
I take the pawn
okay go ahead kill me through the check
yeah
go ahead kill me
be takes a
[Laughter]
everybody has to fall into this pattern
at least twice
their career to be sure that the first
time you fell into it it was losing
right but you lose this is my first time
so you get you get you get to do it once
more so yeah there is Queen A5 that
might be that might be what uh how it
goes Almera jumped in uh C7 C5 with the
inclusion of Bishop B4 check that's a
little bit uh perplexing but uh do your
best and try to explain it to myself
still extremely highly theoretical this
position a lot of recent games and Nazi
was right after Bishop before eight days
before uh GTX C5 black plays D4 wow as
you can see this position is about equal
okay but they have a few games here so
there are two moves you can play Knight
busy too okay natural but there is
another move a more active one a white
Place 95 here okay so let's say if Queen
C7 I think that White's idea is simply
to protect the pawn on C5 let's do it
yes and
you would be happy yes sir after Knight
A6 you there is no way for you for the
moments to well to protect it
in
yeah the pawn on C5 but Knight D2 so if
you take on C5 let's say if you take on
C5 then I can take on B4 and why it is
much better but black strategy here is
not to take on C5 but to play E5
okay and I think that black has a
sufficient compensation for this well
ephemeral phone on C5 because I really
think that you will be able to take it
and let's say after Castle
ephemeral extra pawn bishop F5 and I
like Black's position very much so I
actually think that Bella has to go for
another line here she has to take on D5
and then she takes D4 she did in fact
play just the move that you recommended
for her C4 takes D5 on the board
maybe I should try and be mental coach
okay explain to us uh C4 takes D5 and
the resulting positions uh statistically
is white doing well black doing well
there are a lot of draws in this
variation so
um white is doing as well as black here
so after C takes D5 black takes on D4
the main move
This Night by far his Knight takes D4
okay and so here uh like they have uh
games between zingler and Ayana against
Carlson so Queen B6 wow yes yes is the
main line so you you can play E3 here
and the main
take here is e takes D5 so
Castle probably right yes castle and
Knight C6 that's how you challenge the
knights on D4 and with complicated play
I think that white has to take on C6
then beat xc6 then your Bishop can get
active on A6 so this is the resulting
position from the opening as you can see
white has a slight Edge but
with a very complex plate yeah I see uh
first of all we kind of went to an
isolated Queen Pond and then this
structure that you showed uh is is quite
common after an isolated Green Pond
which is interesting since a tarash
defense was played by
um Anna Anna that we might be having uh
the days the isolated Queen Pond days as
the players are catching up with your
suggestion I like that uh move
especially Queen B6 I thought that uh uh
um was a nice touch so and again Gary
Kasparov he liked it he liked the tarash
so uh probably he's a joke right and
telecarf and tell karpov uh C four takes
D5 again I'm just I'm just so curious
about this D4 business because uh Almera
was was showing as a variation where it
was a a complicated Pawn sacrifice oh
excuse me apologies Knight A6 that was
what she showed us Knight D2
uh E5 and she showed us castles and then
came the move Bishop F5 and I thought
that was sufficient compensation I won't
argue that the move I was going to uh
argue was Knight E
four so the idea is if you take take yes
I agree you could play Bishop H3 and I
was also about to agree
I could take a pawn and uh well let's
let's see the head to head uh between
these two players oh wow
wow okay harika uh adoption yes 16 euros
but 11 wins
that is uh with all forms of competition
by the way not just classical chess but
also rapid and Blitz but I gotta tell
you I mean we've been talking about
having analysis a rival that you really
really don't want to have Bella is like
why did you invite her to the Karen's
cup I mean good wow uh that's probably
one of the worst uh head-to-head matches
I've seen Almera so maybe a draw
actually would be well a very nice
result exactly or Bill but yes sir
analyzed a little bit to the position
and the move that you suggested 94
instead before yeah of course 94.
Bishop take C4 I think Bishop H3 the
move that you suggested is well is very
natural and well you deprive white from
Castle but then I thought okay what
about Bishop H7 thank you yes because
you can have this discovered check so
negative 4 Knight H3 but here blacks can
simply take on C5 while it still has an
extra pound but the Knight is very
misplaced on H3 and I think that after
Castle you can even play F5 here with a
spawn storm in the center okay I again I
would argue that you have a compensation
but it's not everybody's cup of tea that
their material down and having to prove
their compensation and that's where you
know my provocative
bravado if you will uh did cause I love
Flex position with Knight on C5 and
those Central pawns D4 E5 I'll take that
any day over upon
we're we're going to work on your
training we have a lot more work to do
let's go back to our Marquee matchup
between Arena and by the way she did did
play not the old conventional Bishop E7
move again that move was played uh like
the tabia nobody played uh C5 takes D4
at this moment they all Play Bishop E7
but this has become the wrinkle uh
Bishop C5 and again just to make a kind
of an echo comparison with harika's game
remember the Knight Z6 yeah yeah the
same Pawn structure we went from an
isolated Queen Pawn
that pawn structure to not a hanging
pond because they're not hanging until
they get to C5 right but I think Knight
B3 is a more common move here than it
takes or six absolutely Bishop B6 and
every fiber of my being wants to capture
this pond on D5 uh castles make sense
castles and then it was D4 right yeah
okay we'll keep an eye on this one and
uh Almera back over to you
back over to me yes tell us what you're
looking at uh share with our viewers
well I had an interesting thought first
of all in the opening when Elizabeth
especially when Alexandra played Bishop
B7 I just wanted to show you a small
trick maybe it will complete the Arsenal
of your tricks in this position because
he lives a bit played a very solid move
D3 why is that because even in this
position after Bishop B7 after C3 this
move is possible and we know that
Alexandra plays the Marshall so it
doesn't really matter that the bishop is
not on C but on B7 sometimes it even
favors black and I wanted to show you
this variation so let's say you will
take on B5 you will exchange and then
you will go for the pound
but here you can't actually take the
pawn on E5 like in Marshall and the
position on the long diagonal actually
changes everything because after 95 95
rookie 5
white is already lost and this might
come as a surprise you know to our
audience so after Knight F4 there is
absolutely no way for white to deal with
the
the king side and the pieces here
absolutely undeveloped so as you can see
it's almost plus three so because you
have to give up the spawn after D4 and
Knight G2 black has a very dangerous
attack so do not fall for this job
I wanted to show it and why actually
Elizabeth played D3 so the the position
looks more like
um
intentional yeah it's very conventional
yes sometimes yes it can result even
from the Joker piano but okay you have
the bishop on this on B7 so this is
still a very uh theoretical before it
was played this is the last move and
here you have a very standard plan plain
Knight G3 and then maybe H3 Bishop B3
and you can play D4 at the same time but
you can also Play Bishop G5 here
and I can see that recently one of the
French players also played this idea I
think that white is inspired by
jokopiana a lot of Bishop g5s has been
playing lately so after H6 Bishop H4 and
queen C7 with a very complicated
position nice and I also saw behind you
after before there is a game played by
Alexandra with the black pieces where
she defeated a grand master last year I
think yes she won with black exactly
it's like today I like I'm I'm my vision
is a bit blurred but I'm surprised how
nice I can see exactly Alexandra I think
it was a rapid game so she beat the
Grand Master Elias Miller smearing and
so let's have a look I think she played
Knight G3 no that was not the move
because I cannot get what the church
played Knight E3 in this position yes
it's a very unusual move so let's have a
look what if black plays Bishop faith
and that was played in the game and
Alexandra went for Knight to five
immediately so this could be achieved
also by 1995 so but I think that black
is better here like after D5 and
um
Alexander actually played this move with
with black you have to strike in the
center and after D5 he takes D5 Queen
takes D5 Bishop G5 and here what what do
you have maybe B3 yes that was played in
the game it's actually very important to
put this bishop to to use this
intermediate move B3 to put the bishop
on B1 and now maybe you can protect uh
the Alexander went actually for the most
dangerous continuation E4
um but I think you can even play Queen
C6 here so
black pieces look great yes yeah not
backing down from the fight I wanted to
just go to the game of Bella and harika
for a moment because they are following
that line you suggested Queen B6
and after Queen B6 E3 takes castles the
players are following a game
um Levon aronian a Magnus
uh up to well this moment is this on the
board I think
what I think I've already told us Irina
and Anna's game is following games
and by the way Irina did uh take on C6
she did and we have the same Pawn
structures as Bella and herika which I
was saying was like uh an echo uh when I
am playing on the white side of the
um tarash I do like these captures on C6
because I do find that a lot of players
really do play very well with isolated
Queen pawns it's like we kind of train
ourselves for these middle game
structures but a lot of players don't
um study the structures of C6 and D5 we
need a name for this plant exactly
they're not hanging pods what are the
exactly it was like the worst book ever
written as far as chess is concerned at
least it was Hans kamox Pond power and
chess
and the guy invented the most obscure
and crazy ways of naming Pawn structures
the Quant grip and all kinds of things
that you just sort of like get on I mean
the book I mean I think three people
bought the book I was one of them it was
terrible but yeah we need some
descriptive if this happens often yeah
exactly but Pond power and chess avoid
it as best you can
uh and well hanging ponds is a is a term
you'd like to use but we we're familiar
with hanging ponds when they're C55 not
on C6 and D5 maybe we'll have to reach
out to our audience for some assistance
on this uh we we we got a name for the
chess engine that uh
Almera has been
taming uh as best as she's able and you
can join our conversation uh stump the
panel how can they do that how can they
join the conversation I see uh you can
send us your tweets using hashtag
Karen's Cup right or you can contact
Lou's chess club on any social media
platform Instagram twitch YouTube
exactly and Sabina fuser is uh the
Master of Ceremonies on the social media
and we love your questions by the way uh
this will be our wow our final broadcast
yeah we're we're we're coming to a close
as uh the 2023 Karen's got been there
you see it uh thanks to our producers
for being
right there Johnny on the spot
ever missing a Beat
and once again yes thank you so much for
sending us your questions and your
comments at the San Luis chess club
channels yeah and I know Sabine has been
having a lot of fun behind the scenes
interviewing the players interviewing Us
by the way we don't really get a break
around here uh on break we get attacked
and uh we we've had a lot of fun so uh
we want to just give a big shout out to
yourselves and thank you for joining uh
the show tell us what what uh arena is
going to do now that she's defined the
pawn structure well if she follows
aronian Carlson game she'll play Quincy
2 here okay and that makes a a lot of
sense you've got to discovered threat
against the bishop and how did that game
continue Bishop B6 also logical and then
Knight A4 was played exactly kind of
well
I want to say you want to shut down this
bishop not necessarily capture it but
definitely control the pawn the square
and stop the pawn from advancing on C5
how did that game continue Bishop D7
okay after placement but necessary right
and at the same time
I think the structure the bishop wants
to go to A6 so Bishop to D7 yeah and B3
also logical I think white Bishop wants
to go to E3 and control the diagonal and
the black squares especially the C5
Square
yeah
rookie eight so first of all you're
getting out of the potential Tempo but
you're also putting your look your Rook
on the half open file the bottom plate
Bishop B2 here
the next two moves H5 H4 I don't know
well it's too deep for me well the the
the problem is
you're not going to break black pardon
me black is not going to be able to
break White's King Side by piece play
alone you might think to yourself oh I
could play Queen C8 and Bishop H3 you
might think to yourself I'm going to
play Knight E4
but okay you're not gonna you're not
going to destroy the king side
but if you play H5 follow it up with H4
you take on G3 now suddenly Knight E4
Knight G3 you you trade off the H pawns
and now suddenly Knight G4 Queen G5
Queen H5 mate right so you need to
create some looseness in the position so
H7 H5 but then the question is are you
going to follow what are you going to
follow up H3 do you want to play H4 G4
that's where that's where you need a lot
of experience of this H to B8 diagonal
here getting checkmated exactly exactly
but Almira has something to share with
us yes I actually wanted to explain you
the difference between the structure
that you just analyzed and the move
Knight T4 that Arena played in the game
because it might as well lead to the
transposition but a White's main idea
here after Bishop B6 is actually to take
on B6 and even though it changes the
structure I think that this line is very
concrete and they might follow the game
between Hikaru Nakamura and Daniel dubov
and I wanted to show you this line
because it's very sharp and maybe Anna
has an improvement along the way so
let's have a look here after Queen C2
then C5
so now the G5 pound is weakened a little
bit soft and delectable uh White plays
Bishop G5 here
Bishop B6 then E4
so D4
E5 yes this is a very sharp line H6 so
it takes F6 H takes G5 hanging takes on
D7 right seven King G7 taken EA A8 and
well that is the game so white actually
didn't take on A8 and I was thinking
what if we will take this exchange how
to assess this position I thought it
would be winning for white just like
winning not even
because I think after F4 for example
Black's King
I'm a material ahead in a in Black's
King strikes me is more vulnerable well
actually the computer suggests here the
move F3
just yes to keep everything safe but
after F4 Bishop H3 take the pawn
take the pawn you take the pawn okay
yeah I'm coming you know I'm coming
after the king aggressive but black is
already much better no
no much better a bit better but after a
rook takes if one well I can't believe
but probably you can't take the pound
honey too if this is possible no it does
not reject me right completely crazy and
after Queen F5 uh black can play Queen
is six and then after queen of six you
know the computer suggests King G8 G6
and let's see what is the Improvement
that is that's a crazy line I remember
uh one of my favorite moments in in the
game of chess I just played a really
really great game with Ben Larson where
we both had great uh opportunities at
one another and the game ended in a draw
and we were having a postmortem after
the game we were discussing the position
together and I put together what I
thought was an extraordinarily clear
rational piece of analysis to explain
why I was winning
bent at the end said nobody believes you
completely destroyed me like nobody how
that position where I'm an exchange up
and playing F4 isn't better for white
nobody believes the computer crazy I
wanted to turn our attention to the game
of Bella and arika again a very
important game for our second place uh
to determine who's who's going to get
second and it's kind of funny because
guess what happened we got the same
structure yet we don't know what to call
we're having a contest called name that
baby uh how would you name the C6 and D5
Pawn structures H5 that's just borrowing
a print page right from the game of
Arena and by the way I I really want to
emphasize that's precisely what
Grandmasters do they take a look at
approach is that you can take in one
particular variation and then they try
to apply them to other openings and h7h5
as we've just saw it kind of fits
perfectly in with what what uh black
wants to to do but now my question for
you Nasi is is this Pawn vulnerable
can I play the move Knight A4 and try to
uh munch I don't think you can take it
right away so let's say I play Queen C7
Queen C7 third Bishop D7 idea so uh if I
fall for it so to speak the idea is
after Bishop to D7 I have to go Rook C7
B6 or right Bishop D6 so I get two Pawns
but in the words of bent Larson nobody
believes me
I get two pawns so I've got these two so
on a good day I want to play B4
I could have played Bishop d8 maybe to
not give you ah okay okay okay then well
that's a very good point though right so
Bishop to d8 so you keep the A5 Pawn I
take once I take 55. so I got my two
pawns and two Bishops
I do have a compensation but not
necessarily an advantage something to
think about but uh I I saw that pawn and
I wanted to ask you if I could grab it
uh Almera Jump Right In is that
should Bella play Knight A4 and go for
the C6 Pawn well there have been a few
games in this variation and it went
exactly like this so Knight A4 okay
Queen C7
take on C6
Rook takes on C6 uh Bishop D7 Rook C7 of
course uh Bishop d8 is more precise to
protect the A5 Pawn then white went for
Rook D7
97 so if you take Bishop D5 then black
can develop the bishop on F6 okay and
this is a very balanced position
actually so all right yes the computer
analyzes uh evaluates its very balanced
but here I was thinking what if not
Queen C7 but Queen d8 maybe there is a
difference so if you take on C6 and then
Bishop G7 and what happens here but
after yes Queen C2 the queen retreats to
C2 and protects the Knight on A4 uh
black well has to continue on the king
side H4 was played by gookish recently
but I think this this is also a rapid
game so after age four uh White played
Bishop C3
uh more
let's say three USB ah it was a draw so
that's like the game ended here but so
that's what Bishop C3 there was a draw
with the computer I cannot find the
reasonable way to continue here I maybe
age three let's say Bishop F3
Queen E8 to attack the Knight on A4
um white is a bit better once again but
you have to play B3 here a little
awkward yeah yes so maybe now you can
create something
on the king side Play Bishop G4 take the
G4 Knight G4 and then bring your key in
a queen at some point to E4 but this is
all very elaborated for me I think that
if you don't know the plants in this
position then uh as black then you don't
go for this variation then you go for
Queen C7 and you take on C6 and you play
Bishop G7 little update we had those
moves actually in the game uh harika
played Queen C7 and Bella two con C6 so
she's going into that end game where she
sacrifices exchange for a bishop and two
pounds so Bishop D7 will follow so let's
let's have a look once again look she's
seven Bishop d8 Rook D7 Knight D7 can
you actually make another move in this
position uh then Bishop D5 can you wait
a little bit here
so we know that black is going to
activate the bishop on F6 can you play
Bishop C3 or it doesn't really matter it
matters a lot take the pawn
take the pawn bishop F6 Rook B1 and just
try to pretend that the A5 Pawn is an
issue I don't like
like very impressive okay yes okay
we have a cure
whoa whoa whoa whoa okay uh my Spidey
Sense oh right
we can play a B4 and create a password
I I wanna I wanna grab the third pawn
bishop F3 okay Bishop F3 give me that
guy and give me the other guy okay let's
have a oh no 95. life is a very
dangerous continuation so can you can
you actually take an H5 what does they
do I think
four yes ah no I wanted to I wanted to
make sure that I wouldn't be a pawn down
on I I wanted to make sure the queen
side were off so that I wouldn't lose an
ending we already have a lot of moves on
the board instead of taking Pawn on D5
played Rook D1 I think they're still
following some Theory Rook D1 yes I have
a few games left you correctly guessed
an alternative to Bishop D5 so Rook D1
and uh black played Knight B6 here so it
might be six Knight B6 then in one of
the games Bishop takes B6 or rugby six I
think Bishop B6 is well
Bishop D5 here of course not but then
rugby six
attacking the pound on B2 but then I I
thought that white wants to play Bishop
c3b here but they think after Bishop F6
we have to uh calculate this line like
Bishop A5 or B2 maybe bishop B4
um once again it seems to be very
balanced here but what if I I wouldn't
go for this line um after rugby set you
have to Knight B6 Rook B6 take
immediately on B4 take immediately on A5
on A5 here repeat two Bishop to B4 and
in this case you have to play rookie
eight your Bishop wouldn't be on F6 and
I could play Bishop takes D5 again I've
got the two pawns probably it's going to
be a draw but I don't think white takes
any risks
you should exchange the dark Square
Bishops with Bishop B7
I'm not sure if I didn't blunder
anything because that was my exactly but
I'm just saying that uh I don't think
that even in a case where you win the
pawn on A3 and I get rook and Bishop
versus two Rooks and I've got an upon
versus three the four versus three and
for Bella again that that that
head-to-head match-up that that was
harsh I mean the one other really really
harsh I remember uh setup was between
Magnus and Hikaru at one moment Magnus
had some ungodly score and the joke was
that Magnus was the number one player in
rated in the world because of his or
with the car
it was that bad mathematically it
shouldn't be that uh that that was funny
you mentioned that because right now
Magnus is first by raiding and hikaru's
number two and if you were look at their
head-to-head matchup I think Hikaru has
gotten a couple of wins under his belt
at long last but at one time it was like
seriously it was like 12 to nothing and
if you think about five rating points
at 60 rating points and there wasn't 60
rating points between the two of them
number one and number two should be more
or less balance right mathematically it
shouldn't be you know overwhelming in
the in the favor of Magnus by the way do
we have this position uh in the game
between
uh there's just Rook D1 on the board
move 21. oh just for D1 yes and played
Knight B6 yet okay so Knight B6 is the
uh theoretical move yes okay
in the game Irina and Anna uh it really
started with Knight A4 but then she
followed up with Queen C2 so they're
still following it transposed into
Iranian Carlson game I see
now here livon played Bishop D7 and Anna
is thinking
what what's it what what to play Bishop
to D7
um Bishop A6 is also playable
Bishop D7 yeah uh
that I guess that was the the question
did is the bishop better here or you
know like I'm assuming I want to play
Rook to D1 and E E3 and get off this
diagonal then the question is is your
Bishop better on D6 on A6 or D7 the
other thing that I found confounding was
this idea that after Bishop D7 I should
be capturing and you know helping the
structure this uh Daniel duboff line
that we were amazed with uh that's
counter-intuitive it's so counteractive
would you be taking that no I liked it
B3 and put in Bishop on E3 and taking C5
Square exactly exactly okay so classical
training
and of course in case you're just
joining us shame on you for being late
but we do have a champion even though we
call this the championship round Anna
zatonski secured clear first yesterday
yes after her two wins in a Russia
secured the first place and today
players are playing for their second
place exactly
and of course this is a fantastic
career-based result for Anna and one of
the things that comes with the title uh
clearance Cup champion is her first ever
Grand Master Norm so really uh well well
done and the Grand Master Norm of course
is the highest honor you can earn in
chess and she needs to get three of them
yes and you know she shares two more
that's it she'll be a Grandmaster
because she has already reached rating
required of a Grandmaster title she
needs two more norms and well uh Amira
you are saying that
that Anna has some favorite Heroes if
you will that she follows and
it was uh
Grant
who became a grand master uh yes later
in life yes and then Pierre crumling
right and also Monica surgical all of
these players are very accomplished
players they have so many titles but I
think what impressed Anna the most is
also that they managed to have a very
successful Sports career and also to
have children and it reminded me of a
very interesting testimony
made by Serena Williams and about how
difficult it is for for women actually
to get back to their level uh well after
having children and how hard does it
take to to train and to find motivation
once again and to well to get back to
the level they've been accustomed to the
level of play right
I I remember the first
the first time I played Pia kremling we
were playing in a tournament in in
Vancouver British Columbia together it
was an open event
and uh on a a a Pia pardon me Pia is a
tiny tot she's a small slip of a woman
and the pairing was Godzilla versus
Bambi
that was our badge and everybody was
wondering who's Bambi here
came to report I again I want to look at
the game with Bella for a second because
I understand this is a theoretical
dispute but I'm finding uh this end game
position
attractive for White
Once Again defend it if you will Nasi
for just a moment I'm going to take on
B6 how would you like to take uh with
the Rook with the Rook and let's say in
this case I wanted to play Bishop takes
B4
I take on B2 take on B2 Bishop to B4
okay Rook E8 let me take on D5 this time
with the Rook so I'm gonna meet a
checkup problem I do but we want to
check right now exactly
and then Bishop h
I thought even d8 was on C8 never mind
uh I call over the Arbiter and I said
she can't do that you can't play Bishop
H3 I I know the rule book so I have to
play H4 of them age four okay that's a
Pity because that actually breaks my I I
was hoping to have Bishop C4 Rook D7 in
my arsenal of goods so this causes me to
have a
an accident so I've got two ponds takes
takes King here well now I have F2 as a
Target I know I it's it's not what I
wanted uh frankly you you move H4 is
actually confounding that that's a Pity
okay what gets counter play here so why
that's why white doesn't have such
dominating well okay let me uh once
again press you on this particular
moment because now we know what I want
to do I want to play Rook takes D5 I
want to play Rook to D7 and Bishop to F5
maybe I will try to exchange the Bishops
Bishop E7 Bishop to E7
that's actually a very good move and
yeah I guess I'm not uh
uh again if my Pawn were on it you know
terminal trundle trundle you know and I
could get
my just G6 here maybe just G6
uh for Bella again she's she's had a
really really bad she's up against a
really really bad opponent for her
um and I think she's an ending where
she'll feel comfortable that maybe she's
where she might make her first drawing
yeah something like that where she could
do it okay we'll keep I'm sure the
engine doesn't think White's White's
going anywhere with this ending Almera
the Oracle says Bella's position
uh even well it's uh
still about equal I analyzed and I
checked the lines
you both of you are right I think the
last day you know
clearly in the case that we found the
consensus you know we're working well
together you know we we Clash we clash
and we come to a good conclusion but
I've noticed that in the opening uh line
uh Nazi didn't call you brilliant so you
know
some sign of the Rebellion I think right
well I'm slipping I'm slipping
well she is as strong as yours yeah you
are yes or no this is a rugby six so I
think that maybe should be five Rook B2
uh Bishop B4
I rotate here so after Rook D5
this is a very sound continuation yeah
H4 that's such a nice move gosh if you
didn't have H4 uh sorry I'm here just to
i i a quick question after yeah rookie a
rook D5
the second best yeah it would be one the
second best move for black In This
Moment is it's still Bishop B7 because
it's very important to trade the dark
Square Bishop because you're going to
capture the A3 pounds so as you can see
both moves they lead to a balanced
position so maybe H4 keeps uh keeps some
tension on the board actually
white might blunder somewhere down along
down the road but here your move I like
your move yes sir H4 but it's still not
sufficient Bishop is seven fake on the
seven uh rupee seven Bishop D5 I thought
I played Rook D5 but it doesn't really
matter I think overall we're probably
going to get what I don't like about uh
this position is that probably you can
get to the second rank yes can you bring
your Rook to to this C2 yeah I was
always going to be putting my Rook on F4
and Bishop on D5 right so if I go Bishop
E4 for example
to kind of stop you from playing Rook C2
and yeah this my I don't think that yeah
player can win this game so maybe Bella
was reminded by the way B4 on the Move
uh is on the board Bella played B4 uh
after Rook takes B6 B4 so there's still
a continue we have one game left and uh
this game went uh before eight takes
before Bishop B4 right and rookie eight
so the difference is actually the drug
is not on B2 in this position so maybe
this is uh an improvement yes a slight
Improvement uh over the variation that
we analyzed and now your movie as a rook
takes D5 but still a very important
resource in this position Bishop is
seven so for example if you play rookie
five here and so maybe you can play King
f8
ah but here what if you take on H5 now
yes but you will take your son before so
let's say it takes B4 Rook takes before
Oh okay maybe she can actually try and
play this position again I I don't see
any way that White's going to lose this
four and two uh position so for Bella
this is again because of her horrible
head-to-head score uh Bella's probably
happy to have a position where her
chances of losing are infinitesimal but
also harika's clock she has one hour and
21 minutes so she's an indication that
she's actually familiar with all of this
and let's just uh before we take a break
just step in on the game between good
night and Nana for a moment because
um there's a there's a move here yeah I
was about to say the last move most
especially was interesting again a 30
line opening it takes takes and normally
speaking white would have her king on
Castle than to be a knight on D7 so
there would be no tactic that we're
about to see Bishop A3 and that's a
little awkward white has just won the
two Bishops white would like to retain
the bishop but keeping it with Bishop C3
is awkward because he kind of stepping
in the way of the pond it is but that's
what Nana chose to do she played Bishop
C3 because she wants to maintain her two
Bishops it is awkward blocking the
opponents I know exactly yeah by the way
that I want to say that that's a
tactically alert move Bishop A3 because
you know it's very easy to fall asleep
on the position you go okay I'll just
play Knight D7 and you know you just
play all the standard moves without
noticing that you have this opportunity
again I'm just going to check in on
Elizabeth I again it's a kind of a rui
Lopez to gorin a little bit different
because of an anti-martial move order I
think black has an improvement over the
standard stuff where you might see a
Pawn on D4 and in the game of Arena
crash Bishop D7 was chosen and by the
way uh I want to say
in Anna's game she's been playing really
quickly hasn't she uh she's got her
first the last move she's spent about 18
minutes right before that time before
that she had hour 22 years wonderful as
we uh get ready for our first uh break
of the day we want to check in with our
dear friends over at Q Boutique and see
what the special is and it's a women's
jacket
this is the official women's jacket of
the 2023 Cairns cup chess tournament
crafted for 100 polyester featuring The
Karen's Cup logo on the left breast and
the St Louis chess club logo on the back
of the collar stay comfortable and
stylish while you make your next move
and we've seen the ladies really play
with those jackets they love them and
they're all only available at
cubeboutique St louis.com a shop cubic
for all of your chest needs and by the
way if you notice the necklaces that uh
well I'll see you are wearing
um I think that these were the drawing
of the Lots necklaces right you for the
pairing number very attractive
and for those of you uh watching uh hold
on because the cans cup is not finished
there's something you don't want to miss
today we're going to have a very special
guest joining us today Judith Polgar
woman in the history of the game she'll
be on a Skype call with us later today
so you don't want to miss that see on
the other side of the break
[Music]
in Forest Park
it's your move the muni premiere of
Chess plays the muni through July 11th
sponsored by St Louis chess club and the
World Chess Hall of Fame for
ticketsmuni.org
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why chess's
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impact of Chess from our three
floors showcasing the art culture and
history of the game the World Chess Hall
of Fame has something for everyone to
enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
I just caught Grandmaster Irina Crush
after a beautiful win today Irina how do
you feel another looking game yeah I
feel pretty good about this game I mean
I think it was
cleaner than I even expected right I
mean at some point I realized I was in
control but you know there were a few
moves in the middle again where I wasn't
so sure what was going on but it looks
like it was yeah like really clean from
start to finish and I think my even my
technique was quite decent
um in the end game like where I didn't
like take this Pawn on e4 right away or
it's kind of improved my Rooks and then
this move B4 which is pretty cool so
there were some nice touches in this
game and it feels good to get things
back on track I know you had the tough
middle of the tournament can you tell us
about how you're trying to get over
tough losses and you know find your
mindset to fight for the top for the
podium better yeah it's not it's not
easy uh you know I scored half out of
three like in the middle half middle
third I guess of the event and I
certainly felt very bad yesterday about
the kind of um
game that I lost to Alexandra
um you know because I felt like I had
such a comfortable position with very
little risk at all and and I managed to
just
you know play that out to a loss like
you know even had somebody I think so
many chances to defend better
um but anyway so having lost that I was
really quite dejected and I think the
one thing that I did I was talking to my
coach and I was saying like Okay what
should I do to feel better so I like
watched some Netflix show and he's like
no no certainly not you know go outside
go out you know you gotta get outside
and take a walk okay and you know and I
and I dragged myself out to Forest Park
um and it was very beautiful and I you
know somehow on that walk like
my mindset started to change you know
like instead of being this kind of
dejected
self-pitying thing it kind of like it
changed and um and I got back into my
fighter mode like and um and basically I
think that's the power of obedience you
know like that wasn't my idea but I did
what my coach said and I think it helped
me turn things around that's uh very
nice to say that because oftentimes it
is difficult for a lot of players to
come back some players don't come back
after a tough loss in a tournament and
then unfortunately if you put that in
your subconscious I think you really
won't come back and it's an important
lesson for a lot of people to
kind of find a way through it I usually
don't approach you after you lose
because I know I don't myself don't like
to be approached after losing a game but
um
I myself like I said it's bad so I
prefer not to be approached I think
everyone kind of needs to internalize
the the relationship with themselves
after the loss and then come back I mean
probably everyone at this tournament
takes losing very hard you know I think
so
um but you know I'm certainly one of
those people and it's not it's not so
easy when you start with two and a half
out of three and then go half out of
three and then to somehow find it in
yourself to like you know feel like
things can get better again you know but
we've had some Inspirations here you
know like Bella starting with half out
of two and then winning like three in a
row and she completely turned no I think
she started with zero zero out of two
zero yeah and now she's she won her
other fourth game or something four in a
row yeah so she yeah she just kind of
shows that it's possible you just gotta
sit down and play really you know that's
the thing it's not like I was you know
like I had some kind of mentality where
I must win like I don't know I just
played what the position allowed me to
do today it turned out that you know
that was enough and I was able to play a
decent game
that's that's great to hear it was a
nice game so we're yeah I think I'll be
pretty happy with this one you know it's
not that often that you can basically
make it so clean from start to finish
you know that's right I had another
question for you and that's regarding
your hobbies things that you like to do
I've heard you say that you like to do
various exercise uh or reading but
um I wanna I wanna hear it from you
again yeah wow definitely I like walking
you know I walk so much here like I
don't know at least an hour a day I kind
of have co-opted Yasser into that so you
know um he's been my companion for a lot
of these walks in the evening
um yeah definitely some kind of exercise
like sort of Pilates style things I like
to do reading yes lots of books learning
I guess my main interest in general my
main hobby is learning right so it could
be like one of the things that I
um put in a lot of time in recently is
Health you know nutrition Health like
all kinds of
you know exercise
um those things I've you know I've
watched a lot of podcasts on
and I think you mentioned to me one time
that you like to listen to podcasts
oftentimes as you're walking that way
you're killing two birds exactly
well now I listen to Yasser instead of
the podcast but you know what's funny I
just realized I want one I started a
podcast it's like um kind of like a
tutorial on Brazilian Jiu Jitsu you know
so I I'm looking at this and I'm like I
think I'm gonna need a partner you know
to practice these moves with
you're not out there
yeah it's kind of self-defense I mean I
think it'll be very interesting to learn
I think actually if you told me like the
things that I would like to spend more
time on it would be like dance and Hip
Hop I would like to go back to dance
lessons and um and learning yeah
okay now that you said dance and Hip Hop
I gotta ask you previously
comedies romance and Magic Begins
I don't want it to do that but like yeah
I'm not exactly a writer okay
[Music]
is
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back everyone we are in the
championship round yes round nine and
for those of us who are joining us late
we already have a champion we do Anna
zatonski won the tournament yesterday
it's definitely been the Anna zatonski
show as uh we're going to pick up the
action of the game between Bella and
harika and that game actually finished
in a repetition when we were when we had
left it we were looking at this ending
and we're saying is there chances for
white and well Aston answered they went
right down the variation we looked at
with the whole Rook takes H5 they got to
a position with of
two pawns and a bishop for an exchange
everything's on the same side and there
was a very quick repetition and for
Bella I think this was a relief it was
the only game she Drew in the tournament
but at the same time uh she was playing
against a person harika who has a really
big score against her
twin Bella what's in Australia and
Haruka Journal Valley and the other
three games Fierce clashes going on in
all of the games let's just jump to the
game
but before we jump to the game uh let's
jump to Amira who has a guest in studio
welcome Bella
so Billy has just joined us in the
studio Bella you made your first draw in
this tournament it's a very unusual
result for you Yes actually this so I
decided that maybe it's time to make a
one draw in the tournament so when
harika chose this variation actually I
played this a few weeks ago in Grand
Prime exactly in the same position yes
exactly just I was thinking to choose
this lane or line or not but then I
decided that's maybe it's good good
option because I I feel really tired and
especially after yesterday's game
we actually checked your head to head
score and did it have an influence on on
the variation because like you never won
against hurricane it seems
oh I did not
yet it's not easy to win I guess and
also she has a very wide opening Clipper
to her and to prepare it also not easy
so so how far did you know here uh
to this move Yes actually no water
Bishop thoughts
first line I think rookie 8 and Rook D5
yes we were trying to find some
Advantage maybe here for white but yes
this is a very forced line
[Music]
so now that the tournament is over uh
what is like your general impression
about the event oh I'm enjoying playing
here does not matter the results I love
playing in Saint Louis and I wanted to
say a big thank you to the organizers
first of all Mr and Mrs sinkfield uh
what they do for the development of the
chess it's incredible really and thank
you to all the staff who made this
tournament really great
so I'm really happy
to be here thank you fella and yes sir
Nazi well first of all uh
congratulations Bella I know for you it
was a real roller coaster ride you
started with those two losses but then
you snap back with the four wins just
tell us about your emotional up and down
uh for this event
you know yes it was
harmful to losses there's two games and
especially childish I lost first in my
my first game so
I was trying not to worry a lot about it
and to concentrate on my in other games
and it worked actually
lovely oh congratulations uh really a a
fine result and we hope you come back to
St Louis yeah
thank you for such fighting games and
showing that you can start badly and
then come back and win four games in a
row exactly the heart of a champion
right there
um just uh checking in on the game of uh
Nana and uh good night for a moment
because I'm looking you know when we
left it we were saying this bishop on C3
is really rather awkward and I'm now I'm
wondering what the heck am I supposed to
do with the bishop normally you would
like to keep it on the diagonal but if
you played a move like Rook B1 D4 you're
kind of crying here that Bishop this is
a sad Bishop on A1 truly and you might
even run into a bishop B4 check and a in
a queen and A5 so it really seems to me
like well you're gonna have to go with
your Bishop the other way which is well
not that great the bishop doesn't feel
itself very well on F5 F4 or G5
the bishop on A3 while it's doing an
important job of like squeezing why it's
Queen side do you do you consider that
it's a good Bishop overall I do in the
sense that uh I'm kind of happy it's
outside of the pawn structure like if I
buried the bishop and put it on f8 and I
would congratulate myself that the
bishop is defending my king here I would
try to make an argument that well uh I
want to deny uh White the two Bishops
and if for example I'll just make a move
excuse me just make a move and if white
refused the two Bishops or try to keep
the two Bishops I'd sit there and say oh
well look at me aren't I clever I'll
take advantage of the C3 square and uh
you know if I could trade the dark
Square Bishops I'd be happy as black
that's what it's quite rare to see black
Bishop dominate on the queen side like
this exactly in the game yeah with this
bishop on C3 sorry they wanted to also
of course once again congratulate our uh
Karen's Cup champion uh Anna zatonski
but she's not done yet she does not want
to finish the tournament on any sour
note we know she's already got a first
place but she's facing her longtime
rival uh Arena crash b2b3 the move that
you liked I didn't like Knight takes B6
I like B3 I like Bishop A3 I like E3
what is black supposed to do I think if
rookie eight we're still following
Iranian Carlson game and he should be
2h5 H4 is about as far as well that's
what we had looked at in the past
absolutely H5 and I I remember we were
looking at the possibility of H3 and H4
and G4 and what did we think about these
uh I was worried about the diagonal
Queen and bishop ever set up there right
but uh to not allow this live on plate H
for himself after H5
that's also interesting but it's a
little concession just give up the G4
Square big time right I mean your night
both night and Bishop can be very
annoying on G4 agreed with that
and Almera is uh with Shannon a very
special guest on the World Chess Hall of
Fame over to you Almira thank you yes
sir today we have a lot of special
guests I'm joined in the studio by
Shannon Bailey welcome Shannon thank you
for having me you are the chief Creator
at the World Chess Hall of Fame and you
have a brand new exhibit which is called
sound moves where chess meets music tell
us a little bit about this new
exhibition yeah so I co-curated the
exhibition with Bradley Bailey who's my
husband and he is a kind of a he's a
professor at St Louis University in art
history but he does a lot of research on
chess and art and Marcel Duchamp so he's
done other projects here at the hall of
fame and he's a big fan of music and and
if you know anything about the Hall of
Fame we are also huge fans of music so
it seemed like it was an appropriate
time to mix those two together and do an
exhibition
well actually I find this combination
very interesting because for example in
Paris we have a lot of exhibits where
there are a lot of paintings associated
with music so what is the connection
between chess and music there are so
many we probably could have done like
four or five shows on different aspects
of Chess and music but we have just some
things that are just fun where like
musicians love chess and they've
Incorporated uh chess into their music
videos or their album covers or their
music posters we look at things like you
know time in oven smyslav who were
fantastic musicians and fantastic chess
players and that they could have
excelled at either one of those Arenas
we kind of open up the show in a really
exciting way where you walk in and you
see Katy Perry's 2015 halftime show with
her Dark Horse video which is this
beautiful chess piece with a stage and
costumes that are chess pieces and we
have two of those at actual costumes
from the Super Bowl from the designer
Marina toyvena we have musical
instruments Jacqueline piadagorski who's
in the U.S Chess Hall of Fame her
bassoon and then we have Guido
vanderver's chess piano which is an
actual chess board that has all of the
piano percussive elements underneath so
you can play music by playing a chess
game
well Shannon I've been thinking you
worked on this exhibit and you've seen
it as a visitor so what is your personal
best my favorite oh my gosh that's
really hard
um
I it's it's not when you walk in and you
see the Katy Perry exhibit that's really
fun but I love the album covers you know
I grew up in the 70s and 80s when
everybody was had their album you know
their vinyl Collections and now all of
that's coming back so I kind of like
seeing those I like seeing the
photographic elements that we have in
the show where you have like David Bowie
playing chess or Frank Sinatra you know
playing chess with Walter Brown and you
know different bands that are out there
playing chess or you know using it for
for publicity shots it's fun also this
really sets the mood then yeah I know
the players uh well they have their
competition in the World Chess Hall of
Fame yes how how well do you feel about
it yeah the last couple of major
tournaments have been at the hall of
fame and I love that I love seeing the
players in the building I think it's
great that they're playing in our third
floor Gallery which is where we kind of
show off our chess history shows and
we've got our Hall of Fame interactive
screens that have the US and the World
Chess Hall of Fame and duckies in there
and I just think it's really great
because you know that a lot of these
players will be in the Hall of Fame
someday so it's it's great to have that
energy in the building and I know that
our visitors and our staff really love
it too
yes sir jump into the conversation yeah
first of all uh welcome Shannon hi yes
sir it's great to have you on the show
as always I'm very very excited because
of the Abba chess coming to the muni
before you became the curator were you
even aware that ABBA did an album called
chess by Tim Rice well I love music and
I definitely knew the song One One Night
in Bangkok
us
um I don't I my parents listened to Abba
when I was growing up but I don't think
I understood that they wrote a lot of
the music for Chess the musical and I'm
glad that Yasser brought that up because
we have some artifacts in the exhibition
related to several of the variations of
Chess the musical and in St Louis this
summer July 5th through the 11th at the
muni is Chess the musical The London
version of it will be played here and so
it's been a really great opportunity to
collaborate with an outstanding St Louis
institution and um you know we're always
looking for ways to get people
interested in chess that might not be
originally so we do things you know
through our exhibitions things like
music if you like music come on in and
you know you might like chess too so
it's it all works out well for us
thank you Shannon I think that's a great
chance for all of us to see the musical
chess on stage so well sees the
opportunity yes absolutely absolutely
awesome awesome looking forward to it
thank you Shannon and for all you do at
the World Chess Hall of Fame uh really
really big appreciation yeah thank you
and I'm so excited to see the Chess
music I know I know I'm looking forward
to you too let's turn our attention to
the game between Elizabeth and Alexandra
for just a moment because again the
players I want to say there are they
followed a very theoretically important
dispute in the rui Lopez this
anti-martial we just saw this move d4
takes on D4 G7 G6 now your first
instinct is to say Black's worse because
this Pawn on e4 is much more active
right and controlling more space than
this Pawn on D6 but that's not the end
of the story after this last move G7 G6
black is actually planning to play
Bishop G7 give black the freedom to play
D5 and 94 and all of her problems are
behind her so it really feels to me that
right here right now Elizabeth has to
come up with a plan over the next two or
three moves where she either keeps her
advantage or disappears completely I
don't even think white has an advantage
you don't I think black has already
equalized really and by the way the
clock times suggest what you've just
suggested that Alexandra feels herself
very comfortable why do you feel that
what what and if that's true by the way
where did white blow it
where did the advantage disappear so
because of the time you can tell that
Alexander is quite familiar with this
structure and position in general right
I think the move H3 15th move H3 was um
it may have been a novelty
h2h3 right here it looks like a very
standard boost
I think that shows that
that you call it a half of it like like
a wasted move maybe somewhat of a wasted
move but okay we'll get to then I've got
to play The Devil's Advocate good you
forced me to do it uh I like the bishop
on the long diagonal I think Bobby
Fischer in the 60 memorable games
whenever he got a position like this he
always gave himself an exclamation mark
for bringing his Bishop to F4 putting
immediate pressure on the D6 Pawn uh
I'll play B3 yeah G7 okay now again uh
my idea is I'm I'm desperately hoping
the pawn on D6 doesn't move so long as
the pawn on D6 stays there I think I can
build up behind E4 sorry I agree I think
the pawn on D60
problem black has precisely but I like
everything else about Black's position
the pieces I think are better developed
both Bishops even Knight on A5 is better
than Knight on G3 for example right it
doesn't have a really good Square okay
and here I was thinking maybe I can
maneuver pieces a little bit Knight D7
Knight D7 like it uh going trying to use
the E5 and uh
uh pardon me the E5 and C5 squares Queen
D2 connecting my Rooks aren't you proud
of me come on come on
[Laughter]
okay and now Knight to five Knight C5
Rook D1 uh so finally I feel like I
brought everybody to the party
all right and now I wish I could take on
Pawn but I can't do that let me show you
why
you can't do that Bishop takes D4 would
be egregious uh because oops don't even
think about giving away that Bishop yes
please
so maybe I need to improve my position
more because I don't see what your next
move is you did improve your position to
kind of the max yet
Rook C8 Rook maybe H5 H5 wow okay so
your E4 Pawn is not the best Knight on
G3 is not the best H5
H5
some people will call me heroic I'm not
sure uh I would like it
no this is this is like my worst attempt
ever at uh trying to keep the computer
go after your King right computers
didn't exist it could work right it
would scare you uh okay
H5 and that this takes some
responsibility I I had actually thought
much like yourself that my pieces have
kind of reached their maximum and I was
thinking that maybe you would find your
Rook a little bit more and I was
thinking I might have gone say King H2 I
was worried about the queen before here
ah that is of course
apologies I would have grabbed your pond
uh but your move Queen takes B4 was not
a threat so long as your Rook is on B8
because you do have Bishop takes but
okay H5 uh does suggest that you're
going to go after my after me my E4 Pawn
with the move H4
um and the only thing for black I
haven't found a good Square for my queen
I don't want to leave it on d8 but I'm
not sure where it's going to be the best
place yeah exactly okay just a second
hold on
um I'm beginning to consider the move
Queen takes B4
Bishop takes E4 with or without H4 by
the way you can make that decision later
and uh because my E4 Pawn was going to
be vulnerable to H4 I was just wondering
I think you should lose B3 Pawn here uh
oh you mean not hanging yet
take on default I was going to take on
B3 right away because they were pinned
but then my E4 was also hanging inside I
see
we think the position that Alexandra
and Elizabeth is playing is really
double edged Almera and we feel that who
has the advantage is going to be decided
within the next three four moves and
what does the engine think of this I
think it's a very sharp intense position
well yes I think that you've been doing
something with the engine because it's
agrees with you
the engines aren't bad in my my humble
opinion they're not bad
but I I don't know why he really doesn't
want to place the bishop on B2 he wants
to keep it on the 4ng5 but I wanted to
show you an interesting variation so
let's say if you play B3 here Bishop G7
Bishop B2 like you continued and again
in many pre of the previous lines that I
tried the computer actually tries to
remove D5 and after E5 he plays Knight
E4 exactly so I said to myself in why
doesn't well it offered this opportunity
here and here you have a very stunning
uh tactical idea Knight F5 so I wanted
to show you that this is actually the
idea as it is in the air in this
position so after Knight F5 let's say
how can you defend this position you
have rookie 6 maybe or a d takes C4 so
white sacrificed a piece and is playing
for initiative in this position a very
nice move Queen C1 wow so what computers
suggests here is actually that you are
playing with this Knight on A5 and yes
and then actually the material is more
or less equal here balanced and uh well
the you continue here after Knight H5 he
proposes 97 97 Queen H6 you know Knight
F5 Queen F4 uh with some crazy uh well
dynamical play
but you also have Rook E6 here let's say
a knight F5 rookie 6 which I think is a
more human move because you want to
bring the The Rook to G6 in some
variations but then Rook E3
he gives up this pound D4 so he closes
the diagonal Knight D4 and then brings
in this Knight because these things that
it's important yes to leave The Rook on
E6 and to bring the Knight on A5 into
play but the evaluation is still showing
that white is much better and how
dangerous this position is
for example then
um here after B3
He suggests this move immediately D5 so
he uses the the moment where the bishop
is still on C1 right and even though
like after G6 it's so natural to play
Bishop G7 but I think G6 is actually a
played also uh to take away the square
F5 so let's see uh B3 D5 what do you do
here E5 of course is a very natural move
and then the computer suggests Knight E4
and the position is still very balanced
but for me uh is this position is very
double edged and so after Bishop before
you protect the pawn and E5 uh you can
play Queen B6
with the ideas of playing Bishop C5 and
X train the Knight on D4 and the pawn
and F2 so
I can continue you know the just to show
you what is the spirit of the position
it's extremely sharp so now you can take
on V8 and I'm not sure that Elizabeth
well we'll go for this line and if
Alexander will sacrifice The Exchange
here because it's it looks very strange
to me so Queen B8 Ruby Queen G4 Bishop
G7 wow and the evaluation is still
balanced yes what it is after all of
that the the position's still balanced
D6 D5
again I played the move b2b3 and I again
Bobby Fischer and 60 memorable games
whenever he got these positions he gave
in he played Bishop F4 exclamation mark
you know in his humble opinion Bishop F4
and it's interesting that the engines of
today agree with him that Bishop F4 is
the right way to go by the way the
grantchester remember
continues and boy does it ever as Magnus
joins us Magnus will be back in just a
few weeks to play in the Super United
rapid Blitz in Zagreb Croatia and you're
gonna be back to join us too aren't you
for this event very excited it's I love
commentating on rapid and Blitz it's
it's fun well three words uh for that
[Music]
wonderful so what would happen after
instead of B3 the immediate Bishop F4
what does the engine give in that case
Almira just wanted to to say that what
how am I going to live without you guys
I lost my will to live after this
announcement right so let's have a look
um
Bishop F4 here but then I think black
has a few options because you can play
Rook C8 it's a very natural move so he
still plays B3 but for another reasons
of course he's taking the square away
from the Knight on A5 here so B3 Queen
B6
and then I was thinking what is computer
suggesting after Bishop E3 it does he
Retreat the queen or not but here he
once again suggest the move D5
yes it well I'm not sure that this is
very human but both of these players are
um relying on their calculation skills I
think Elizabeth and Alexandra they see
so much during the game so as Elizabeth
said during the interview uh her well
first intention is to play intuitively
but in this position you well you simply
can't do this so right you have to be
um
that you have to pay attention uh like
at everything here so as you can see the
the computer already thinks that black
is better here after D5 and there is no
Square probably where can you jump with
your knight here that's not it can you
sacrifice this would be a typical
sacrifice for some positions but I'm not
sure what happens after E5 through K5
and can you uh win something here but
then probably black will sacrifice The
Exchange on E3 and after rookie 3
because I don't think that white should
take us F takes a three because this
will weaken all the dark squares and
this diagonal so maybe even Bishop D6
here
um
I should explain the relation a little
bit of course because even though that
white is an exchange app the computer
yes thinks that black is much better if
not winning here so wow all the squares
their squares are weak weakened and the
main factor is also the bishop on C2 I
think that computer evaluates this
position
um especially because of this passive
Bishop
does make a very passive impression
doesn't it it's defending B3 but the
diagonal B1 to G6 is uh it's close it's
closed it's uh
a very very nice exchange sacrifice
thank you omera really really nice I
want to turn our attention to the game
of Nana for just a second because good
night she was very sharp I must say
again I I really like this move Bishop
A3 and it very much is dictating what
the consequences so you know I think a
lot of us would have said okay well
Bishop takes A3 Queen A5 check Queen D2
Queen takes A3 yeah you robbed me out of
my two Bishops but you know I'm kind of
happy I I've got my good light Square
Bishop I'm gonna go for C4 and so on and
now I said no no no I I want to keep the
two Bishops but after Bishop C3 C5
Bishop D2 D4 castles a very consequent
position is Arisen where gunite is
saying you know what I'm going for your
C3 Square what are you going to to do
about it she's really playing on the
black squares exactly and I think the
changing up the upon structure C5 D4 for
it was absolutely Justified right I
really like her minor pieces 96 Knight
on D5 the bishop can go to b2c3 right
yeah I mean and one of the things I
think would be an egregious positional
error for white you would like to play
this move E2 E4 but after you play the
move E4 you can almost hear the bishop
on G2 crying though Bishop on G2 is
saying why did you close off my diagonal
wouldn't you like to play the move E4 B3
back and Black's next moves might be
Knight C6 Knight before Bishop B2 and an
invasion what a way to win the A2 phone
hey look that's what I dreamed about you
know I wake up and I think to myself
okay I went upon
um here we go uh and Nana's got to fight
back here because uh if if black is
allowed to complete her development
unimped it things like Knight C6 and
Bishop B4 aren't it's not going White's
way what would you recommend for now I
would agree I think objectively why they
still find but I would much rather be
black here because my plan is clear
right but for white I'm not sure should
she keep playing E3 should she I was
gonna say maybe should she really be
trying to play for I would try E3 E3
Knight C6 right
easy move for me to play
I don't like to take on D4 because after
ctxd now black also gets the open C file
where they can put a little concierge
and more pressure on C2 and C3 agree so
I can't do that maybe after 96 uh move
my queen
E2 let's try it too
um
okay
yeah let's be as consequent as I
possibly can and suggest I want to trade
the dark Square Bishop so once again I'm
dreaming of the invasion of the C3
Square take on B4 take on B4 oh
you forced me to take it in an awkward
way right okay
and I'll take the pawn e takes the E
takes and
play Knight E2 Queen E3 okay I have to I
have to
um
very nice
yeah Knight takes E4 I'm going for the
Royal Fork I'm giving up the pawn on B7
but the head to head between these two
players actually really strongly in
paper not yes she has seven wins only
one loss and three draws
I'm surprised I've played so many times
because the different Generations right
but yeah that seven to one is pretty
decisive we'll keep an eye on this one
as we go back to our again uh Anna
satonski uh has won the event but she is
playing her
Nemesis rival I mean her her biggest
rival in uh women's chess in the United
States Arena Crush whenever these two
meet over the board we can expect a
great deal of fireworks I think annals
or Irina said it at some point that
they've been teammates for two decades
Rivals and teammates right they've been
applying for the US team whether it's
World Championship or Olympians or maybe
more than two decades exactly that's
really remarkable for me it was always
an awkward thing first of all I want to
say no no seriously I really really
enjoyed my Olympics I enjoyed
having all the people who were my rivals
Larry Christensen Nick defermi and John
Fedora as Joel Benjamin guys we always
buddy at heads with now suddenly I'm
rooting for them to win you know but it
is a very different Dynamic when you're
on the same team you know like suddenly
you start rooting for your your the guys
you were always trying to beat I wanted
to turn our attention to uh Irene and
Anna for just a moment because as we
have been describing up until this
moment the players have been following
um
I think it was Lavon didn't we said
Levon and Matthew yes but Queenie seven
was a deviation from the deviation and
an important one too because
essentially I really like magnus's plan
of uh including H7 H5 and uh Anna is a
shoot
viewed that idea altogether she was just
very happy to plant
the flag in the middle of the board a
great Outpost for the night but she
hasn't played H5 H4 she's kept it in her
pocket uh
break down the position for us what do
you think about her strategy this far I
think black has equalized comfortably
we do have two Bishops for white but I
like Black's uh Center The Pawn on D5
Knight on e4 evaluation is equal but
it's not completely balanced
so I think anything can happen still but
I would prefer to be black I like H5 H4
like you mentioned okay uh I like the
two Bishops uh and I do see from my
perspective uh that I have well I want
to say the possibility that of a
candidate outside past pawn and I think
a lot will be determined whether or not
I get to play the move F3 and E4 so I'm
going to pay play what I would say not a
bad move but a half move and I'll play
F3 and if I get you to go Knight F6 this
is what I'm more or less aspiring
towards uh opening up the position for
my two Bishops my Rook is already on D1
which is a kind of a a good thing right
and and I I feel like I can accelerate
uh the opening of the position if I get
in F3 E4 especially if you do something
really egregiously wrong the again let
me play a really bad move uh G5 and
again where I'm opening up the position
and I get to exploit a a terrible move
so I see F3 E4 on my agenda I also see
potential of A4 B4 A5 you have to give
me something concrete that you would
like to do as black
Rook C8 for example I'm just waiting
eight okay let's do it Rook to C8 and do
you want to follow that up with Bishop
G4 and and C5 or do you just I just want
to frame my Bishop to free the bishop so
that you um if you go to F5 or G4
depends where it's where your goes okay
um and chime in on this one uh Almera
because uh
I feel like as white I should be happy
but black structure is really solid
well you have to be happy by definition
I'm born to Be Alive glad glad to be
here uh yes sir I really loved your
proposal here because I'm I was
questioning irina's last move Rook afd1
so I wanted to understand here was the
move E4 F3 and followed up with the four
possible so let's say here how would you
react after my take C4 because rookie
one yes you can continue with rookie one
then maybe Queen C5 check okay there's a
very important intermediate check so
Queen C5 sadly yes Knight C5 and then
there is no way to continue here with uh
with white I don't think that white is
worse here because the pair of Bishop
guarantees them a lot of drawing chances
and at least the small compensation for
the pound but I'm not sure that Arena
wanted to enter this line that's why she
played uh Rook fd1 but then if I play H5
you no longer can proceed with this idea
by the way H5 on the board oh just
played that mile that was my last chance
to Glory
attempt to H5 so I think that white is
almost forced to play H4 here and that
now this Knight is very comfortably uh
placed on e4 because you you will never
be able to play F3 because of the Pawn
on G3 so can you uh try and play F3 here
this is your last chance so exactly what
is the difference uh because now we have
the pawn and H5 The Rook on D1 I was
thinking maybe the bishop on D7 is
hanging so at the end of the line you
can play B4 and when the bishop let's
say I just want to illustrate what I'm
saying uh what time exactly yes saying
this is the line uh sorry take on e4
take on e4 take on D7 yes
here yes and
yes you told me so this is absolutely
winning for white so The Rook fd1
actually prepares this idea so where can
you Retreat this night now can you go to
G5
let's say Knight G5 right and this will
come actually in handy because if you
play E4 take Stakes then you have a lot
of white uh light squares which are
weakness okay now you can even play
Bishop H3 so I think that after F3 here
you have to play Knight G5 and you can't
follow up with E4 but rookie one
looks very artificial you protect the
phone on an E3 and you can see with
Knight H3 uh King H1 I'm not really sure
that I want to take the Knight on H3 but
then I like the idea of playing Queen D6
and H4
this move H5 has really allowed some
nice play and uh I'm beginning to
understand more and more why white
played h2h4 in that stem game that we
were showing between Levon and Magnus so
H7 H5 h2h4 and well the knights now
feeling much more comfy on the E4 square
and make it very difficult for us to
play F3 and E4 feeling that Anna's got
to be satisfied with the outcome of the
opening and well looking good
and I love that Anna is so confident now
she plays moves like H5 fast yeah
exactly well uh it's like the success
breed success and she's done so well
she's now playing even with greater
confidence for those of you who are
joining us late apologies but uh we've
got all we we've got a in 10 minutes uh
for alarm uh check it out she's the
strongest female player Judith Polgar
will be joining us on the show
what questions might you ask and what
questions might our audience ask of
Judith
I'll have to think about it I have so
many questions you can join the
conversation you can have your we
compose your questions for Judith and
you can uh send us your question how do
the people send us their questions how
did they join the conversation you can
uh join us by sending
sending us questions using hashtag
Karen's Cup right or tagging San Luis
chess club on Facebook Instagram Twitter
Youtube and twitch okay I'm thinking in
my mind the question that I would like
to ask Judith is when will a woman win
the overall
World Chess Championship not just to
become a grand master not I mean Judith
of course became uh one of the top 10
players in the world played in the
candidates defeated Gary Kasparov while
he was world champion basically
beat everybody at the very very elite
levels uh and competed very successfully
with men but never won the World
Championship herself and I think that's
uh that's a question I'd really like to
ask her and see what her answer might be
I'm also curious I've noticed recently
she's been doing a lot of commentary yes
and I want to ask her how does she like
this new role exactly
player to commentator I'm sure
I'm going to guess her answer less
stressful
we can we can sacrifice your pieces a
lot easier than sacrificing our own
pieces and if we're wrong
well that's too bad
we gotta lose any rating points for
being wrong uh keeping an eye on that
one but also for Elizabeth uh check it
out she did play Bobby Fisher's and the
engines first move too Bishop F4 and
knight uh Joe I think were we on Rook C8
and queen B6 the engines
I think so yes yes that was what engines
liked but 97. that was also a move that
you liked too why although it was when
white was playing B3 and fiancado in the
bishop that is true yeah I was just
Knight on F6 is it's a fine piece but I
want the bishop on G7 to be completely
open right and use my knight to go to C5
and attack E4 from there
when when the Knight is on C5 again
you're attacking E4 but like you say
you're leaving the diagonal
um G7 open the reason I had played b2b3
at the start I didn't know if my Bishop
was better on B
uh two or F4 but I'm pretty certain I
want to play Queen D2 I'm pretty certain
that the queen is well placed there when
I play Rook D1 the problem is I'm
looking at a knight C4 and I'm like well
you know am I comfy you know walking
into that Tempo that was why I played B3
earlier uh but in this current uh
position uh Almera chime in Bishop F4
Knight D7 again I'm I'm still of the
opinion that the next two three moves
will Define who's in the driver's seat
uh you're absolutely right yes sir once
again but I wanted to show you could you
repeat that could you repeat yourself
just a second I I think I'm getting
really used to this go on no go ahead
sorry Evan so um but here I um I've
noticed that you know that now after the
night retreated to D7 uh the queen no
longer protects the pawn on D6 so how do
you deal with the bishop and E4
attacking the pound on D6 and actually
let's say uh what if I play your move B3
here because
I explained previously that Black's idea
in many positions is to exchange
actually this Knight against this night
uh on A5 but you cannot play Knight C6
here because you would simply take on C6
take on six six and take on G6 boy would
I ever but the computer suggests that
first you play Bishop G7 here so he
gives this phone away he just ignores
the threat yes and this is very
surprising for me once again he ignores
the thread so and if you take on D6 and
attacking also depend on before Rook C8
and the follow-up is to play an idea of
five here so let's suggest a move which
is more human so we should understand
how how white can continue here so what
is the threat let's say well Bishop
takes D4 and Rook takes C2 is scary
right yes so that's why Rook C1 right
and here Queen B6 so attacking the
bishop on D6 and the Knight on D4 so
actually we cannot play E5 in this
position and close everything because I
will simply take 95 and White's position
is collapsing correct that's why the
computer suggest in the previous line
and even here they move Knight df5 so I
told you this is in the air this is the
tune of today's game a knight F5
sacrifice
and once again the position is rather
balanced even though white has just
sacrificed the piece so what is the
follow-up here you notice that the night
is attacking the bishop on G7 on in
every line so before we had we Queen C1
but here we have Queen D2 exactly the
game continues actually uh I don't know
who is better here it actually depends I
think who is in better shape and who is
ready to calculate everything well white
shirt feels like they're in a
rambunctious mood and that night on F5
certainly has got my attention and uh
just not in the time actually Elizabeth
uh even though it's a it comes from a
theoretical position she's really played
it slowly in these last five ten moves
yes an hour for she has uh 24 minutes
left for 20 moves but Alexander has a
full hour
I found that move uh
absurdly interesting the idea of just
giving away the D6 Pawn Knight D7 b2b3
Bishop G7 take my Pawn
like Bishop takes Rook C8 and now
because this bishop is going to be hit
this Knight is under a fire The Rook on
seats Pardon Me The Rook on C8 hits the
bishop on C2 it's time to give away a
knight
and it's time to give away a rook
and well let's say hello to Judith
Polgar and welcome her to the show hello
Judith hi Judith
how are you good how are you
I'm fine thank you it's late in Budapest
that was where I was going to ask are
you home after Norway
yeah yeah I came home for nearly two
days I'm home there were a lot of
excitement over there it feels like
you're in a Auto
well you're correct
I'm writing with you in the auto what's
the what's going on
your show and I couldn't change my plans
so now I'm here in the car right
well thank you so much for making time
to join us have you been following the
Karen's cup
well to tell you the truth only so very
few shots but not really yeah you've
just done commentary duties yourself in
Norway stabbinger and that was a
fantastic tournament I mean wow uh great
great stuff Judith uh tell us a bit
about your experience in Norway
oh wow in Norway it was an amazing event
I must say it was uh quite incredible to
see the different generation of clash
and I think uh well I found it very
amazing to see them how to see the old
timers kind of Mama jarov and
and see Magnus he's uh he is also from
the oldies right
well I don't want to think of Magnus as
the oldies but go on
is old man but
she also good cash how he's his style
he's studying and following his Focus to
follow Carolina playing incredibly well
the tournament he was completely deserve
to be the winner I must say he made this
incredible game against firoza
sacrificing a rook but I have to admit
that Nakamura the number one streamer he
was the most amazing collecting the full
point in the last round versus Carolina
and won the tournament
and actually speaking of all this we
have a tournament winner already and it
was Anna zatonski who won the tournament
and she said in the interview that she
wanted to prove that age is just a
number would you agree with that
generally saying yes
but I think age is is not stopping you
perform very well because of your age
it's more of you can make a lot of
profit out of your experience at the
same time sometimes age makes it
difficult to not motivate yourself I
believe and look for new challenges we
are which you're very eager to
accomplish
interesting Judith I had a question that
I've been wanting to ask you for quite
some time when will a woman win the
World Chess Championship title overall
to tell you
either to the most
[Music]
going to see more ladies in the top 10
or 20 in the world all right full
Champion you have to be a very special
character whether you're a lady man
because let's face it we didn't have so
many chess uh world champions uh in open
section either right you have to have
extremely
uh detailed worked out skills to be able
to become a world champion
like five women in the top 20 then see
one become world champion okay so when
are we gonna see five women in the top
20.
um I think it will be like 10 years
possibly
but there has to be some changes and I
think it goes back to
General the house Society is taking
girls when they want to play chess
how secure the environment is how much
the
parents are supportive on their success
how much a coach dealing with their
talents whether they are supporting and
encouraging them to become the best
chess players they can or they want to
challenge them and Inspire them only in
the women's section
fair fair enough uh before we let you go
one more question what's what are you up
to what's coming up next for you
well I have some big projects going on
I'm working on a book series for
children with based on my method and I'm
going to be traveling again in two weeks
in first half of July to Chile to make
some chess promotion tour Chile wow
wonderful well thank you thank you for
joining us in your car ride and uh
giving us vertigo and emotion sickness
uh thank you Judith thank you so much
okay bye bye bye as Judith Polgar going
through the streets of Budapest and who
is she well if you don't know Julie
Parker you don't know chess right yes
exactly she became a Grandmaster at age
15. highest rated female player of all
time defeated 11 world champions
including Gary Kasparov and Magnus
Carlson wow that says a lot right there
and in 2021 she was inducted in the
World Chess Hall of Fame absolutely and
for me a memory of Judith will I'll
never lose this memory I I think it was
2002 Moscow it was Russia versus the
rest of the world I was the team captain
for the rest of the world team
apparently the organizers had scraped
the bottom of the barrel and they came
down to my list at the end oh everybody
had declined before they invited me and
I had Reserve players on the team so I
was bringing in and out players and
stuff like this and I said to Judith
Judith you're resting
these rounds and you're going to play
Gary Kasparov in the evening round
she wanted to punch me oh she was
Furious why do I have to rest I can play
Gary no no no work with Victor korchnoy
he was our chess coach by the way for
the rest of the world team worked with
Victor kortner come come rest at your
game with Gary oh she was mad she came
to the game and destroyed Gary just
crushed him off the board and I was
standing behind her because as a captain
I had to sign the official result right
thing
she turned she looked at me she jumped
in my arms and I'm holding her and she's
looking at me and she says I'm back in
business right
wow talk about a fierce competitor she
did not want to get taken out of the
lineup and uh yeah I said yeah most
players not just women but most players
would be terrified to play Gary exactly
exactly no no no no no no Judith was
like I'm back in business uh what do you
have for us uh in the game between
Elizabeth and Alexandra Elizabeth's got
to speed up her or her tempo of play Yes
actually
um one thought yesterday I was inspired
by your story and I thought that this is
an idea for an event let's say because
the United States of America is the
number one Federation in the world for
men and one of the leading federations
for women so World against the United
States of America I think that's an now
you can be Captain once again
I'm not sure we're anxious to take on
the whole world I mean I think we have
uh we have a troubles enough at the
Olympics uh I mean my goodness but thank
you for the uh inspiration uh something
to think about go ahead please so
Elizabeth just played uh one and uh here
for example after Bishop G7 we can
transpose to the line which started with
Bishop G7 uh Rook C1
but here why it doesn't take the pound
and you should probably play Queen D2
here because I think that if you make
some move
um which doesn't alter the position
let's say I will play the move Knight E5
then you want to play Bishop H6 right so
the idea behind the move Queen the two
is to exchange those Bishops so black
here should reply after uh Queen D2
with the queen B6 and that's the line
that we've been analyzing so here Bishop
E3
and the move D5 actually here in this
position doesn't work because I need to
understand why because the lines are
incredibly complicated compared to the
lines before so let's say Knight df5
here and you have the intermediate move
Bishop C3 this is very complicated and
once again Elizabeth doesn't have enough
time I think to enter all those lines so
but if
Bishop B3 D5 Knight
there's another move suggested by the
computer F4 here
I have to understand what is the idea
behind the move F4 yes so the Knight on
D7 is hang in there let's say if we take
only four then an idea five and
after Bishop C3 you can take on G7 so
that's the difference yes between the
previous line but F4 of course is played
with the idea uh sorry a four is played
with the idea of plane
um E5 on the next move so how can you
parry this idea this is a very strong
move so I like it very much much more
than Knight D5 F4 and there is no way
for you to stop E5 actually here what do
you think I see it's a very impressive
for me F4 is a real real visual move uh
to uh quote Mickey Adams of the UK a
very visual move but you do want to play
E5 and as we get prepared for a break
just to remind everybody uh our
standings uh once again I mean we can't
say it all more often enough Anna
zutanski as won the tournament and we
have one drop thus far we have one drop
between hot and shrilli and Jonah Valley
also I forgot to mention that it's a buy
round today for jeans to my league the
rest of the three games are still going
as players are fighting for that second
place
but we do have a champion Anna zatonsky
winning the 2023 Karen's cup taking home
45 000 and her first GM Norm I know it's
just such an exciting moment uh for Anna
congratulations most certainly and as we
go to a break we had an interview with
Arena Crush previously some audio
problems apologies for that we'll reply
the whole interview we hope you enjoy it
here it comes
foreign
[Music]
premiere of Chess plays the muni through
July 11th sponsored by St Louis chess
club and the World Chess Hall of Fame
for ticketsmuni.org
the World Chess Hall of Fame located in
the heart of St Louis's historic Central
West End want to know why Jess has
intrigued people around the world for
nearly 1500 years stop by and learn
about the impacts of Chess from our
three floors showcasing the art culture
and history of the games the World Chess
Hall of Fame has something for everyone
to enjoy for more information on current
exhibits please visit worldchess hof.org
thank you
I just caught Grandmaster Irina Crush
after a beautiful win today Irina how do
you feel another looking game yeah I
feel pretty good about this game I mean
I think it was
cleaner than I even expected right I
mean at some point I realized I was in
control but you know there were a few
moves in the middle game where I wasn't
so sure what was going on but it looks
like it was yeah like really clean from
start to finish and I think my even my
technique was quite decent
um in the end game like where I didn't
like take this Pawn on e4 right away or
it's kind of improved my Rooks and then
this move V4 which is pretty cool so
there were some nice touches in this
game and it feels good to get things
back on track I know you had a tough
middle of the tournament can you tell us
about how you're trying to get over
tough losses and you know find your
mindset to fight
yeah it's not it's not easy uh you know
I scored half out of three like in the
middle half middle third I guess of the
event and I certainly felt very bad
yesterday about the kind of um
game that I lost to Alexandra
um you know because I felt like I had
such a comfortable position with very
little risk at all and and I managed to
just
you know play that out to a loss like
you know even had somebody I think so
many chances to defend better
um but anyway so having lost that I was
really quite dejected and I think the
one thing that I did I was talking to my
coach and I was saying like Okay what
should I do to feel better so I like
watched some Netflix show and he's like
no no certainly not you know go outside
go out you know you gotta get outside
and take a walk okay and you know and I
and I dragged myself out to Forest Park
um and it was very beautiful and I you
know somehow on that walk like
my mindset started to change you know
like instead of being this kind of
dejected
self-pitying thing it kind of like it
changed and um and I got back into my
fighter mode like and
um and basically I think that's the
power of obedience you know like that
wasn't my idea but I did what my coach
said and I think it helped me turn
things around that's uh very nice to say
that because oftentimes it is difficult
for a lot of players to come back some
players don't come back after a tough
loss in a tournament and then
unfortunately if you put that in your
subconscious I think you really won't
come back and it's an important lesson
for a lot of people to
kind of find a way through it I usually
don't approach you after you lose
because I know I don't myself don't like
to be approached after losing a game but
um
I myself like I said it's bad so I
prefer not to be approached I think
everyone kind of needs to internalize
the the relationship with themselves
after the loss and then come back I mean
probably everyone at this tournament
takes losing very hard you know I think
so
um but you know I'm certainly one of
those people and it's not it's not so
easy when you start with two and a half
out of three and then go half out of
three and then to somehow find it in
yourself to like you know feel like
things can get better again you know but
we've had some Inspirations here you
know like Bella starting with half out
of two and then winning like three in a
row and she completely turned no I think
she started with zero zero out of two
zero yeah and now she's she won her
other fourth game or something four in a
row yeah so she yeah she just kind of
shows that it's possible you just gotta
sit down and play really you know that's
the thing it's not like I was you know
like I had some kind of mentality where
I must win like I don't know I just
played what the position allowed me to
do today it turned out that you know
that was enough and I was able to play a
decent game
that's that's great to hear it was a
nice game so we're yeah I think I'll be
pretty happy with this one you know it's
not that often that you can basically
make it so clean from start to finish
you know
that's right
I had another question for you and
that's regarding your hobbies things
that you like to do I've heard you say
that you like to do various exercise uh
or reading but I wanna I wanna hear it
from you again yeah wow definitely I
like walking you know I walk so much
here like I don't know at least an hour
a day I kind of have co-opted Yasser
into that so you know um he's been my
companion for a lot of these walks in
the evening
um yeah definitely some kind of exercise
like sort of Pilates style things I like
to do reading yes lots of books learning
I guess my main interest in general my
main hobby is learning right so it could
be like one of the things that I
um put in a lot of time in recently is
Health you know nutrition Health like
all kinds of
exercise
um those things I've you know I've
watched a lot of podcasts on
and I think you mentioned to me one time
that you like to listen to podcasts
oftentimes as you're walking that way
you're killing two birds exactly
well now I listen to Yasser instead of
the podcast but you know what's funny I
just realized I won one I started a
podcast it's like um kind of like a
tutorial on Brazilian Jiu Jitsu you know
so I I'm looking at this and I'm like I
think I'm going to need a partner you
know to practice these moves with
them
yeah it's kind of self-defense I mean I
think that would be very interesting to
learn I think actually if you told me
like the things that I would like to
spend more time on it would be like
dance and Hip Hop I would like to go
back to dance lessons and um and
learning yeah to just who sounds pretty
good to me okay now that you said dance
and Hip Hop I gotta ask you I believe
you did one time
uh a recording of uh rap yeah song are
you still into would you be doing
something like that yeah I'm like no
well well if you want to write me a rap
lyrics you know
um we we can do that again like I mean
I'd be up for it you know if someone
wanted to do that but like yeah I'm not
exactly a writer uh you know Lyricist
myself okay but you would sing it yeah
okay something else for those of you who
haven't checked your wrap guys give me
the song to do it too and I will do my
best
okay that's great is there anything else
you would like to let us know about
yourself you're gonna have something
that people don't know are
already you were kind of famous and
popular but maybe there's still
something you'd like people to to know
about yourself oh to know about myself
wow you know
question there's a lot that's like what
do I want to reveal you know okay but
you know just come up with some
questions guys and I will answer them
all right so let's let's do it that way
let's not you know let's make people
work for it yeah I can't give up
everything right away right yes I agree
I agree right now well as always it's a
pleasure talking to you I'm gonna let
you got two more games you gotta focus
on so I'm Gonna Let You Go yeah today
Saturday so I'm going to church or
church first church first then hopefully
some walk and preparation for the last
two years good luck here right now thank
you
the St Louis chess club Scholastic
program brings the educational value of
Chess to kids and schools across the St
Louis area active in over 100 schools
throughout the St Louis city and county
the St Louis chess club has been able to
reach over 85 000 students in both in
school and after school programs we view
chess as a valuable educational tool
learn more about our Scholastic
programming by visiting
stlouischessclub.org education
[Music]
thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomed chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
hosting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that also include over 2
000 chess lectures for anyone to enjoy
become a member and enjoy perks such as
free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischessclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
foreign
welcome back everyone results so far in
the last round we have one drop between
hot and Ash really and drona Valley and
a buy round for zhensai afternoon Lake
absolutely and the action is really
intense as I'm looking at this big fight
for the second place between Elizabeth
and Alexandra I find these uh games
these positions of the I want to say uh
rui Lopez to be the most classical and
important kind of games of modern chess
because if you can't get an edge on the
white side of the rule of past just may
be a draw uh when we left it we have
just left it in this position with after
the move Rook C1 Knight C6 was played
that that moved Bishop G7 wow I just
found that to be such a confounding and
intriguing move Knight C6 Knight takes
C6 listen to mention that since uh
Alexander played G6 many many moves ago
we still haven't seen Bishop G7 on the
board right you play G6 you kind of
think Bishop U7 is going to come next
but uh kind of uh
maybe right 96 Knight take C6 Rook takes
C6 Queen D2 Queen A5 that makes it kind
of a strange impression I understand
we're defending the pawn on B4 maybe on
a good day we get to post up The Rook on
uh C3 but simultaneous to all of that
the queen is really well offsides it's
not uh there I also would prefer Bishop
well you definitely want that Bishop G7
and Bishop C3 I get that that's on your
agenda
um
what's your take and uh on the business
I think balanced it is balanced but
what's gonna affect this game is the
time because position is quite
complicated right and Elizabeth is down
to her 20 minutes right Alexandra has
twice as much time 41 minutes they still
have 17 moves to make that's a lot of
moves 17 moves in this position was just
20 minutes on the clock that's
very difficult uh some time management
issues we might have to talk about there
uh for me I look at this position again
the the street strategical side of me
takes over and I say you know what's my
good piece what's my bad piece and I go
through it all and I see this bishop on
C2 as the bad piece and I really want to
play the move Bishop to D3 and Bishop to
C4 for on the C2 Square my Bishop's
doing not a zero nothing it's defending
the pawns on B3 and E4 as you were
saying that yes usually it's the
commentator's curse in this case yay for
the commentators the bishop comes to C4
and it's a completely different Vista I
get to look at F7 that's a very handsome
Pond and it's much more aggressive place
so I love this move Bishop D3 same move
faster was better
think we're a little bit behind on this
board oh yeah the light board I think I
have the live board where you see
analysis that's the light board and here
you see from the video cam
um we've admired the fact that Alexandra
hasn't played the bishop G7 move for a
long time
when is it going to come she could play
it now but I also like your move Rook C3
right now in this right now just posting
up okay well I see that you're I don't
want to take on B3 I I'd rather not see
a passer arrive on my doorstep so let's
say I played the move Bishop C4
okay and
and five trying to attack your Bishop
that's a that's a very
gosh darn it I was I was prepared to
give up my darksword Bishop after the
move Knight E5 but this move Knight B6
uh okay I will end up having to whoa uh
did not see that coming Alexandra with
40 minutes played D six she would love
to open up h1a8 diagonal because in that
case her Bishop on B7 that doesn't look
so great right now would become a
monster especially with the battery of
the queen and the bishop
hello hello uh chat mate is on your
agenda so wait a minute though I one of
the one of the things I was regretting
uh if we just go back one move here so
I'm sitting there saying I'm I'm happy
happy happy happy not happy so that move
I get Bishop D3 also not happy right but
I see the move D5 I understood exactly
what you're saying you know you're
trying to make a life for that piece but
you may end up making life for my knight
on G3 my knight lands on F6 it could go
Splat right well there are some topics
let's go let's go I was not expecting
that Bishop C4 so uh again take the
bishop okay take the knight uh Rook E7
you're a party pooper
Rook E7
oops sorry Rook E7 I thought I wrongly
thought that I was gaining an important
Tempo against your Bishop apologies that
just well that put the kibosh on that
idea we need something uh more Splendid
in that case why'd you just trade pieces
here Rook C6 and Bishop H6
Roxy
wow I don't know uh
okay Bishop Rook C6 and Bishop so is
this idea somehow related to some kind
of a an attack against the king I'm
hoping if I get Queen on H6 I might have
some chances on the king side well the
problem I'm having uh I see is uh
yeah that that desirable Bishop C4 I
just don't get a chance to play it
um yes sir I have a marvelous positional
idea for you as usual you will
completely suicidal with your Bishop C4
what do you mean I mean I thought it was
inspired
and uh I think that uh Nas is a proposal
Rook C6 leads actually to an equal
position but what I loved about the move
which is suggested by the computer here
is that uh is the positional idea behind
it actually you don't have to exchange
anything you have to keep all the pieces
on the board and here uh the move Rook
cd1 is actually
well amazing it's a marvelous uh
proposal by the computer because let's
say one of the lines that He suggests is
Knight F6 and if you play E5 then you go
back to Knight D7 then you know that
there is already something wrong with
the position so if you exchange on C6
you
um make Black's task a bit easier here
but rook cd1 and well the best move in
this position is probably Rook C to C8
that's not such an easy move to find yes
exactly and here you can continue with
Bishop H6
because if you take on H6 then Queen
take H6 and okay look at your pieces
every piece is white pieces pieces
completely active so here Knight f8 you
know I was thinking how to continue here
with white and as usual this move H4 is
well it's very useful and you keep that
time going
uh intriguing line I must say that for
me the move Rook c1d1 doesn't come easy
to my mind because
I'm I'm afraid of Rook C3 you mentioned
Rook C8 but we were thinking that the
Rook was going to come to the C3 Square
post up maybe Knight C5 and after
am I supposed to play Bishop H6 and
ignore my hanging Queen side no actually
now the rookon C3 is a bit vulnerable so
you can take on D5 Queen takes D5 well
Queen takes D5 is losing after Bishop B4
Bishop yes and while the computer is
using this battery and especially the
fact that the Rook is on D1 right now so
there's absolutely nothing that you can
do so you'll take on the two you should
take Bishop takes of course and now like
everything is every possible piece is
hanging the bishop is hanging so if you
take Bishop B4 then I can even take the
Rook yes Rook C3 and then I'll take so
you cannot take Queen D5 here I think
that's a very important point in this
position so maybe you should trade
because the Rook is hanging 98 so okay
Queenie one and once again if Queen G5
now you have this x-ray with the Rook on
the event so maybe bishop D5 here but
then the Knight comes to E4 you know
attacking the The Rook on C3 and I in
all these squares so what can you do
here give me the pawn yes
it would be three if I'm going to go
down I'm going to go down with a full
tummy yes you're going down in style in
style so okay let's try Bishop B5 and
that's it by the way Bishop B5 Bishop B5
okay that's also a visual move Bishop B5
in that position a stunner Rook c2d1 is
a positional brilliancy but it's very
hard to find and instead Elizabeth took
on C6 I think she's trying to simplify
the position considering her time
situation she only has 16 minutes left
um okay she's played Rook take C6 Bishop
takes C6 and she's combined it with E5
so she is uh enjoining her opponent go
ahead play Knight C5 and or wait a
minute isn't this pesky week I'm not
sure about if I would suggesting Bishop
H6 just to exchange more pieces right to
get rid of this but E4 even I'd don't
like that move because I really don't
see her follow-up to either Knight C5 or
Bishop G7 Knight to five looks very
logical maybe even follow up with 96
afterwards defense B3 that's a nice
blockading Square it also uh I'm
I'd love to ask the question
how am I defending the E5 Pawn Maybe
I'm not defending it instead I'm going
for counter play Rook C1 uh-huh Rook C1
okay I
guessing I'm dropping back maybe E6 and
babe
or Bishop C7 because you're the queen is
kind of Trapped uh sure uh Bishop C3 you
got takes
um okay game suddenly got very sharp uh
Almera jump in tell us what's uh what
the Oracle thinks well actually oh sorry
you're in another another game it's a
it's a very important moment because I
just noticed and it's a very simple move
that Irina can play Queen Z4 and win a
pound immediately so uh the pawn the
mate of course on G7 is a real threat
here but there is a Pawn on B6 which is
not protected so it's a double attack
what can Anna do here I thought maybe
Queen G6 but what is happening after
Queen B6
you had me at winning a pawn immediately
I guess she wants to play Queen F6
against Queen D4 what do you think ah
queen of six here oh wow I'm not not
that I'm overly proud of her decision
yes but ah okay and transposed to this
end game but how
is this end game actually it's well been
maybe not so easy to play this one if I
will be able to create something on the
queen side maybe before
even you can include maybe bishop F3 but
I do I do see what you're saying the A4
B4 A5 some Advantage for white okay the
double pawns but yeah queen bee I I
can't imagine after Queen D4 uh the loss
of the B6 Pawn I don't think you can get
enough counter the computer suggests
here
variation is perfectly human so I didn't
even analyze it and so here I stopped
and I thought okay but rookie six in
this play Let's Play then well you bring
your queen back to D4 and now Rook C to
E8
it's a very mysterious concept that I
think he wants to push C5 and also
sacrifice it on G3 when the moment comes
so let's say I ignore everything and I
will play Rook C1 I wanted to check you
know so does it work actually Knight
takes G3 I have to take G3 Queen takes
G3
so this is the critical position of the
whole line right and let's have a look
uh oh the computer suggests Queen G7
here so I was maybe right if he gives up
the queen immediately so the threats are
very dangerous so you're threaten Bishop
H3 Rook G6 Rook E4 Rook H4 so maybe uh
this is the variation that's Anna has in
mind
wow sacrificing the pawn for uh the
attack just with doubling the Rooks on
the e e file and Knight takes G3
um
didn't see that coming I I definitely
underrated uh the attack there I thought
this was a very quiet position
it blowed up on us didn't it uh going
back uh if you don't mind the game of
Elizabeth and Alexandra for just a
moment because this move E4 E5 it really
feels like
Elizabeth is making an overreach at this
moment and we're looking at both Knight
C5 as well as Bishop G7 and we were
looking at Bishop G7 Rook C1 Bishop back
to C6 walking into e
line is just losing three takes three
right that that that's for sure so we
were looking at a pawn sacrifice for
white and what did the Oracle think of
E6 uh this is a very beautiful idea and
white is much better actually left 36
but that's why uh computer includes
first the move Knight C5 not Bishop G7
right uh this position E5 okay not
change this mind but before he was
support proposing Knight C5 Bishop C2
okay now you don't have this idea it's
playing books you want and Bishop G7 now
or even Knight E6 so let's try
Bishop G7 in this position so can you
play Bishop H6
Bishop E5 right the very important
factor of course is that the bishop on
C6 protects the Rook on E8 so Bishop B5
F4
uh I was thinking that you cannot play
Bishop G7 here I think for some reasons
uh maybe yes take take then you take
then you take then you
take on G5 yes and it's it's maybe a bit
better for white but a microscopic
Advantage but here after F4 Bishop D6
then you take on the eight you take on
D5 and maybe Queen C7
your opinion your queen and I in the F4
Pawn so I think black is really fine
doing fine in this position so agreed uh
so the question for you Almera is after
E4 E5 has black got the upper hand yes
the Revelation actually changed slightly
well in Black's favor
it still looks balanced to me but maybe
because of the time factor and as you
mentioned this no black doesn't have
real problems in this position so and
the time factor is getting severe or if
I somebody has seven minutes but I'm not
sure I think this is actually the moment
where Alexander that's wrong can seize
the opportunity and play for more
well she has played Bishop G7 she did
not include the move Knight C5 so Bishop
G7 is inviting this uh Rook C1 and E5 E6
and maybe the queen on A5 is
mysteriously uh trapped I I think it's a
Charming variation by the way you have
to have a very
a keen tactical awareness to pick up on
the fact that the queen on A5 is
suddenly in like what shockingly uh
trapped
and again for those of you who are
joining us late the fight for second
place is actually really Keen right
there's four players
uh
uh oh because we had a result now
entered the round with four points she's
a she she's finished her tournament and
at four and a half so four players who
could finish
Arena crush and Elizabeth pets because
these players are still playing and if
Elizabeth needs a win correct if
Elizabeth wins she knocks Alexandra out
of the fight and then she's hoping that
Arena would be knocked out by Anna and
they would be a shared sacket now
Alexandra on the other hand is saying if
I can win
[Music]
with a victory and Arena don't you score
a victory so the fight for second and
again 45 35
000. it sounded so good when you said it
35 000 second prize paid cash uh prize
and let's go back to the this Alexandra
game because we just had Bishop G7 and I
must confess I I have missed Rook C1 E6
and Bishop C7 that's uh really a sharp
idea Alexandra spotted it because of
jerroxy one she didn't play Bishop B7
and moved the queen out of this danger
zone and move to B6 okay supporting the
bishop and
in a sense that's
do I now
play A5 or well I would love to make two
moves in a row illegal of course I'd
love to play F2 F4 and I'd love for you
to move your queen the problem I'm
having is the desirable Bishop E3 Queen
B7 F4 then I think you know like
everything's going kind of my way I'm
not completely sure about that but the
DeForest putting the kibosh on my plan
and taking on D4
right one and well because you haven't
had E5 at the end exactly we we're
talking about Nana's game where one
player Gunner is uh dominating the dark
squares uh Nana's dominating the light
squares but in this case the dark
squares win uh so uh Queen B6 you've
mentioned A5 how did A5 does it help A5
Queen B7
uh I don't think it changes much
position is still preferable for black
slightly right
I keep trying to make things with Knight
F5 work I I guess not Almera uh what
have you got for us well I've actually
been told that we will have another
special guest in our studio so I will
let you analyze the this position
uh well more thoroughly but you we have
the queen of six move uh on the on the
board between Irina and Anna and this is
not a very nice end game for black so
actually Arena will try hard to win this
game after Queen F6 Knight F6 and Bishop
F6 and he takes F6 so A4
maybe bishop E6 here because you cannot
play C5 immediately the pawn on D5 is
hanging so and I really like this move
before
yes I'm trying to create a postpone here
and uh
this is a very unpleasant ending
yeah it feels that I can just see this
uh pass Pawn especially you've got this
bishop on G2 patrolling the A8 Square
it's another end game worldwide has no
risk right and it's only playing for two
results exactly
um help me out here with uh Alexandra's
position because Elizabeth obviously
when she went into this line with E5 she
was thinking that she has some tactical
solution how is she going to defend
against the very straightforward Knight
takes
fine let's try A5 okay yeah we can yeah
the queen drops back I guess maybe I
should play against the A6 spawn Queen
E2 okay let's do it
Queen E2 although I'm not happy that I'm
putting my queen right in front of you
Rook I know and we're we just have to
look at a line like this right Knight
takes and uh uh trying to exploit uh the
discovered attack
by the way the clock is Elizabeth's
really feeling the pressure of the
ticking clock now yes she's down to 10
and a half minutes
in a very complicated position indeed uh
not
I somehow I I really want to do
something else for Elizabeth the queen
C2 trying to go again into those lines
where the where the where the queen can
go to C7 so let's say you moved here
uh even Bishop A8 makes some sense so
Queen C7
or your Rokon C1 is protected
Rook CA oh you oh wow you would you
would try to make a shish kebab against
your dear friend a good commentating pal
no no no so Queen C7 maybe this is uh
her intention Queen CT should we check
in the game that we haven't really
talked about much Nana and gunesse came
right now when we left it again that was
one one player gunai had the dark
squares Nana did end up playing E3 by
the way and oh E4 I thought that that
would have allowed Knight C3 if you
recall we were looking uh and then the
best move was E4 E3 E4 and check Knights
hit three what's maybe the best response
right and the ampersant actually is very
helpful
and with that
uh they've got a position uh good night
still kept her black Square Bishop on C3
which is very annoying for white truly
truly I like I like Black's position I
like Black's position I do I do because
if black plays like something like B6
now that white Bishop even though it's
beautiful on that open diagonal it's not
doing much yeah it's an empty diagonal
the other thing that uh definitely has
my attention is this Pawn on G3 the pawn
on G3 is a potential weakness I can see
uh Bishop E3 Queen G5 even a Rover and
that pawn on G3
you know you don't have a Pawn on H2 and
you don't want to play G4 so I'm
thinking uh gunay as doing really really
well Arena
it's a second so interesting take on F6
she played Bishop takes
wow
Bishop in game with an extra Pawn
so I take with the bishop you can take
Queen F6 and win a pawn
and then but in obstacle Bishops I don't
think that poem carries that much weight
no I I don't either I I'm beginning to
question who stands better actually even
though white is a pawn up this bishop
to my way of thinking is actually kind
of dominating and also the central poems
as well exactly wow uh big uh big uh
decision there and Bishop takes E4 maybe
one will second guess but we have a very
very special guest in studio and he's
with Almera sure she goes let's go
Rex uh welcome to the Cure studio and
I've been joined in the studio by Rex
thank you for them for those who do not
know you yet yes I'm very nervous right
now Rex thank you for such a wonderful
event actually I was thinking what is on
your chest bucket list because well
there are so many events organized in
Saint Louis
do you have another idea well eventually
when we have a St Louis and
participating I'd like to host a world
championship match here
and wouldn't it be great if the St Louis
was a female
and was in the world championship match
that would make Yasser happy too and
Judith Polgar what a wonderful interview
with her that we had it was very
interesting uh for all of us and then I
wanted to ask you that I think that this
year we have 10 events broadcasted so I
think more than 73 days of Chess wow
Saint Louis is uh well is it the chess
Capital not enough in the world so how
about the team event
let's say the United States against the
world I think that is a great idea and I
was just going over it with joy we've
got the people that'll do it we've got
the horses and we got Fabi and and uh
Hikaru and Lavonne and Lanier
uh Wesley yeah we can do it bring them
on okay
well uh yes there's going to be the
captain of the United States team uh I
oh
I don't know anymore do you
um Rex we already have the winner and
Anna's is the first American winner
congratulations on a very well done
Hannah so well I think that it makes you
very proud yes
so you have been followed the event for
I follow them very carefully but don't
ask me for any insightful comment
well today we have this absolute clash
between uh yeah and Anna the game is
extremely it was extremely complicated
at the beginning okay so it's a very
complicated middle game which is heading
towards the end game right now
um who are you supporting
this well I have to be officially
neutral but I but I think Irena here
should jump and get a kinger or am I
mixing up my games
I'm sorry I mean there's actually a much
better here uh well so I got a secret
piece of information I know that you're
training with Yasser tell us a little
bit about this oh well he was just
trying to show off how patient he could
be with the student and he took me on
for an hour and it was it was amazing it
was it was great fun though because we
covered
a game that uh
I was just played recently and then he
covered one of my games from the
internet and I thought the whole world
would rise and Revolt I'm looking at my
moves but Yasser didn't he was very
patient and steady he put up with it
well I have a question then for yes sir
Easter eggs a good student actually he's
marvelous because Rex is sitting under
the board and he's going wow that's
really good the the the game I showed uh
Rex was between Fabi and Magnus and it
was the first game that Fabi had won in
eight years in classical chess so I said
okay Rex this is the position I'm going
to show you and you have to here it
comes
correctly predict Bobby's moves you
don't just predict right correctly and I
was really shocked in fact it was about
10 move combination he found about eight
of them eight out of ten and I asked Rex
directly I said Rex did you see this
game before and he said no sir no sir so
uh he surprised me and by the way it was
a tune-up it was just making sure that
he had all of his tactics so he
impressed and yeah genuinely it wasn't a
tune-up it was a total remove total
overhaul no I told you I need a week for
that Rex the tune-up was for an hour
that was good uh Rex what is your
favorite opening
as black I think so yeah as black if
it's against E4 Sicilian otherwise the
grunfeld and what type of the Sicilian
uh the hyper-accelerated dragon so
grandfather and the dragon you were you
have a very aggressive style well I
didn't know that somebody told me that
you know I thought I was just being a
mild-mannered chess player but I said no
that's pretty aggressive so and in these
tournament uh well we have such a great
number of decisive games yeah well
compared to the syncope I wanted to have
your comments about this well the women
are probably better players than the men
that's why we get more decisive games
I hope that gets back to the men
well thank you so much uh foreign
the best team in the world there's no
question about it no well we are
probably the finest one okay thank you
thank you Rex we are definitely enjoying
ourselves thank you uh to you and your
wife Jeannie for everything you do here
in St Louis it's uh well I'm speaking
for the players here that it's a real
pleasure for them to be in St Louis and
it's a great pleasure for us as well and
to call all of the actions so thank you
for everything that you and Jeannie do
uh getting back into the play uh this
move Queen E2 F1 by Elizabeth she's
saying okay do your worst and let's pick
up because this fight for second place
is really just suddenly heating up
what's your immediate take after Queen
F1 I think
so everything will be will be decided in
this time
this time exactly but I do see I like
this move Queen F1 because okay it was
important that I maintain the defense of
the bishop I'm getting out of
but I'm feeling that if it's my turn
Bishop B5 is going to solve a lot of my
problems so you've got to do something
right now right here right now uh to
exploit the moment can you yes I think
the main difference in this position is
that it's a race between two pass pawns
which is A5 and D5 right I definitely
like black spawn better because The
Bishop's in front of the okay but go on
yeah but Bishop B5 is an unpleasant
threat so I would start with Rook E6
maybe just to avoid that
uh exchange okay sidestep with Rook E6
okay I don't like the fact that my
Bishop on A6 is kind of stuck if I but
if you move it I'll take the pawn on A5
so that's ahead that's my iPhone okay so
I'll take you appreciation I'm sorry I'm
giving up the two Bishops Bishop takes
Bishop takes Bishop to B5 I'm hoping
that you will trade and well maybe I'm
not hoping but you're not worried about
Messina pure I'm worried I'm worried yes
I am I'm more but again what you
described it best it's
I it's a race your deep on I have to
make my a pawn as potent as possible and
as long as my Bishop is sitting on A6
forget about it I I like Black's
position
um yeah I was about to say I'm giving
you a really nice opportunity uh to put
your Bishop on C3 I think you should
take advantage of it
um I'm winning at least upon here I
think because a pawn is just gone yeah
unfortunately my strength turned into a
liability
uh Amira help me out uh Elizabeth seems
to be slipping and time is also a factor
as well
yes um
slightly worse right now even though
that she uh well to the she took the
pound and A6 here so the computer
suggests two moves here Rook E6 and
Knight C4
Knight C4 seems more human to me in this
position Knight C4 yes seems more human
yes because like I just want to take
your Bishop on A6 or get the pair of
Bishops and having this almira's been
working with Oracle too much because
Knight C4
I thought Rook E6 was the most human
movie I'm like actually I liked it
because first of all I wanted to well I
today is not my day and I'm blundering
all the time so I wanted to take the
bishop but they said how do I make it
work and then I wanted to keep the pound
so actually at night C4 takes on C4 then
Queen C4
and then Bishop G2
here so right row that's scary so if not
Queen C4 you cannot take Rook C4 because
there is Bishop B5 and black is
completely winning so that's why I
actually like this move but rookie 6
which you consider more human actually
yields a black uh
even a better Advantage so that's why
I'm not I was not even option for the
best move in this position so let's have
a look at rookie six sure yes and then
you have to retreat your Bishop your
dark Square Bishop for some reason here
let's say Bishop D2 as you can see uh
computer hesitate so he attacks the pawn
on B4 then maybe bishop f8
but they wanted to make what if actually
let's say Bishop B5 here then you can
simply take on A5 and actually that's
the whole problem in this position
whenever you move your Bishop a black
comfortable it takes on A5 and
it's actually much better in this
position so that's why I really thought
the move Rook E6 was really good I was
trying to play Bishop B5 Almera to
rescue my bishop and to push my pawn and
the move Rook E6 defending the bishop or
over protecting the bishop allowing
Queen takes A5 is what's really uh
disconcerting for Elizabeth and is great
news for Alexandra's fans and
opportunity for Alexandra because if
Arena doesn't win her game in Alexander
does we have a clear second yes and uh
she's also leading on the clock 27
minutes against six minutes right she
has a very good chance to
get improve her position even more in
this time scramble
uh I would love to say that Knight C4
crossed my mind but it really didn't I
don't know
I thought Rook E6 was really you know
just cementing everything keeping all
you know everything intact and I really
like that point that Almera made that
Bishop d uh two was going to be met by
Bishop f8 it's kind of interesting how
the Bishops uh Shadow one another I know
what was really surprising in Irena and
Anna game let's do it with the pawn
we were looking at this uh okay this
moment right in this moment yeah this
moment where we our our primary move had
been Queen text F6 right we in fact we
did not consider Bishop takes e Ford all
my instant reaction was Bishop takes E4
and who's playing for the win uh in
Arena's mind
the Bishops of opposite color with the
extra Pawn she's playing for a win but I
will say to you that your extra Pawn is
this G3 pawn and that's not really extra
uh she took with the with the pawn it's
creating a passer on in the corner on
the queen side she just played A4
but how is he creating a passer the this
is dead uh black has no worries right
well are you going to place
so are you comfortable with Pawn on C6
oh very much so so I would probably play
Rook a for some reason I was considering
C5 and then B5 and minus that I'd get
scared about uh I would be afraid that
the uh bee Pawn is actually more scary
than my C5 Pawn but I'm also thinking uh
if I just trade off the Rooks we're just
going to shake hands there's nothing to
discuss so Rook A8 maybe Rook A5 here
I'm still trying to get a passport
leverage uh that uh okay so something on
the king side maybe King H7 and get out
of uh
uh Rook G5
uh but before
the time control the time travel really
rears its uh ugly head let's sneak in a
break and we're gonna see you on the
other side of this commercial break
foreign
welcome girls thanks so much for
stopping by to talk to me a little bit
how do you feel the tournament is
approaching the end
any feelings
said
happy really so upset was for me right
I mean
tired come back
thank you I have the only one
and then I'm free because the last was
against humpy so only against there is
some chances
um what side the tournament's going well
but not for everyone maybe uh well I had
good life till yesterday and then I just
lost and okay I'm just looking forward
to play good Blaster insurance so we can
finish in on good knots
you're both really young so you still
have a long way so it's like every
tournament you take it as a good
experience right to continue
hopefully getting better I'm looking at
your science and I want to laugh again
all right let's let's get to the serious
part questions can you tell me a little
bit about your hobbies is there
something specific that you like
okay for me it was boxing but I stopped
like a year ago maybe so I'm thinking to
to come back with with the lessons she
told me that in the
days ago when I asked you yeah with
Elizabeth is there anything else that
you like
I don't know other sports
at least traveling
well trolling is always nice
uh but for now I guess just the sports
and staying home okay
well for me I'm reading and I love you
yoga
yeah and
um I was doing for three years horseback
riding but I quit for like because of
the time management
I also want to
to go to do this again so like that
it's good
um good night do you have a favorite
place both of you have traveled so many
countries do you have a favorite place
that you really liked and you would love
to go back somewhere where it's not home
of course home is probably special but
um well recently I've been in Berlin I
love really historical places so Berlin
is like the mother of kind of cities so
I really love Berlin I think I can say
that this city okay
uh for me it's probably Singapore
yeah I lived there when I was 10 I was
sitting in a chess Academy so I stayed
there for like two years and okay this
was the last time when I was in
Singapore so I want to visit again
I've never been in that side of
the blue though I've asked you before
this how many countries approximately do
you think you've been to
about 50 for me well I'm using the track
the application being up
so it's like 36
. we still haven't we still have yeah I
still have lots of
uh you've been playing chess ever since
you were kids both of you what age did
you learn to play
that was six it's me five
years actually we played first time when
we were both seven yeah it was in 2007.
yeah we played world use in Turkey
Turkey yeah yeah
so still playing yes still together do
you have a nice memory of when you
were something that inspired you to
continue playing not the not the person
but like something
why you stayed in the game was it your
parents that were more pushing you to
play chess or yeah for me it was
definitely parents yeah but also okay I
mean we I'm sure we both really enjoy it
yeah just to play and the first two ways
you should be enjoying then someone else
yeah sure do you have something specific
you like about Chess why what do you
like about it and what what's your
favorite thing about Chess
for me the feeling after you went so I'm
trying you know this tournament I didn't
get the chance to win still but okay
tomorrow last round I'll try
and also she's the she's the leader of
the tournament so
why not
for me it's creativity I don't know if
it makes any sense
I think many things I mean yeah there's
a lot there's no specific reason it's a
tricky question I like to ask it
sometimes just to kind of give people a
sense of watch players
um like to do and what they fight for do
you have a game that of yours that you
think
that was your best game or something
interesting happens or maybe you won a
competition after that game brought you
a big victory
that you consider your best game of your
career so far
wow I think it's hard to say I mean yeah
I mean we played many nice years but for
Me Maybe I played World Cup against
mariachuk I think it was
in 2018
so I play it with black there was some
nice silly and give I mean I think many
people saw it because there was also
some videos on YouTube and was some
people were just trying to commend it
and yeah that was a real interesting
fight so 2018 in Huntington's World Cup
it doesn't
World Championship
it's World Cup yeah world cup ah okay
okay
what about you um for me well also hard
to say but I think um like they're the
games against GMS that the winnings I
mean I well also then find them like you
know really amazing when you win and uh
if it's like the young players gyms so
in Sergio last year I won a game against
the Evis relief
I found this game really fighting
because like there was up and downs and
uh
I won a beautiful game
do you have any GM norms well ridiculous
and notes yet because I was like four
times half points uh shy so it's just um
well we'll see
someone has inspired me recently
um
regarding that
um saying that
if you you are going to get your GM
title when you play like a GM there was
a grandma
and I'm struggling to get my I am Norm
so this is my final month so uh I hope I
hope you will get to
you became a Grandmaster
um what did it take for you to go from
International monsters to Grandmaster
would you feel that you did something
you know what was the final push that
got you to be able to reach titles I
guess
pandemia because you know I got my three
norms and I couldn't reach the 2500
rating and it was really hard because I
was always thinking about it like I have
to do it and it was always like you know
very close but I couldn't make it so
then when we had this pandemia time I
guess I had some rest and after that I
played the Grand Prix in Gibraltar which
I won and that was a tournament when I
got my rating yes
yeah so it took me like maybe two years
to reach the rating it wasn't easy do
you feel that the pandemic has affected
the positive way but do you feel you had
more time for rest and rethink your
training because before you you have the
chance to play more tournaments but
um during the pandemic it was about two
years
do you feel that you were able to spend
more time on chess
well maybe first month when the
everything has closed yeah we didn't
know what to do so we're trying to you
know just continue the the lessons
because no one knew about the
tournaments the dates so you have to be
ready like any time
uh but then but then it was hard because
you had no motivation like yeah yeah
actually for six months the old
tournaments were declined so there
weren't any plans yeah and also I really
hated online chess I mean this both
cameras yeah from two sides I'm not a
fan of that you don't feel the how the
the opening is doing during the game
because I mean in life it's much better
of course as you can see like how it
feels so I didn't I didn't like this
time even though I had some time to rest
but still it wasn't nice
one thing
I think I think that is not very known
or maybe something that was perceived
wrong and
for like your friends you know
well nothing comes to my mind I don't
know I got married but I think everyone
so thank you for me I don't think people
knew I
yeah I mean like after everything
happened I haven't post I made a post
and I saved it on my page Instagram page
but still like some people are just like
texting me like are you like seriously
like you're married
yeah so so yes
or enjoying married life last question
last
one well she is nearly married so she
can answer first
um enjoying yeah what can I say I mean
no I mean it didn't like we didn't have
much time to spend together because like
after all happened I mean I came here
and almost didn't see him for like 20
days it's really hard so I want to go
home yeah I think Guna is already tired
of hearing this every day you know
looking forward to finishing the
tournament and going back home
yes and for me it's just like you know
nothing really changed so uh I'm just
more happier so like I love uh this is
new stage of my life yeah I like the
feeling that someone is waiting for you
you know it's not your parents or your
brothers or sis someone is just waiting
out of your family yes and he's like
even though we have like 11 hours
difference he's still like always online
checking for the games like it's nice
yeah I mean uh considering the the time
difference they can be like wake uh I
don't know like for 4 AM 3 A.M like
checking your game so it's yeah just to
talk to you after the game and ask how
are you feeling that's
I agree well thank you girls so much for
your time and good luck in the last
round and uh thank you tournaments
thanks
[Music]
the muni's premier season bursting with
comedies romance and Magic Begins June
12th with the muni premiere of beautiful
the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
[Music]
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our current standings of course we
already have a winner and as a chance
won the tournament yesterday but uh
playing for the second place four
players
Alexandra kaistenio Irina crash and
Elizabeth pets still have a chance and
for Alexander custom music's fans uh
they're cheering because at this very
moment I really like her position
Elizabeth not only behind unborn
terribly speaking Queen takes A5 is
going to clip upon but I think on the
clock yeah there it goes that's
confirmation right there of Elizabeth's
problems 41 seconds yep she's playing on
just 30 second increment while Alexandra
has luxury to think for 20 minutes and
the number of moves it's still to be
played still five moves to go okay we're
expecting Alexandria to clip the pawn
queen takes A5 just getting rid
of this uh
passer and now what Black's got the
bishop two ponds and I see bad things
happening I see the grocery shops
looking really good for black or black
yeah so so with a victory uh that would
mean for Alexandra that only Arena could
tie her what's happening in Arena's game
in Arena's game a few changes C5 B5
happened so both have past Pawns so she
did play C5 that was a move that
appealed to you I was a little bit
reluctant I was very reluctant in fact
to allow the move B5 which was played
Rook B8 Rook B1 Rook E6 and I see that
well from Anna's point of view what's
the problem I'm going to play Rook B6
and Bishop E2 and I'm going to round up
this Pawn on B5 is that true though I
think that's why I should push C5
Chicago
she can get that pawn very quickly and
if she can then it's definitely a draw
because on the king side White's extra
Pawn nothing doing huh yeah it's not
enough to win the game exactly the time
situation however is a little concerning
for Anna she has three minutes left and
11 more moves to make
but her position is that's a kind of a
luxury sorry you were about to say in
her position is quite easy to play so
maybe time trouble won't actually be a
contributing factor to this
to this game okay so let's see so Rook
to E6 the bishop drops back let's say
Bishop
sent to C3 Rook B6 Rook on E6 to B6
um
now Rook takes E4 walks into Bishop F5
that's bad news
and if you go Rook A5 Rook A5 I thought
Bishop
issue E5 rotates right
I don't that doesn't uh
I don't profit from that
so just a second I don't like where I
put my Bishop so let me let me find a
better Square for my
you should let's say I go here G5 okay
Rook B6 same idea yes
and let's say I go Rook C1 give me this
Pawn You're Gonna Go rookie like a rook
takes
and just Rook B1 exchange one pair of
rocks you might be able to exchange both
um
I'm hoping that you're not going to play
Bishop F5 trade trade and ask me can I
win that and then I can do a rook C1 and
Bishop F3 Rook C1 and Bishop F3 that
might be the better way because in this
case my desired Bishop E7 has met PSI C4
and then thanks to the back rank me you
have an easy draw so Bishops of opposite
colors and uh Anna's banking on that to
overcome her
material deficit it's only a pawn but
the light squares the position is
completely equal yeah it feels like it
and uh once in the game Nana against
grenade yes has a very big Advantage I
believe well indeed it was one of those
games where uh you've got the light
squares I've got the dark squares but uh
let me tell you about your dark squares
and she has just played a fabulous move
Queen to uh C7 with the battery you will
like White's next move as well
it's almost study like you wanted to you
have to open up this diagonal in order
to defend the H2 Square so you put your
Bishop as far as you can Far Far Away
distant Galaxy but I don't I mean
everything about this position I love
for black uh it's just like you know F5
F4 I've got all the time in the world
and White's King is so vulnerable I'd
almost start to think I I have to run I
I think I'm going to die on Camp inside
you can't even the center in Queen side
is not safe so I think black has a
long-term Advantage because that's C3
square is a very important Hall in
White's position and that's why
true if you were to move the king all
the way to the queen side I would just
reposition my queen and Bishop on the
other diagonal so
oh you be you you'll be there ready to
greet me as soon as I get to D2 or B2 I
hear you it's not a pleasant position
for Nana somehow out of the opening it
it went wrong in fact and again I'm
going to turn back to the game of
Elizabeth and Alexandra to see what
progress they have made and Amira Jump
Right In we think oh she didn't take the
pawn on A5 how could she not do that
she's very patient she's very patient
Queen
A7 okay with the threat of Bishop takes
G3 that was meant by Queen D3
Bishop to D4 and
well Rook C2 probably only move rookie
one check
well I mean one night F1 I have to go
is she picking up the pawn anymore
yeah it was almost
not that I'm tempted don't don't get me
wrong I hate playing such moves but in
this particular now you've probably
played Bishop C3 yes it's not so easy
for me to well I have Queen A5 hold on
okay just go ahead and kill me put me
out of my misery Knight H1
Bishop C3 Queen B5
and I'm doing my best to pretend that
I'm not busted
I'm probably D4 is good enough I
probably am busted but I thought I'd
throw that in with me yeah but with
confidence I'm not busted yes you are
okay
um A6 right yeah
oh dear oh dear what can I say it's not
uh it's not been a good day in the
office in day three and uh finally my
night which was on H1 is actually for
the first time doing something a little
bit too useful
oh God
nope nope it's it's bad it's bad it's
it's all going Alexandra's way and uh
wow okay Bishop D4
um hold on she didn't
hold on Elizabeth played Rook C2 that's
on the board
and Alexandra is thinking
gotcha
hold on
the is that is as the game board I'm
going to just refresh my board to make
sure that I'm up today behind right okay
so Bishop to D4 Rook c2s on the board
and we're thinking it's all Alexandra
going on here Elmira please confirm our
judgment
can about the game that Alexander played
against Nana and his uh if you remember
she didn't take on F3 and didn't go for
the obvious line which for the human
mind is very intuitive so you know that
even though you're exchanged down like
the advantages overwhelming here as well
I think that computers has changed our
prism and take on the positions that we
no longer know what's good or right if I
might explain so it's become much more
difficult for us to evaluate the
position so there are so many positions
now that the structures been demolished
with the ponson F2 F3 and H2 for example
for white and that computer thinks that
white is much better so I think that
that explains first of all the decision
in that game but here we were talking
about the most obvious decision Queen A5
but for a player who is trying to
calculate everything and Alexandra is
playing a bit like computer and this
game she
she calculates the variations very
deeply she's trying to play like a
computer here in a way so
almost the same analysis as in the
previous game so here I tried to
understand what does she wants after
Rook C2 Knight F1 and let's see this
move Bishop E6 and actually after Bishop
B5 the position is already equal because
a white period all threats and black
didn't take the pawn on A5 yet
so you have to be careful here but on
the other hand after rookie 1 and Knight
F1 I cannot come with a useful move here
for example the computer suggests go
back Bishop F6 so of course Knight is on
F1 here The Rook is much more active
only one but you just played Bishop D4
and then you have to go Bishop
F6 back here so let's say what if Queen
D2 I'm starting to attack The Rook then
The Rook goes to A1 and those variations
are a bit artificial to Maya
so as you can see the evaluation doesn't
change here black is still completely
winning but for the moments uh White is
the white is trying to defend everything
yeah that well again uh kind of strange
not capturing that pawn and just to
refresh remind everybody that the fight
for a second is incredibly intense and
Alexandra is in pole position to win
that uh what was it 35 000 did you say
yes given her position right now she's
winning and if she does convert this
game she'll be in the clear second and
if Irina doesn't win her game she will
take home the thirty five thousand
dollars for a second place uh that
variation that you were showing Almera
uh with rookie one check sure I love
that move Knight F1 for me the move
Bishop F6 a little bit of a head
scratcher because he wants to take on H5
actually yeah but I was thinking you
would play Bishop to C3 same idea I want
to take on A5 and
more or less protect my Rook so there
would be no Queen D2 business
Rook E2 here and then can I gobble
gobble Rook takes we do not have monkeys
I'm so sorry just uh yeah this position
uh you cannot take on if well you can't
take only five here but after Queen is
seven it seems that uh White is actually
doing fine
E8 suddenly on there is the this I get
it very important wow uh none of this
happened because
rookie six instead of rookie one check
wow um
a couple of very difficult moves you
know you you wanted it yeah how can you
avoid not play checks so Elizabeth
played rookie sorry Knight F1 Elizabeth
made her move with 10 seconds on the
clock ten seconds so she had 41 so she
made it with 11 and now with 10. not
like Arena that this goes down to 31.
Knight F1 uh still the A5 Pawn is still
alive
so now Bishop C3 still makes sense and
she's played it finally yes to C3 we'll
probably see a rookie too well there is
Bishop A6 right
or you ready to sign
I still have Bishops still correct hold
on just a second it's so long Rook E2
Bishop A6 Bishop B5 take take take we
get into this ending but this is a the
best that white could hope for is that
Queen and Knight and your Pawn down and
you hope for some kind of importance
there was uh Elizabeth
she was going back and forth Rook she
was reaching for rookie two she was
reaching for rookie two and we're three
seconds on her clock she went 93. she
was completely losing right there's D4
and Bishop B4
yes this was a huge blunder time trouble
E4 D foreign
absolutely D4 double attack
and of course Alexandra says everything
yes heart skips a beat when that night
landed on E3 because I think Alexandra
had foreseen this possibility
Knight G4 okay trickies yes Bishop E4 so
we have to include rookie one check
Maybe
Rook E1 check oh King H2 and queen B8
isn't that Checkmate G3 H1
yes uh I'd have to play Queen
G3 so Rook check King H2 just so that
our audience is up to date Queen B8 G3
thank you very much that's second place
I'll take clear second Queen G3 I can
take the queen and push D3 and game
order correct that is absolutely game
over
and just to through the magic of
Television how close did she come to
flagging well and she was reaching for
the rock she should have played rookie
two and then last second
yeah four or three
oh my three seconds this is reaching for
the Rook rookie two I think was the most
stubborn that I think it was also still
losing uh as it is though uh the move d4
Knight to G4 a light Rook check and
queen check I think I like H5
this is good yes because Knight has no
good squares you can go to each well
that yeah
Knight H3 just Bishop E4 exactly Knight
H2 Bishop E4 Bishop A6 I do have Bishop
B5 but I don't have a good answer to
Bishop E4 and again down to five seconds
but now I think our problem is the
position and there it goes it's game
over oh the original party oh sorry they
just made move forward you're my top
agents in these matchers
she's made the move 40. uh she did not
flag but unfortunately for Elizabeth's
fans she's a she's she's lost she's like
the commentators are getting tired
exactly exactly and uh take us over to
Arena's game because Arena has got to
win now and what has he done so when we
left it we saw the move rookie six
Bishop C3
Rook B6 Rook C4
well well Bishop
to E2 pawns got exchanged C5 for B5 why
can't she take on B5
I don't know I guess you'll play Rook C1
or so I don't know Bishop E2 takes check
King H7 takes we're anticipating Rook
takes
and that has just happened as I spoke to
seven Chuck
right I have to play King H6 and Rook
takes F7 but I guess Bishop F3 indeed
Bishop F3 and uh Rook check am I made it
uh we always have G4 here always have G4
yeah I was about to say we gotta get we
we have to make a room for our King but
I would think that this is a an easy
draw
the Bishops of opposite color let's just
say wow I mean Anna uh made her
Grandmaster Norm already regardless of
the result but the extra draw so to
speak you know really means more rating
yeah it really puts it uh really a a a
nice exclamation mark
on a absolutely absolutely fabulous
result I think Anna playing with
confidence is extremely dangerous
opponent the true uh and I've always
said that chess is actually really a
game of confidence and when you come
into a tournament and you feel yourself
well prepared it makes all the
difference in the world and uh when
you're when you come to the game with
confidence and winning as many games as
Anna did also so it helps helps a lot
confidence helps a lot I wanted to ask
you Almera Bishop F3 Rook takes F3 would
be terrible because I'm gonna have to
play G4 anyway
and she has played Bishop F3
well after Rook takes F3
um
black is just winning yeah I don't think
that's well but G4 yeah and
well you will have to take with the
bishop I suppose here after G4 because H
takes G4 actually gives you another
opportunity to win the game you will
have the postpone well really though
because let's say You're Gonna Go King
H2 and I'm gonna go Rook B1 and I'm
You're Gonna Go King G3 and I'm gonna go
Rook H1 okay and that H Pond is going
absolutely nowhere I don't see it
getting to H7 yes but here now that your
pieces are stuck
Corner maybe I can use them uh the
momentum and play Bishop E5 Bishop to E5
yes okay let's say you if you will give
me a rook H3 check okay king of four and
it's already plus six because I
obviously I'm missing something I
slurped the pawn and I'm walking into a
mating net yeah yes King F5 is a very
strong move in this position wow
and I think that arena is going to
verify I think this is actually one of
those positions rook and Bishop versus
Rook there's a few positions that are
winning and I think this is this is one
of them yeah even if you remove all the
other pieces that's why I think that
this is very important to take with the
bishop on G4 exactly to keep the H Pawn
still on H4 okay
good and actually now that I've I look
at it also Bishop takes
G4 Bishop takes G4 King H2 I should play
Rook F5
so King H2 first is what Arena's done so
that that that's a very sensible move
because she wants G4 and not she wants
to force Anna to play Rook
uh B1 before playing G4 or wait a minute
now I'm really confused with the Rook
yeah right now I'm really confused can't
she go Rook check
King Rook check okay you can take on the
rook and take another one oh well wait a
minute oh we're still walking into the
maze exactly we're still walking into
some kinds of checkmates right yeah
something like this and Bishop F6 alone
yeah just Bishop F6 threatening made in
one threatening The Rook
ouch
so somehow actually blacks oftentimes
trouble but they are very close to more
40. three more moves for Anna to or
former moves foreign
and the critical moment of taking the
pawn on G4 yes will come in the next
three moves exactly
um
I was about to say uh can she pick up a
Tempo Force the bishop to maybe a lesser
Square although I don't see why D4 is
isn't it you can play Rook C1 Rook C2
and before surgery that way
ah so Rook C5 on the board
oops sorry I've done something wrong uh
no I forgot to include King H2 Rook C5
on the board and in case of Bishop D4
Rook C2 as well right
I've got to go for the same G4 business
check
here check here here and I'm hoping
no I think
be so greedy and pick up everything with
the Rook right not with the Rook but
maybe with the bishop in order
to chase
46. that's like King E5 and still
less scary right less scary let me just
refresh my board uh for just a moment
I'm going back and forth everybody
King H2 on the board now irina's has
less time 33 seconds
but for her is there anything better
than just Bishop D4 nope and she did it
Bishop D4 Rook C2
Rook C2 and G4 will have to come
uh Almera I think Anna is putting uh the
finishing touches
on a spectacular tournament and she will
go undefeated
well to be honest I I think that this
game will still go on for a while
because even after the variation
which you analyze let's say Rook C2
which has just been played Rook C5 is a
very precise move of course so let's try
Rook F2 King G3 you don't actually need
a computer for this so yeah
um G4 King F5 and I tried the two moves
Rook G8 or Rook G6 but they think that
at the end of the line uh White will
manage to win the pawn in E4 so they
will play another X well 50 moves so
we'll say Bishop F6 I want to play
Bishop G5 sure Bishop B4 and a bishop G4
and King E4 so it will get to this
position right and and I will have to
defend it for a while I see and G4 by
the way is on the board we were thinking
that um there might be easier ways uh
for uh black to defend it Chad King F4
Bishop takes G4 I guess we're giving up
E4 Pawn right away yeah so then maybe
you can take it immediately just take
immediately yeah
and if I go after ah but now maybe you
can play Luke Cage too and by the way
Rook G4 Rook takes F2 check on the board
of King G6 yeah maybe this is the most
precise
continue
and they will reach move 40 on the next
move so Anna can take her time to decide
with which piece to take on G4
nice luxury to have but I do like that
idea of taking with the bishop I feel
that I just need to make sure that I
don't walk into a mating net uh with my
king stuck on H6
Bishop takes
G2 yep they just made him a 40. I must
say I'm really impressed by the calmness
with which Anna plays even under time
trouble and as we've seen throughout her
career she's often under the stress of
the ticking clock and it doesn't seem to
phase her she's just kind of casually
it's actually comfortable for her
it is so strange how is Nana doing sorry
to our friend our Donna's uh many many
fans uh number one player from Georgia
and uh
so they also just Regional 40 and I'm
hearing that maybe good name is the win
right before muffordi Uh Oh you mean one
of those uh last last move situations
instead of Queen H4 G5 was winning Queen
h4g
oh sorry for K2 and here
after rookie 2 G5
just let's go
85. if you take Queen F5 yum
uh G4
what
I'm guessing what Queen G4 and Rook G6
is this not older
G6 queen of three this queen says
there's gotta be something here Queen C6
yes replied queen of five I did
heroically you forgot to ask
oh Rook Cafe no
Rook G1 and then
it's a very long line that in time
trouble wow uh okay I I tip my head if
you find this one on move 40 wow so that
would have been a double Pawn sacrifice
in my naked King right oh my uh
so G5
wow
threatening G4 exactly
and uh that well G5 how how big an
advantage was G5 uh Almera uh was black
just winning after G5 yes it's about
minus five what yes but it's worth a
rook it's worth a rook but you really
have to come up with well a series of
only moves here after G5 Queen F5 G4
Queen G4 then Rook G6 of course
queen of three Rook G1 King G1 Rook f8
here and now you well you have to give
up the queen because let's try
you can you cannot play Queen G2 here
right
[Music]
if you play three four here then I think
Queen G7 check
is it possible that you have this
beautiful move Queen A1 there's some
geometry going on here beautiful
geometry on the board and I think maybe
this idea was missed by gune because
Queen G7 with the idea of playing uh
Queen A1 wow
great stuff uh wow you should still keep
some advantage in the current position
but first missing a big win
which is not really a queen H3 wins as
well she might not get a second
opportunity
hard to believe right because it seems
like it's one of those situations where
you want to prep the move G5 I mean
obviously it would be very nice to be
able to play G4 in one go so you would
think that in the current position I
would just prep
G5 by defending the pawn so let me just
put a move on the board Rook F6 if G5
and G4 is winning for black why can't
she maybe Rook e to G2 Rook I just stop
in G5
I think I'm going to ask for more coffee
what's going on here I didn't see that
oh you just stopped me you want to play
rough huh just a second we created the
Monster
uh if I play Rook G8 okay you're
stopping me I am I'm being insistent
I can just put my Rook on G5
but is it it's not stable there right
okay right
happy to hear it
uh I mean so much of the game is is
based upon black advancing her kingside
majority H6 G5 if white is able to stop
it well
well done I don't know
very accurate move here
E4 looks tempting but I don't think it's
I want to play e4h6e5 but I don't think
it works you can just take it
the timing the tempo is just in time
right well okay uh uh it's not a
surprise uh that uh gunay still has
chances but I tell you that move G5 on
move 40. that's a that's a tough one to
play because you've got to see all of
those you know very accurate Tempo moves
and you're going to sacrifice a Pawn on
more 40.
uh sacrifice is a nice way of putting it
blundering
back to Elizabeth Alexandra is
completely winning just
making her final moves because I think
all white pieces are under attack the
queen rook and knight's about to be
under attack as well just King G7 or H7
right and um wow three single pieces
hanging
you didn't say check
but on guard as far as the queen is
concerned the rook and the Knight by the
way
um Almera I mean I know this is modern
chess and uh so on but uh in the old
books they used to say angard when the
queen was attacked so you would say
check when the King was attacked do you
do they still do that in France
well nowadays we want to win at any cost
so we certainly will not warn our
opponents
that's we are about to take his Queens
right
but here the Revelation is very severe
it's almost 9 minus nine so I'm
expecting Elizabeth to resign in a few
moves right
I was just a walk past the club the
other day I was watching I stopped to
watch a Blitz game they're playing Blitz
outside of the club and uh I a young
lady had put her opponent in check and
the opponent had uh grabbed a queen
and was making a move and she didn't say
anything and then he recognized that he
was in check
so he put Rod his Queen back and he
reached for his King and she said touch
move so he had to put his Queen in front
of the shack and then she could take the
queen no no no no I mean touch move in
the Blitz game yeah
it's touch move I think it depends I
mean in my circle of friends it was
touch clock once you pressed the clock
that was it that was so we let you take
your move back on an illegal move but
yeah some people like to play Touch move
they feel that's uh more tournament
etiquette and by the way in Blitz
tournaments it is touch me okay I didn't
know that yes sir I have a question
please
what is your score against the top
ladies
In classical chess unfortunately for me
I really didn't play that many ladies
and classical chess
um I
I played Judith a few games I I won one
in the world team and uh you remember
draw it draws uh I think with Judith and
I played by a kremling once in
um the well this tournament I told you I
have won against Pia but I I played in
The Melody Amber the rapid in Blitz with
sudazuna and Judas do you just meet me
in the uh the blindfold that was the
rapid chess but in classical chess I'm
sad to say I don't really have that many
games and there was just not that many
women playing
um
professionally yeah professionally in
fact it was really really tough even for
arena
playing professionally here in the
United States and she was a really very
very successful as we know uh but uh how
do you think you would do here at the
Karen's cup if we gave you a wild card
you're going to have to be a prime
subscriber to get the answer to that
question boy
when you said the Wild Card
well my openings are terrible my
calculation isn't as good as it used to
be and my energy levels are really
really bad so I don't know plus four
plus five you know something reasonable
I mean you know whatever uh who was it
Ty Cobb I think it was Ty Cobb tycob a
very very famous
professional baseball player
so he was like 60 years old or maybe he
was yeah okay let's just say 60 years
old he's on a radio program and they
they're calling a baseball game and uh
the baseball pitcher is throwing
and the announcer says to take up so hi
if you came back and you were facing
today's pictures how would you do
and he said oh probably I'd be a 250
hitter meaning one out of four times he
gets on base he says well well that's
remarkable that you would be able to do
that against today's professional
pictures and he says well I am 60 years
old
oh well
you know I don't know I think the ladies
have really really improved their game
especially from the days of Bobby
Fischer
so I told the story about Judith and I
had played probably as many as 4 000
tournament classical games in my life
but I could never recall playing an
opponent on their birthday
it just doesn't happen so there I was
playing Judith and the the
Arbiter comes on just before he hits the
gun and he goes well I'd really like to
announce and congratulate happy birthday
to Judith paulgar so we all kind of
applaud I said Judith that's fantastic I
didn't know I'm sorry I would have
brought you a present if I had known she
said well yeah sir you can make a
present you can take anything you want
off the board
so I remember that Bobby Fisher said he
could give a night odds to the top woman
player
and Michael Tall famously said Bobby's
Bobby but a night's a night the top
woman player accepted Bobby's Challenge
and he said no I'm sorry I take it back
so remembering what Bobby Fisher said
and recognizing the incredible strides
that women have made I reached across
the table and I took her knight from G8
off the board she said give me back your
my night I said no no no it's my present
she says you're not a gentleman I said
that's true and you're not getting your
night back so very very reluctantly I
was forced by the Arbiter
and her very first move in the game was
Knight G8 to have sex so she didn't lose
it but yeah no I mean the strides that
women have made in chess have just been
extraordinary in my lifetime it says
great to watch and he's coming here to
the club and seeing the U.S girls
which is actually coming up it's only
getting stronger we're seriously younger
and stronger Alice Lee is just an
inspiration it's just wonderful to watch
shout out by the way she just made her
last I am Norm in Canada wow
congratulations Alice U.S uh female I am
at age 13. 13 years young that's just
I mean come on at 13 I was struggling to
become a b player no seriously it's a
really an extraordinary accomplishment
uh congratulations Alice
I'm thinking
Elizabeth's about to resign yes yes what
is taking her that I mean there's just
it's such a terrible yeah that's true he
was trying to win and clutch that second
place so right
it's just so bad I mean the queen The
Rook the night oh sorry I had King H7 on
my board I I made Alexandra's move for
her uh she seems to be thinking between
G7 and H7 is there a difference uh
probably not but she's confirming that
okay
Amira what has caught your eye uh in
this uh round eight Championship round
yes I was looking at this position
because after Knight age six uh King G7
if you play you can't try Knight F5 but
there is it's just a ghost so a bit
Queen
95 GTX 5 Queen G3 Rook G6 you have a few
checks but after Queen A5 simply King H7
and Black's uh Queen and A7 protects the
bound on uh F7 so even well if you take
only five I can still take the Rook
right
black is completely winning but here
actually after Knight age six I tried
another variation yes this was okay even
if I play King G7 Bishop B5
Bishop B5
Queen B5 then
rookie two
Queen A2
and well you can simply take the Knight
on H6
uh merci beaucoup a little surprised by
Anna's mobshi 24 with the Rook allowing
King F5
oh that was the one thing we thought
that was the danger for Anna which was
literally allowing pardon me uh go back
to this moment so what can cause defeat
the one thing we thought that could
cause Anna to lose the game is if white
magically were to get the king to F5
then there would be a bishop G5 check
and made so just don't let the king get
to F5 and you're saying that she's done
that she's let yes I'm so sorry yes sir
because we analyzed the move Rook G6 and
I was
analyzing the second alternative here
Rook G8 okay which is probably more
precise at least you're not given the E4
pound immediately so
Rook G8 and here if you play uh Bishop
E5 then
I think that after Bishop G4 you still
take only four and
[Music]
um
as well this is something like Bishop H3
Bishop H3 yes
hmm yeah the king
well short of squares but uh not trapped
yet
sure I mean it's good that it's holding
for black but it's a little bit
dangerous and Anna has to find accurate
moves here well it kind of goes back to
that and it was move 40 right 41 yeah it
kind of goes back to this position she
she had a time to study the position she
decided she took uh she spent 16 minutes
she
she must have felt that and she's she
has played the Mover of G8 as you've
advised uh Almera Rook to G8 and again a
move that attracts my eye Bishop F5
Bishop F6 to go uh Bishop G5 check I
take the pawn I became G6 which is why
Almera wanted to play Bishop to E5 I
also not allowed that King G6 sorry
please I have Bishop C5 if I want to win
the pound so let's say Bishop C5
threatening Bishop f8 yeah and then you
have to play Bishop G4 Bishop G4 here so
can give four and King G6 yeah just get
my king out of that uh situation where
I'm I'm really feeling like I could get
mated right that's that's pretty awkward
but uh King G6 with the idea Rook E8
the extra Pawn is not going to be enough
I mean the Bishops of opposite color
there's one good thing that's going on
in White's favor the H4 Pawn is the
right color uh Bishop uh
um to get the end game where you're
winning because of that good luck uh
that's a rock I get that I get that a
lot
let's just uh jump back because again uh
those of you who are joining us as late
shame on you but we do have a winner uh
Anna zatonski and the question is who's
going to get second well we may have an
answer yes Elizabeth just resigned so
Alexander Caster nuke at the moment in
the clear second only person who can
catch her is either in a crush if she
wins her game exactly
and boy I've got to tell you Alexandra
what a what a roller coaster ride she's
been on uh not many draws in her games
as her line scores have been and uh
victories and defeats but she she said
she was very happy with herself here
that she had gotten some classical chess
wins and uh enjoying last tournament she
only had one wins yeah so here she's
happy she won four games right I think
yeah
uh well uh
our former women's world champion will
likely join us to share what kind of a
tournament she's had two games remaining
we're going to jump to uh Nana's game
for a moment as the fight over G
6 G5 intensifies last moves were Rook G1
and okay the last few moves it looks
like Nana's been moving her Rooks which
may be preparing F4
is that why she put the Rooks on the
file well I thought I thought her
intention now that you mention it was
just to defend the F5 Pawn so she could
go G5 G4 but that's a good question
I if I'm white I'm trying to make a
blockade so I think I'm happy to see the
move F5 F4 and I'm not that I'm ready to
jump but I would really love to somehow
keep a light Square blockade
so only way for black to improve is to
push G5 I think so now the question is
how should you get it would you like to
play Rook F7 King G7 H6 G5 slowly slowly
slowly you know Advanced the pawn up the
board or is there another way Rook G8
and G5 something that we looked at
before book G8 but her last move was
hook f8 yes it's exactly instead of G8
so that makes me
think that she doesn't want to play G5
that way yeah
can we do oh no sorry that's my analysis
apologies let me just refresh my game
and my board so we're up to date and
these were the last few moves the white
has been waiting there's really nothing
that Nana can do and she's been moving
her Rooks back and forth in this exact
moment I would see say the move G6 G5 is
a threat so why needs to move Rook after
Jewel exactly I would see that as a
really rather obliged and again uh Arena
the only one who can stop who can share
the second I want to put it that way
with Alexandra needs to win a position
she's a pawn up but with the Bishops of
opposite color we don't think it's
sufficient it's nice to be extra Pawn up
but in this case uh what should I be
doing I probably I'd be I'd be anxious
to get my king off of six yeah I can
live with that
I'm ready to uh
again so unpleasant that your king can
come out true true I I don't uh
I don't claim a draw but I do uh but
you're saying but I can hold this Joy
even just passively passively let's take
a look at the updated standings as we've
got two games in the history books
all right so another chance K are a
winner with five and a half points she's
still playing her game and second place
Alexandra Costa New York with five
points
in the clubhouse with four and a half
finished her game so four and a half and
Irina Crush still playing her game with
four points trying to catch Alexandra
pretty certain that Arena's got a draw
in the pocket so she will be tied with
Bella for a third place they're really
hoping that she could tie with Alexandra
for the second
and we have Almera with our second place
finisher Alexander
uh welcome Alexandra congratulations it
is always nice to finish the tournament
and uh well on a positive note indeed
but for the moment you're also on the
clear second place well I have six out
of nine I'm sorry but I have six out of
nine I I know that I could have gotten
more or but that's that's it if there is
someone who sticks out of nine we're
gonna talk okay but yeah of course it's
a very very I mean I'm very happy to
finish on a win and to finish so well
because I mean this tournament as I
mentioned it's second in a row so the
fatigue the cold the disappointment of
this like stolen point I mean and
despite all uh like this um
uh oh yeah events uh going in in the
background I managed to play well and to
finish well so of course I cannot
complain
so tell us more about the game you
played today against uh Elizabeth Pitts
with the black pieces it was a highly
theoretical game yes that was an
anti-martial line and actually I looked
at this line before my game was Jean say
Abdul Malik because she played this line
but with C3 Bishop C2 I don't think it
should be dangerous for uh black because
I mean intuitively white just putting
the bishop on the wrong diagonal it was
there is a line with Bishop A2 which I
consider a little bit more dangerous and
I think I played well I mean so here's
the position yes so it's about equal
it's all about D5 right here D4 and D5
in this uh rui Lopez games and I was
very happy when on the 24th move I
played D5
I think I solved all my I mean problems
if there were any uh with this move and
then somehow I don't know what she did
wrong probably E5 was uh wrong because
then it started uh to be very difficult
for white and she was getting closer to
time travel and okay I'm just you know
threatening to take the spawn so if you
inaccurate decisions here led to a very
unpleasant position which is again it
can be holdable by a computer but its
own Pleasant to play in a practical game
on the time pressure and yeah then she
blundered on the 39th move although I
was not happy with my
attempts to win the game in time travel
instead of just capturing the pawn on um
A5 yes here for example Queen takes if I
I played Queen A7 although I see that
the game computer likes it yeah because
here okay she was going to play Queen B5
like capture I mean exchange actually I
have an extra opponent pair of Bishops
it should be enough to win but you know
it's going to be a long battle and you
want to finish it as uh as soon as
possible but here yeah somehow I thought
that Rook C2 is not going to be possible
due to rookie one uh but then I realized
that after Knight F1 Bishop A6 that I
was going to play I mean let's do Bishop
of B5 yeah I mean and there is nothing
and I mean I got disappointed
and I uh yeah played a switch to this
back to the plan of just getting a pawn
but she blundered by playing 93 instead
rookie 2 I think was the only way to
play and here well I was going to play
Bishop A6 to exchange everything to take
the pawn on A5 and okay
again a very pleasant position with an
extra Pawn but you know like you should
really demonstrate your Technique here
and when you're tired it's not so clear
so I was very happy when she played
Knight E3 the only problem here was you
know to pick which we uh after the time
travel when she played 96 check I mean
here I have two moves uh King G7 and
King H7 I was I was hesitating because
um like I thought that she was going to
play Bishop B5 anyway on both of them
and I was afraid that after Bishop B5
Queen B5 rookie to Queenie two okay here
I have to take on H6
A6 and it should be winning like D3
Queen takes these three Bishop D4 but I
thought what if you know during a
practical game you start like hesitating
what if it's not winning who cares that
you have an extra Bishop maybe it's a
fortress and I was so scared and I
played King to G7 okay I thought that
she was going to play Bishop B5 anyway
and then yeah same line but here I have
a choice I can also take on A5 Queen
takes A5 and I like this idea very much
but I was afraid also of Queen yet
um and then yeah somehow if I play
something like a D3 yes D3 well H4
doesn't work okay I thought that as we
will get closer I would decide whether
to whether to take on A5 or just simply
capture on H6 and play this uh end game
with an extra piece which should be
winning but sometimes you just get
scared of those ghosts you know and
yeah but now that we analyze this with
the computer uh you can see that it's
interesting yeah it was a very clean
game indeed uh Alexandria we had today
an interview with Judith poker and she
told us that
um later in the career it is very
difficult to find motivation so do you
still have goals
no not really I mean my like uh
the goals we can my goal is to play a
good game so like I take it game by game
and tournament by tournament and yes
indeed it's very hard to motivate
yourself not only play tournaments but
also work in between tournaments on
chess and sometimes I'm I'm not very
good in forcing myself to
um like sit and do this daily routine
that you must do unfortunately because
if you don't I'm in work at home then
kind of during tournaments you try to
like close this gap of theoretical
problems and like you run out of energy
sometimes and make mistakes but
uh
time after time I mean
I'm able to you know to play well and to
produce some nice games it keeps me
going
so how does your perfect day look like
there's no chest in it no no definitely
not
I mean there is some chairs but you know
just not to feel guilty because if I
don't study Chess at all I mean I have
this
unhappy voice inside me like complaining
that aha you didn't study I mean you
should have so no there is some chess
but just a little bit and but definitely
not in a tournament now I'm like I'm so
happy that it's like this classical part
of two tournaments in a rose over and
there is going to be one more very like
new event in Dubai as it started in less
than a week the global chest leak I
don't know what to expect but at least
it's a rapid event so I can rest from
the classical chess and but another
thing that I want to add what keeps me
going what is my motivation actually
um such tournaments or my motivation
because it's amazing I mean when I was
starting my chess career you know we
could have only dreamed about such
tournaments with such a price font with
such conditions and it's incredible I
mean I feel so grateful and lucky to be
able to play here like third time in a
row it's already for me it's quite an
achievement and of course I want to
thank the organizers for creating such a
dream come true tournament for women's
chess and that's probably why it's so
it's pity just to stop playing you know
at this point when there are so many
great tournaments and you just want to
play you cannot refuse such invitations
so that definitely keeps me going thank
you Alexander and you're one of the
greatest Fighters I think on the chess
scene yesterday do you have a question
first of all uh just congratulations for
an outstanding result we're forgetting
about the point that was taken away just
an outstanding result but also simply
for being an inspire operation thank you
Alexandra congrats Alexandra absolutely
as Alexander close to New York in the
clubhouse hoping for a clear second will
Arena Crush managed to uh
uh
catch her as the Shadows of the light
the Light Shadows that on the floor
there uh one look at the standings
before we take a quick break and as a
tasky is a champion no one can catch her
but in the second place at the moment is
Alexandra Costino and Irina crush is
trying to catch her and in the third
place Bella hotel is really with four
and a half points Alexander says give me
six points give me six points I I
deserve it I deserve it we'll see you on
the other side of a break for this uh
two games remaining Championship round
thank you
hello everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Bella Hotel Nashville Bella just won a
beautiful day the game today how do you
feel well after today's win four in a
row after your tough start uh yeah I'm
surprised then yeah I feel great that's
really good yesterday you had another
rest day yeah were you able to take some
time to yourself I kind of
did you spend a lot of time preparing
for today
what did you do yeah actually I prepared
party a lot but I did not prefer it
against this variation okay it was
surprised for me
um I relaxed I tried to harvest some
rest
because
um
last three rounds are mostly very
important during the tournament so I try
to keep my energy
of course of course last rounds are
always suffered it sometimes doesn't
matter the start as much but if you get
to con Focus then the end you can do
really you can do really well and you
can change a lot of things I wanted to
ask you about Hobbies do you have any
hobbies things that you like to do it
can be Sports too
oh I like reading reading reading yes
gardening uh yeah uh the both Sports I
do yoga yoga and then swimming
mostly I love walking
do you spend a lot of time walking
during a tournament I know it's
important you play very long games
during the tournaments I try to keep my
energy but sometimes I love to work but
for a much longer time okay so you spend
a lot of time preparing then you play
the game you relax a little bit and back
to preparation well something like this
I see I do something like a lot of
openings too repeat before the game so
yeah I have to prepare very hard you
have uh two more games now I believe
you're sharing first at the moment that
we're recording this
um are you thinking about winning the
competition or you try to take it a game
at a time actually I try to do my best
I am concentrated on each game I don't
think about the results for now
maybe after tomorrow
sounds good and last question who is
your favorite world champion
probably Magnus Carlsen mine too virtual
high five I'll give high five after
arrival and thank you so much wish you
good luck in the last rounds thank you
the St Louis chess club is the Premier
chess facility in the United States and
is among the best in the world thanks to
co-founders Dr Jeannie Karen sinkfield
and Rex sinkfield the St Louis chess
club is a non-profit organization
committed to promoting the game of chess
locally and internationally we bring the
educational benefits of Chess to
thousands of students across the St
Louis area promoting cognitive
development critical thinking
concentration and analytical skills the
St Louis chess club welcomes chess
lovers of any age and skill level to
come and enjoy the game of chess we also
promote Chess at the highest levels
posting all levels of the U.S
championships and the American Cup as
well as high-profile tournaments that
attract the world's best players
including the prestigious sync field cup
Cairns cup and many more all tournaments
can be streamed via our YouTube and
twitch channels that all also include
over 2 000 chess lectures for anyone to
enjoy become a member and enjoy perks
such as free classes and lectures weekly
tournaments merchandise discounts and so
much more visit
stlouischesclub.org to claim your
membership today
[Music]
meet me at the beauty
in Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
[Music]
hello everyone I'm here with Grandmaster
Nana had a beautiful game today
congratulations for your win against uh
Grandma sir Alexandra Costa new how do
you feel after having had a rough couple
of days but you're back does it feel
good to have won this game yeah of
course at least one game I managed to
win because after
this my game against Corner game which I
won
um
it was shock to me that after I won this
game after some three hours I got
message from the chief Arbiter that my
result canceled I know that was a very
unfortunate
situation I really don't know what's
what the rule is this and who is writing
such a rules it's really I mean not
since I think
and yeah it influenced I think uh the
next question because I I got absolutely
winning position
and I didn't do last two moves with the
bell I are talking right and yeah I got
another another shock there and so after
that yeah it was
very difficult to play chess
but yeah it is what it is what can I do
now yeah two more games so
that's unfortunately I'm a tournament
[Music]
it's not what it has to be
I understand that it was definitely a
tough and a shock for all of us but
of course health comes first and
hopefully Fida will come up with some
better
better rules and
extreme situations so that
players you know I don't know what the
role will be but hopefully they will
come up with something
if you have any ideas feel free to
please it shouldn't be like that how
it's possible you won the game
you earn that point you you work for it
I mean you are preparing some two three
hours before the game you played some
four or five hours game you earn the
point and after some hours they're
telling you that
[Music]
um
you don't have any points
I mean it was totally shocked to me and
I was expecting actually from them to I
mean right to feed and ask something I
don't know because it's such an absurd I
mean I mean
there is no doubt I think about it
so yeah after that it was really
difficult for me to contain continue
it's it's same spirits
and uh as the day off had helped you in
any way just kind of yeah yeah actually
maybe but actually after the day of I I
lost again yes I know but
yeah so
I'm looking forward to playing to last
around last two rounds okay some good
games and that's it today was was
definitely a good start people have been
asking about to learn more about the
players so I was wondering if you have
any other hobbies that you like to do of
course a chess is your main profession
but what hobbies do you have do you like
reading music yeah reading Walking but
most of the time this I just I spend
with my kids okay yeah
but
um yeah reading Walking and maybe
sometimes Fitness because it's really
when you're a professional just where it
really needs you to be in shape because
um we'll say now I'm I'm playing country
I'm in in a rows third tournament so
without like physical exercise yeah not
to be in a good shape it's impossible so
I tried to I mean stay in a good shape
do you have something specific that you
like to do swimming swimming yeah I do
some swimming some maybe yoga a Pilates
some boxing maybe wow okay those are
really nice a lot of chess players now
are doing chess uh and boxing and there
were some um
there was this uh match between
Alexandra botez and Dylan Dina belenke
how are you not Alexandra sorry Andrea
botez and were you watching that did you
I have no idea okay I'll tell you more
about it later
it was it was quite intense so they were
playing chess and and boxing it's it's
getting very intense uh last question
for you can you tell me what is the most
memorable game of yours one that maybe
brought to you uh winning a tournament
or a game that you are very proud of of
yours did you have one yeah exactly
before the pandemic when I won this um
in Switzerland and I read
world champion Jordan
yeah it was a very long game and uh I
did some good night manures I remember
and I won that's very decisive game and
after that I won this tournament because
after that game I was so confident and
uh yeah this game I think I will
remember always okay I will be sure to
check it out thank you so much nana I
wish you good luck in the last two
rounds and I'm glad you got your your
focus back together thank you
[Music]
thank you
welcome back everyone let's take a look
at our current standings anasutowski has
already won the tournament but she's
still playing her game meanwhile
Alexandra Costa nuke won her game and is
now sitting in the clear second and only
one who can catch her is Irina crush and
in the third place is Bella hotness
really with four and a half points
absolutely two games underway and that
game between Arena and Anna it's a pawn
up but I'm just looking at this position
and just saying No this is just one of
those uh positions we've got this
beautiful blockade on the light squares
and there's just no way I don't see any
possibility of Arena sneaking her Pawn
through the E6 Square this bishop is
beautifully anchored protects the rook
and The Rook can just go back and forth
you can defend the position passively I
don't think there's anything Arena can
do I do think Alexandra's got second
place wrapped up I think so I think it's
a pretty simple Fortress that Anna has
built and the there's no break in that
Fortress absolutely let's jump to the
game of Nana and gunay for just a moment
because uh for for goodness this would
be nice it's the championship round
she's not had a good tournament
whatsoever she started with a win and
she might finish with the one but that's
what I mean the book ends right
and I see that she's she she did manage
to get in the move G5 and she does have
the opportunity of playing Bishop H2
check uh kicking the king if you will
into high gear uh King F2 but then how
is she supposed to follow it up it feels
like Black's winning but I have to the
impression you need to be precise
okay what does the Oracle tell us about
goodness position
I don't want
chocolate
yes but here the variation is not
obvious once again because I looked at
the move Bishop H2 it's very simple but
now of course Rook H F6 protecting The
Rook uh on the face because you want to
take an A4 but unfortunately the red
screen of eight minutes so you need to
include Rook H F6 and here E5 he is also
very obvious reply but computer
continues with G4 wait for it it takes
F6 and Rook E8 wow it's crazy wow
it's a nice mating net it's a beautiful
do we see the next move by the computer
screen is seven
that's why I'm on strike
well you have good reason I I I'm with
you on that wow Queen E7 oh my goodness
uh tactics Galore suddenly out of
nowhere I don't think any of this will
happen on the board because from both
sides those moves were just alien chess
absolutely but Bishop H2 check King F2 I
think it's a more or less a requirement
you've got to really start with this
move and drive the king uh towards the
center by the way for those of you who
are joining us late you miss one of the
most beautiful winner Smiles you're ever
about to see because we're going to talk
show you Anna's moment of Victory which
we started the show with from yesterday
have a look
wow she almost ready to burst into tears
I think uh happiness as
E5 I don't think she has realized yet
that the other games went her way as
well right and that she's a few moves
away from winning the championship
because irina's games going to be a draw
right
and I don't know if you realize it yet
but you are about to well you won the
tournament wow
when I was living I was thinking here I
was not smiling I was thinking that if
it's dropped because like um quite
feeling like slightly misplaced and she
had to find a couple of exact moves wow
so you're very happy unbelievable
cannot believe it so this is probably
you
and there she is our 2023 Cairns Cup
champion
taking home 45 000 dollars and her first
GM Norm
congratulations Anna an inspiration uh
for us all uh as she's currently
defending uh the worst side of a
Bishop's of opposite color with Rook
ending uh and again arena is just hoping
it against hope that she'll be able to
pull it out and manage a victory so that
she can tie for first something that we
don't sorry apologies for a second
something that we don't expect today we
are wrapping up our coverage of 2023
Karen's cup it's been a wonderful
wonderful event but we have a lot of
people that we would like to thank most
importantly we're going to start with
Rex and a genie sinkfield for all of
their support that they do as well as
the staff here at the St Louis chess
club and Scholastic Center every time we
come there's Smiles they're here to help
us with everything so big thank yous to
Tony Ryan uh
yeah
who wears many hats and she's the reason
why every tournament in St Louis runs so
smoothly absolutely she's very very
welcoming but uh also so many people
that there right thank you to Randy and
his team at Spectrum Studios making the
production all possible yeah right Kevin
and everyone at the Silverback uh
Studios
and also the orbiters yes and Judith for
um managing the tournament so well and
the World Chess Hall of Fame itself our
host for uh the tournament uh site and
you saw Shannon Bailey uh here being
interviewed today and of course you
gotta you got a shout out to varusian
you know you know he keeps us on our
toes he tries our his best we do our
best trying to ignore him but uh vara's
good good people our producer Tom
Whispers in our ear says take us to
London and we believe him
thank you so Almira for bringing so much
light and positivity to our team
absolutely you've been wonderful thank
you so much and you too Nazi you you
said I remember this it wasn't that long
ago you had started the broadcast and
you said I'm nervous and I said what do
you have a handy right to be nervous
about and you you've been terrific still
nervous but you make it so easy for me
to work with you oh it's it's it's nice
so thank you and thank you everybody
show me that variation again that's a
crazy variation of Nana and good night
okay so we're starting with very obvious
move Bishop H2 check the king comes to
F2 The Rook is hanging so we defend the
room that looks pretty normal by the way
yes sir I wanted to just to point out so
if you don't play book hf6 and for
example you play Queen H4 here
computer says that white is already
better so just wanted to run you know
you have to be very very precise precise
here of course so then
Rook hf6 E5 very obvious move I need to
close the f file of course and now comes
the star move
G4 yes
so e takes of six and then the second
Stars wow great onion queen of three
mates so Queen is seven right and then
well we can continue Queen H4 check here
so kinky two you are taking the pawn
with the check right so King D1 and here
uh Queen H4 back so you protect the
bishop on H2 and let's have a look what
happens after Rook F5 because it's not
that obvious to me the computer suggests
Bishop F4 so you can pick up the Rook
after Rook F4 Queen H1 and well now of
course black is completely ringing but
what if you don't take so on F4 and
let's say what will be the 93 instead of
93 right but then you can take no I
meant sorry instead of Rook F5 ah no no
but here I wanted maybe to try King is
it possible what what if you
king queen H3 and then something like
crook F2 which
and Bishop H6 maybe so this is the end
of the line but it's highly complicated
well the start of the lines and I'm not
sure about the end of the line another
line looked like where my goodness so
far we have one move
uh well you always look at the most
forcing lines and always the most
forcing lines are checks and captures so
the check
is a good start uh defending the Rook
looks like a good start but here's the
trick right here you have to be careful
to not give another check with Queen H4
that's what I mean here the star move
for me is this move G4 and you just
invite your opponent to take the Rook
and then you play the quiet move rookie
eight that sets up the Checkmate thread
and kunai has minute and a half on the
clock oh my goodness if she sacrifices a
rook with one meat on the clock wow
we're not worthy that that would just be
an amazing line and then to get here and
see the move Queen E7 what a re what a
resource it
Bishop whoa whoa Bishop these wow that's
a very tricky oh whoa whoa whoa wait a
minute just a second Bishop D6 that
feels wrong just wrong but her idea is
if Knight takes D6 she wants to take on
e4 with a check exactly so she it's a
way for her to protect her Rook so sorry
you were about to say Knight takes D6
you takes it for a check and then she's
picking up a rook one of the Rooks
is she uh King E1 I have to take on F1
first Rook F1 by the way I didn't want
to play King E2 so you have to take on
yes Queen F3 check Queen F3 check
I can't cover on F2 because of Roku and
jackmate
I can't sorry say that again you can't
cover on F2 yes I can't block yes with
F2 Rook H1 mate I blocked with the queen
same story so I have to move my king
now you check and take the Rook yeah
you continue wait Rook do you want Queen
G3 yes so you can see okay then it's
going to be my turn
check quinja through and now remember
your king is pretty exposed right so I'm
gonna go King
uh D2 get him on my sneakers and it's my
turn to start giving you checks and
don't forget
so if I take what you want with the
queen am I getting mated uh maybe maybe
something Queenie five chat 26 okay wow
wow uh Bishop D6 at first it looks
really attractive because you're winning
a Tempo but then at the end of the day
Bishop D6
it's actually Black's King
and when she played the move I think she
played it with confidence like check
that check out this deliberate placement
yeah it doesn't look like a blender it
looks like Black's about to win exactly
sometimes that's very important to
convey hidden message to your opponent
that I'm confident
sometimes your opponent believes you
didn't take it please
check which isn't a bad move either
right I mean queen D4 check and you're
just saying you can't move your king
because that would be uh Rook takes G5
you've got to put something in the way
well if I play Rook F6
then you just take Knight takes D6 oh
I'm sorry I was actually gonna do
something else if you play Rook F6 I was
thinking I was just gonna close the f
file maybe I'll play E5 probably
the more I'm looking at it uh Almera the
move Bishop D6 sad to say it just looks
wrong it's just not working for black
yes so this move is actually losing and
you had 96 and queen D4 so Nana just
played Queen D4 after Rook
F6 Rook h of 6 you only can play E5 or
Knight D6 either one yeah either one
because she here
played Rook F6 with the afrook so let's
have a look at Rook F6 but here you can
take Knight D6 similar idea takes an E4
check and move the king yes and move the
king because the Rook is pinned once
again so you have no time to take the
Rook on G2 because I will take on F6 and
as you can see white is completely
winning right
uh just turn around yeah that final
position by the way it reminds me they
used to have these commercials the Cola
Wars they called them and it was like a
seven up versus Pepsi and it was sort of
like they would have the two chess
players in the park and one chess player
would would make a move and and say
check and the other player would make a
move and say Checkmate and I was like no
so this is one of those rare occasions
where you go check
Shack
and then the other player would okay you
you win and then you would take your
Pepsi or whatever
um check check that's that looks like a
winning variation but 22nd no that's
eight minutes right uh Nana has eight
minutes I'm gonna have one minute and 20
seconds actually I wanted to show you
what if here a white plays E5 and this
move is not winning compared to the
other situation just in case yes doesn't
take on G6 if she looks like a very
strong move but black has this very
strong move Rook H4 because now The Rook
is coming to F4 with a lot of checks so
uh what can you do here you can play
Queen G5 no Rook F4
king2 and a very lovely move Rook E4 so
no the queen was protecting The Rook on
G2 no once again yes so I did take C4
Queen G2 uh Rook F2 Queen G4 and I guess
uh there is a Perpetual somewhere wow uh
rookie for a check is quite the visual
uh but but in this current situation
Knight takes D6 and King F1 uh that's
like very very clean I want to say that
that's a nice win for white E4 E5 just
the moment you see Rook H4 it has the
feel of something's wrong it's exactly
at this moment do you think uh gunai now
realizes that Bishop D6
definitely realizes and she probably
regrets pushing well everything she did
she takes D6 on the board the attack on
the king side was correct but the
problem was she she left herself no time
and when it came to the most critical
moment of the game she had to find such
difficult moves with one minute on the
clock exactly that's where things start
to fall apart and the players are
reaching that position of check check uh
nothing better in the position than to
make the Discover check
King will
Retreat and queen takes Rook takes and
this is where it goes wrong
Rook f
cover check let's just check in on Arena
because oops Yeah so F takes E4 on the
board
because again uh
Arena Crush
hasn't has a chance at least playing for
a second
place but she must win this position
that's an interesting decision why did
you push D5 no I was wondering why Anna
put her King on a dark Square I think
she's just moving it back and forth okay
yeah it's just like wait a minute
I'm living on the light scores that's
all I know
streams writing back and forth because I
don't see how white can improve
if I remove my rook and Bishop right
yeah you can put your Rook on D6 invite
a rook trade but I won't do that I will
keep the blockade but yeah I was
thinking I'm just staying on the light
squares draw is inevitable let's go back
to the game uh King E1 on the board
and good night I think made a move on
six with six seconds on the clock Queen
H4 check as this horrible awareness that
she's just
uh too bad that Rook on F6 is pinned
otherwise exactly should be cruising
here but just King day one King D1 Rook
F2 absolutely I should maybe not King D2
allow an E3 check that's the one thing I
was about to say
and the the the game flares are new I
love your king D1 I also saw Rook F2 uh
just uh
you know I hate pinning but in this
particular case on Rook up two can I
still play E3
strangers so many pins right right
uh
well okay Queen takes and this is a pin
but this is I know and it's not these
winning but it's not the cleanest wind
that I've ever done maybe E3 check
807 check
interesting
and then take the Rook
I also saw a little perplexing too and
this guy I think is his toast well okay
uh but probably King D1 is even the
simplest of them all in my Rook uh G2 to
F2 is a little except excessive King D1
no E3 checks
no Rook takes F1 nothing to be done
yeah I think this game is
going to be over very soon by the way in
our thanking everybody we always managed
to forget somebody in this case I really
want to say a big shout out to Sabina
and all that she's done on the social
media networks I mentioned something oh
you did okay well she deserves a second
shout out uh she really did a lot behind
the scenes and interviewed us we had a
lot of fun with a lot of those
interviews unfortunately uh not
everybody gets a chance to see them
because we can't put everything on the
air and that's why we have other social
media channels exactly where you can see
everything behind the scenes about the
tournament about the players
thank you Sabina thank you very much
indeed
um we did have King D1 on a spotted that
moment and we do have takes on C3 I'm
supposing you mentioned Knight F7 check
but I'm supposing uh Knight E4
that looks like a re I mean the one
thing I we have to be very cognizant
about is this one
uh
I was going to be excessively silly uh
Knight F7 check and Rook takes G5 check
yes why not
grabbing a pawn
and it's actually I played in two I
think you should have happened
King j7 and Rook G5 Rook G5 check and uh
this one it's gotta be a mate here right
you think probably
uh
Queen G7 and Rook
fine or queen d8 queen G8 rookie five
what should we winning yes yes
um
she plays Knight E4 which is also very
very very prosaic uh the most natural
move in the position I would say is
Knight E4 uh blocking the threat
reinforcing the capture on F6 and the
king is perfectly perfectly safe and
ready to dance away
well uh not a perfect game for Nana but
a victory nonetheless inside Almera for
Nana in this final round well you remind
me of the Italian Masters you know who
discovered the power of the new piece
the queen you know during the
Renaissance period so I well you seem to
enjoy this position as well but I wanted
to show you a funny moment uh in this
position
uh Anna just played King G6 and they
said is there any possibility to improve
you know so avoid's position at least in
some way but that's where you sometimes
over push your position and if you play
King D5 Bishop F3 mates I found that
this is absolutely incredible that even
with a pound down you can actually mate
your opponents in the middle of the
board yes in the middle of the world
because you attack the rock you think
the rock will retreat but now the bishop
is stuck on G4 then I will play Rook D7
D6 something like this but actually
Bishop F3 is a very elegant mate it
certainly is everybody I mean everybody
remembers Nigel short moving his King up
the board against Jan Timon and
checkmating his opponent on G7 but what
a lot of people don't know is Nigel did
absolutely the same thing in a game in
monares he was is much better moved his
King up the board against
um
Big Al Alex
bellieski Alexander belliovsky moved his
King up the board and
uh Big Al played check that happened to
be Checkmate
literally Nigel moved his King into
Checkmate and uh well there we have it
uh Nana has won and that that Victory
and take a look at the standings that
that might kind of boost her up the
rankings there yes as we see she's now
in a tie for fourth yeah and as Irina is
drawing her game I think Nana is going
to get a clear fifth place exactly
and because the price fund has been so
very generous to our players that uh
that feels good and just winning uh
finishing the tournament with the win is
always a good feeling exactly exactly
but it's disappointing for goodness she
was the one pushing for a win today
right yes and once again to remind
everybody
of the generous Price Club right total
of 180 000 in prizes and as a transcript
will be taking home 45
000 Alexandra Costa nuke 35 000.
currently with uh with Arena hoping that
it will be split and looks like Bella
and the arena will share third and
fourth prizes 25 and 20 uh thousand so
22 and thousand and again a grand master
Norm for our 2023 Karen Scott Champion
and I
and our summer time to
tend to also I was informed she didn't
know but she was informed that the
defending Champion is always inviting
invited back to the tournament and she
said oh very good she's already looking
forward to next year's Karen's Cup
Championship she can make a second Gym
Norm right
very very nice and Anna is still playing
I wonder how much time did she spend at
the board during this tournament she had
the longest games I believe of everybody
she's by moves right because she played
long end games yeah at least half the
time it feels like in the broadcast that
we've done of the US championships over
the years of this one game remaining in
the playing Hall it evolves Anna she
loves her endings and yes uh I would say
she's probably played the most number of
moves of anybody of any competitor the
tournament here although she's defending
blockading very nicely this
e-pawn with a rook on E6 I would be so
anxious to put my king on E8 and I would
say to myself no way is that King ever
going to get out of the way of the
e-pond and it's just such a
form to my way of thinking such a very
very clear and direct path to a draw 40
seconds on the clock for him yes and in
order to claim a draw she needs to make
50 moves without changing the position
and upon E5 was pushed on move 55 so we
may see the game go on until 105 and
we're currently at
57. buckle up
because when you're upon up I mean you
know where there's where there's a
chance you you you have to you have to
do your very very best I mean if Anna
had one hour on the clock I think Irena
made give up and try it but with 40
seconds you can easily blunder
especially as the game goes on and they
keep playing an hour later she'll be a
lot more tired right it's it takes one
blunder too
change the result of the game
um for yourself
well I was listening again I would never
be just out of the Primal Fear of
blundering anything I'm not putting
anything on light squares I'm not
putting anything on Dark squares uh
would you be uh yeah I wanted to ask
would you be
uh would you agree with me that you
would put your King on E8 or do you like
the King on G6 I like this setup I like
I would like to keep everything this way
so just move pieces back and forth and
not change it
really uh okay I find that intriguing
and I would be
slightly miffed
that my my king
has been cut off
but if you're on the last rank it can be
cut off from the seventh rank right so
so in this case uh there's a chance I
can lose the game right so I I don't
want to allow this possibility which is
why I think Rook A6 so King the now
Bishop will come to E6 yeah
and I can also Play Bishop H3
if I need to
and back right
so Almera jump in here uh I'm sure the
engine is as finding uh zero zeros but
uh
um any tricky trickies that Arena could
possibly come up with not really but I
um I tried a different setup for example
after Rook F2 I think that Irina wants
to play Bishop C5 okay I like that and
Bishop D6 because the Rook is stuck on a
six maybe uh once again you will you
will feel pressure at least a little bit
so after okay six I try to play
Rook C5 if you play rookie six Bishop D6
that's why Irina played Rook F2 so you
don't have Bishop F5 anymore so
um what can you do here Rook G7 or
Bishop H3 maybe bishop H3 is more
stubborn okay now I have my position
with King D5 but I'm not sure this is
enough once again because uh Bishop G4
and I don't know how to continue here
because Rook f8 has always met by King
G7 and yes and four is met with Bishop
H3
yes and uh sorry
okay four yes sir okay four yes you can
there is no soups unfortunately here so
and you always have rookie E8 just in
case right right I mean if the road goes
on the other side so you cannot play
Rook F6 checks so
um we do have King D5 on the board uh by
Arena
well King D5 it doesn't change much why
can't I
give check here because King D4 I simply
go back on G4 good point uh thank you
Almera for that
um
you know no draw offers right so you're
gonna have to make a three-time
repetition but would you be giving it up
at this point uh would you think that I
should be going for the 50 move rule or
how would you play this position with
white says my opponent has one minute I
would keep playing for a while that's
what I'm I'm thinking right that that's
the encouraging Factor whenever your
opponent's down on the clock as well as
down on material you certainly will feel
like you should press as much as you can
even though
you might be just uh
guarantee as far as there is no reason
for why to accept the draw now right
of course both players know Etc but we
also know that you can squeeze and
squeeze and make your opponent
uncomfortable exactly until they
get too tired and blunder we hope so
Bishop E6 check uh something to be said
for King C5 King B5 trying to cross
King C5 I can come back with the bishop
and
clear up the square on E6 for The Rook
and I'm back right you are uh
maybe oh here I was thinking if Irina
can get the bishop on D6 then King can
sneak in but I can't move the bishop
because E5 sure
exactly even if the Kinks mix in doesn't
change anything yeah and uh Almera with
a Gaston Studio over to you Almera I'm
joined in the studio by Nana welcome
congratulations uh you finished the
tournament with the win
uh tell us more about your game
um at this moment I think that there is
a very important decision yes I mean
when she gave gave me this bishop I
already felt very satisfied and I think
but I think instead of Knight F3 I
should have taken with Bishop
it's more accurate I think and after
that this castle and E4 and the white
must be yeah a bit better yeah
because I have pairs of Bishops and yeah
but after Knight F3 I gave her all these
ideas with Bishop ace3 because if black
exchanged this dark Square Bishop I
think they are fine
Queen A5 and
kc3 or queen D2 the method Queen A3 and
I think black has no problem here
that's why I decided to keep my bishop
and yeah Bishop but uh
here are suddenly Blake's got this
very good play on the dark squares I
don't know if I played
correctly here or not I don't know
but I was calculating this I was
calculated calculating instead of E4
night night E5 with idea Knight C4 but
what I didn't like here B5 maybe B5 and
and uh Rook I would say I was thinking
like group B1
F6 like Knight C4 BT C4 B takes C4 and
Knight C7 she has because I was
calculated B6 she doesn't turn Knight B6
because I have
foreign
so yeah
but yeah here I have some weaknesses
[Music]
it's for it was more or less balanced
position yes but at some point I was
trying to create something but
I don't know
G4 yeah
um
this Pawn struggage structure is very
strange because I didn't know which
piece to exchange and which to save yeah
we just keep and okay later on please
continue I had a chance like later on to
keep like
bishop or to exchange with knights so
yeah here I'm worse
I know because my Pawn structure is
terrible
and yeah I I I don't know somehow I saw
this idea and I take Knight A5 Bishop A4
Knight C6 something like this but she
was in the time travel and I I that's
why I had the chance otherwise position
is bad
and here yeah here I was thinking to
play Knight C6
um
like if she gives me this uh Bishop B8
then I think okay still worse but more
or less I have drawing just like this
yes I thought yes
yes and maybe I will exchange this
bishop at night also
and maybe I have some drawing chances
here yes this is balance yeah and but
here you took me I took I I yeah I took
on E8 I decided to give this bishop this
night here nice friend I thought
I keep balance but I don't know because
black has big advantage on King side so
at the end this Knight took everything
yes
I was very surprised because you know I
missed this please continue this is
worse I know continue
and here after G5 after G5 and I played
Queen F2 I thought I after Queen H3 I
have Rook G5 but I absolutely forgot she
has Rook G8 I think this is the only
move which wins are or is there any
other just even Queen H6 because if you
open the G file six let's say if I go
Queen G2
but somehow yeah after E4
it I mean when I played E4 of uh C4 E4
no no E4 before
yeah I don't know because I got some you
know crucified some thread
to be honest I didn't see how how she
could win immediately I don't know she
played Luke Cage but after Queen C5 here
yeah she went I think Bishop H2 and
after King F2 Rook hf6 that's where I
was yeah correct yeah that's what I was
thinking and here if I maybe yeah
crazy life yes I was concluding this
section
yes uh queen of no I think I should I
should have shouldn't take this
uh Rook Maybe
I don't know Queen D5 or something where
I don't know something I I was
calculating but I don't know this is
crazy
um so it then your opponent and yourself
you were in a time travel yeah she was
in time travel that she that's why she
couldn't find this Rook hf6 because
after Bishop D6 I think it's already
lost
correct so yes this at the end
everything was crystal clear
um no no so now the tournament is over
so more you have a free day
are you going on a shopping spree
tomorrow more shoes
so I will I think whole day I will sleep
tomorrow because no energy for shopping
I love shopping when I arrived here
first thing which I've done here was
shopping I called to the organizer and
ask ask him to take me to the shopping
center
but now I'm totally I mean exhausted yes
I think it's important to to talk about
how well exhausted actually players are
after the end of the tournament because
you used all your energy the chess
tournaments are actually very long so
you're playing the second tournament in
a row yes and I didn't expect it to
would have been such a tough like two
tournaments in a row Grand Prix in here
if I knew it I think I would have chosen
one tournament only okay how do you
train
physically physically
I trained usually I told my train but I
don't know if it helped helped me here
or not because
it was really one of the toughest
tournament in my age is career I would
say
thank you I know thank you
since uh Nana finishing on a very high
note indeed
um well done well done a nice game
especially at the end there where okay
the tactics
took over as she's earned time to
wrestler now she's earned it absolutely
a lot of people really don't get that
that you can be totally exhausted after
a tournament because you're Zapped
mentally you put oh you know all your
your nervous energy your mental energy
your preparation into the tournament and
you just feel like you fell across the
Finish Line you didn't yes you know
exultantly cross the finish line also
until you finish you're still running on
adrenaline yeah and then as soon as the
last game's over you just crash exactly
and then you realize how tired you
actually are exactly as we've got uh one
game remaining uh the great rivalry
surprise surprise as the two American
contenders in the tournament Anna and
Arena are going head-to-head Arena's
upon up but it's not enough as the light
Square blockade on the E6 square is
going to be sufficient but that doesn't
mean that Arena isn't going to try her
best to put as many problems as she can
in front of Anna but has she changed the
position or is it the same if Black Goes
rookie six now uh I suppose the idea as
Almera was mentioning
give I don't know how do we do it let's
let's give
the best case scenario if you will for
just a moment by the way Anna making
moves with 11 seconds on the clock so
once again okay so in a sense this is
the maximum that white can achieve she's
got her Bishop on D6 which more or less
isn't snaring uh The Rook on E6 can't
move Bishop H3 here
right so I the the one trick I have is I
want to play Rook g eight check and if
King goes to h file then Rook takes G4
so your Bishop H3 more or less Dodges
the threat right so I I've achieved the
maximum but that's it
going around with the king king C6 okay
um don't know where I'm going but I'm
going but the problem is like a
desirable yeah D7 just steps in into a
I can go to C7 and then d8 and that's it
exactly
you brought her key back let me just
refresh my board for a moment here and I
tell you if we if Sabina does have any
uh of our viewers questions now is a
very good time because well we don't
have too much to talk about it's just
the clock and the number of moves uh the
50 move rule is uh well it's not looming
large because I think you told me
107. we're getting there now we are on
move 69 and 105 would be the 50 105 105.
uh Rook uh B6 Tempo and rookies who
mentioned Irina also caught up on time
with Anna so she's also please just a
few seconds on the clock well I think
that the commentators are dreaming about
their dinner so
that too I don't want to State the
obvious there but I had the question in
mind for yesterday if you have a
favorite dish if there is something that
makes you so happy like a cake from your
childhood
wow well for me it's very very simple
chocolate
hey chocolate anytime a day or night
chocolate is good chocolate is good uh
as far as dishes are concerned I must
say I really really love Asian food I
love Japanese food I love Indian food I
love
just Chinese food every type of Asian
food just something about the spices and
the combinations
fantastic I also have a lot of favorites
but I would say my comfort food anything
that my mom cooks
mom says it's actually a very good Baker
and I love baked goods yes that's why I
was talking about the cakes but maybe my
favorite dish from the Georgian Cuisine
the khachapure
how about yourself Amir well I really
love one cake that my mom used to make
it's and it's actually has a French name
it's called Napoleon I love that cake
yes wait a minute as we've been talking
I've been a little bit surprised that
Anna is allowed the pawn to get to Essex
or has she Rook F6 check
why didn't she just keep her Rook on E6
she could have of course of course I
drove but she did allow why is it still
a draw King just happened King G7 Bishop
f a check
s
oh boy
I don't have E6 sorry I just maybe you
can play Bishop H6 here after King G8 so
yeah for some reason I just King G7
Bishop f8 check by the way that uh what
you were saying about the clock you're
beginning to see the players react right
so now Bishop H6 I want to go E6 right
right so I guess I'm going to be forced
to play sure do you give any checks
I don't know yet uh but if I go rookie
one you can't really improve right
eventually you're going to have to give
King D5
and then I'll give a check and I'll go
back
um
strange decision uh Almera by
Anna your Rook was sitting pretty on E6
and we were just kind of expecting that
maybe she would move their Bishop a
shuttle or Bishop back and forth between
G4 and F5 or H3 and G4 she moved her
Rook voluntarily to the e-file a
surprising decision a very surprising
decision indeed and I actually like the
move Arena just made on the board King
D5
it puts a lot of pressure on Anna
because she cannot make a forced move
so there is it's not like Bishop f8 King
G8 and then you give checks but after
King D5 you have to find out where do
you keep your Rook right
so Rook D1 maybe bishop D4 and you don't
have the bishop F3 check because Rook
takes F3 exactly
and E5 I mean whenever I get to play
uh for the E5 E6 well you know this and
this is dangerous now well that's what
I'm saying why it will keep the Rook on
E6 even if the engine still says triple
zeros I'm saying there's a practical uh
reality well the engine says now almost
class three after Bishop
whoa
wow white is actually winning
wow E6 is Unstoppable and then you don't
have a fortress anymore we we in fact I
believe we start now with E6 I mean this
is a dream come true for arena she could
never have anticipated that her
opponent would give up the blockade of
the E6 Square
definitely strange because Anna was
defending with Rook on E64 absolutely
already moves and all of a sudden
decided to
move away with them yeah yeah yeah great
a stunning turnover events and if Arena
were to win this game well she would tie
for a second yes that would be yeah
that's very unexpected we we've been
calling this game a drove for the last
three hours and where was that blunder
what was the mistake that uh was it Rook
E1 is that
Rogue D1 Rook D1 so here she's already
loses
much worse she had to keep her book on
the a trunk or to move her Bishop
so right now there's just one more cage
in the current position Rook H6 is just
Checkmate I mean you have to sacrifice
your bishop and you're absolutely right
that is Checkmate indeed and she see oh
I was about to say she sees it and then
she went Rook G6
oh oh
wow and now you cannot play King f8 only
King H7 is the only move King f8 does
walk into a Checkmate Bishop C5 and Rook
G8 would be the Checkmate but with the
move King H7
and the fact that you've got your Pawn
knowledge
oh my
God
that is a very okay I think this is
tiredness yeah tiredness in time trouble
because they've been in time trouble for
a long time and it gets to you at some
point exactly but that Rook H6 is a very
visual move because the pawn is covering
F7 and you're threatening mate but uh
after E7 now in the current position let
me just refresh my board part again and
I just play Bishop D7
in fact she's going to be forced to play
it right yes so how does Bishop D7 I
guess I'm going to play King six
Bishop sorry I was thinking Bishop F6 to
defend E7 and then look G8
yes
yes oh yeah I I don't think it's a
difficult
win
for uh Arena because you don't have King
D6 I have Rook D1
j7 true so no I was thinking uh
yeah
right right sorry yes
Bishop F6 yes
and Bishop D7 on the board
wow
suddenness of the turnaround I think is
kind of I shock this will happen while
we're talking about cakes
uh we're having a good time right my
favorite dessert well let me tell you
whenever I can win a pawn yeah that's uh
that's it
wow oh no King D6 right now Rook T1
hold on what just happened is Rook D1 is
a draw
King decency
no way hold on wait do you know how it's
a draw no King the seven Rook D1 yes
King E8
what sorry you're playing Rook do one ah
she missed it but let's show the players
oh my gosh it's going back and forth
like a hot potato King takes the seven
yeah King takes D7 54. and black should
be winning because I'm about to take the
Rook but kingy eight stalemate
oh my gosh
oh my gosh that was terrible but Bishop
A4 Returns the favor
now she moves her Rook Rook to G8
and she's reaching for it and she's
played it Rook G8 is the winning move
oh my gosh uh just uh tiredness once
again I mean they're on move 79 they
must be and this is the last round of a
very long tournament well not a set of
best I'm totally exhausted she can't
even do what she loves to do what
happened she's that tired yes okay but
Rook G8 and why is this so absolutely
absolutely over I mean for the moment it
would appear
that black is covering the promotion
Square so let's say I start with King
age I probably can't hold it for too
long
okay eight
okay oh I have an idea I can play Bishop
E5 so I'll start with rookie eight and
then Bishop E5 that's so
after you after you push my Bishop right
now you okay
yes
one move too late but if she were to
manage to sacrifice the bishop for the
pawn
and take the H4 Pawn then it's a draw
rate yeah
yeah recognition yeah but H4 Pawn is
hard to take because white Bishop will
defend it
uh
I I'm trying to uh
I think it was against I'm not really
too sure but but I had one of those
games that were witnessing right now
where we both
it was like a case of mutual blindness
and we were both uh my opponent and I
were tossing the point back and forth
between ourselves uh it's not as
uncommon as you think uh King C5
okay I have to go back okay one
stop your Pawn she's done that
but I also liked your move from before
which was to plant the bishop on F6 just
to make sure but here can't you go
hunting with the Rook uh Rook A8
yes rookie rookie seven Rook takes A4
and I don't have rookie four exactly
Rook a a rook E7 what you're trying to
do of course is to sacrifice your Bishop
for the remaining pawns but as you say
you don't have the move Rook before
because of the Discover check
well we may be as tired as the players
but you're still spotting the tactics I
mean not my game
well we say in chess that kibitzer see
everything right with sirs uh let me
just refresh my board pardon me
she played the bishop of six months very
natural move I must say at this point in
in the event you really want to make
sure you've got everything protected
before you go uh hunting the bishop and
chasing it off the diagonal
and I think it's actually possible to do
that it's not a very long diagonal the
combination of The Rook
and the King should
suffice
yes um I wonder what made Anna change
her mind about that setup with Rook on
E6 I thought it was the ideal blockade
and again when The Rook was on E6 and
the bishop was on G4 I would have been
putting my king on E8 as well like my
second line of defense so to speak not
to allow back up for you yeah backup
fortification of a blockade on the light
squares
Almera is this the position where the
wind is is simple I it's still it's
requiring some efforts right yes it's
still uh requires some effort here maybe
the most stubborn was rookie 6. not King
age seven but Bishop G5 King H7 Rook 8
yeah
and the current position after King H7
what's the what's the Sim I'm looking
for Simplicity do we have uh are we at
that moment where we can at last claim
an easy simple solution Rook A8 perhaps
yep she's done it
Bishop D7 king of D6 yep I'm running out
of uh it should be five squares from my
Bishop Bishop B5 but now you can play
Bishop B5 that's the key move yeah I
like that move that stops okay but hold
on you you gave me a a hope
I'm gonna play Rook E4 and invite you to
make a queen
well let's say you take and you take on
H4 but if I play
Rook B8 here you simply Play Bishop
A4
King G6 on whoa whoa King G6 on the
board sorry she left the bishop hanging
so if white plays Bishop C3 here it's
game over because on rookie 4 Rook takes
A4
that's clear and she's reaching for
Bishop to G5
I think yesterday that even if you take
on H4 I can still Queen and bring my
queen to E6 and he will not be able to
escape so you're saying the rook and
Bishop versus Rook position would
actually be one of those cases where
there it's winning because black king is
in the right corner in the dark Square
corner and because of the Pawn on H5 it
can get out easily yes and you cannot
give lateral checks I see uh Bishop D7
on the board once again Almera is there
a I I just I'm just uh give me an easy
win
is there an is there any such thing in
this tournament as an easy win somebody
please give me a present
well King D6 on the board yes King D6
and Bishop B5 yeah okay
then they will have to repeat they think
moves a few times maybe rookie G8 oh I
do have a trick for you when your Bishop
gets to A4 so I will go after Bishop B5
Rook to ba so the idea is I want to push
your Bishop to A4 so that I give you a
check
and in this case
you can't go up the board
because I I'll pick up the the bishop
thank you so after check you have to go
back to H7 and then I will
try to pick up
sub 10 people it should be five back and
now I like this bishop transpose into
the same position we had yeah but I want
to to put the king back on H7 if that is
significant or not
and by the way just being informed that
this is their 32nd Tournament game
together when you include all of the
rapid and Blitz and classical chess
together I think they know each other
pretty well that's uh I could almost
write a book on their clashes that's not
let's not forget this the players have
been teammates for two decades
oh
I should kind of rolled itself to the D5
Square can mailbox have a new setup with
King on F7 yeah now it's located once
again well yeah I was about to say
didn't didn't that move just make it
easier another draw position another
another Fortress position suddenly and
the king is actually
do you want Rook is going to get itself
cut off right Rook D1 I love that setup
where the bishop was on E5 the King was
on D6 The Rook was patrolling the eighth
Rank and I was about to Queen
I mean Irina had a simple Bishop set
removed I was attacking rook and the
bishop that would end the game on the
spot wow which was missed and now Anna
has a fortress again
yes because the idea actually is oh she
didn't play Rook D1 because if you play
rookie 6 Rook F6 with the idea of
playing uh Rook f8 you you had Rook D7
and rookie seven
when What's Happening Here is why it's
still winning after Bishop F7 lets me
have a look Rook A6 check so the king is
forced to uh step back either to G7 or
H7 again I I I would instinctively I'd
be putting my cane on the light square
and playing King H7 just so that I don't
blunder into some kind of a mate but how
am I how is Arena gonna break this
Fortress if not by putting her Bishop on
E5 and her King on D6
I don't see any other way
the bishop
if you go King to d8 I'm gonna chase you
yeah I have to start with Rookery six
Rook to D6 okay
make sense
and I will Rookie for
28 okay and wait and I need Rook d three
Bishop B3 or something like that
should be rookie 3 here
or not because you have looked before
checking before exactly by the way I
think this is a good move by Irina King
apartment uh Let me refresh my board
Rook H6 check just to get the king
on a dark Square
you never know
both to D6 now yes
wow uh
I wouldn't have imagined that White Pond
would make it all the way to the second
exactly
I think
Alexandra's in the hotel room just
looking at this game saying come on Anna
keep your undefeated uh streak intact
I mean I still wouldn't call this game
because it's not that easy to break
through no especially with no time the
players have been playing on increment
Amira yes I wanted to get back to this
moment where Irina played a different
move but here after Bishop E5 actually
so after Bishop B5 this is the setup
which you needed to like I have it on my
board that's the position and that's
where you can play Bishop E5 I suggested
that black would play rookie four so uh
guarding the E8 square and taken on H4
but I really struggled to find
the way that black can actually get out
of this
yes after King E6 I think that and now
yes and the computer agrees with me that
you're getting mated in 11 or 12 moves
King F7 Bishop F6 and Rook h8 so let's
say maybe uh we'll make a rook Rook G4
more stubborn defense so anything gives
them black didn't have that H5 one that
would have Rook G7
yes one is a problem yes
so keying age six Bishop F6 taking the
G5 square right and now well with the
mates
which will follow Rook h8 then you have
to give up The Rook here wow
so that was an easy win you were asking
me for an easy win yeah
and that was a long long time ago as
this situation
is not easy it's not easy can she play
Bishop E5 right now
so Bishop E5 in this moment I will
probably play rookie one rookie six
I'm playing with fire uh
okay that's a visual Rook E6
uh are you sure you're gonna win Rook
condition Rick and Bishop versus queen
probably you are uh I mean I might be
is it even a winner I don't know
I don't know but definitely rookie six
is a visual move
she has played Bishop to D4 once again I
am sorry I keep
um refreshing my board to get an
up-to-date board 41 seconds versus 50
seconds
yeah so now I think Irina needs to
find a setup
so that she can push the e-pawn
and win the bishop indeed it's not easy
so if I come back rookie one
for working one makes sense you've been
upon and I'm going to play I'm assuming
I want to play King d8 as well as king
D7 so to keep the Rook rookie four tied
Rook E4 okay
now at some point
I'm just sending a little key too
you're just standing
just standing
there because since like it was better
when Keith was on D6 and Rook was on the
eighth rank because then Bishop E5 was
winning right
here
you can Bishop
can't block e-files as easily
ah
can I well uh
I want to be able to play Rook F6 right
but then you're going to play King no
sorry let me just
wait for just a moment
Bishop C3
Bishop F6 Arena how many seconds three
seconds I hate to look at her I hate to
look at her clock but she just made a
move with three seconds
uh
you can really get carried away with
calculating lines here and forget about
the time
indeed
and for Anna the same situation 15
seconds and counting
a very very nervous endgame Affair can
you imagine seconds
if Anna had five points right now and
they were playing for the first place
right
position right
Bishop E8 wait a minute doesn't that
just invite Rook d8
oh no there's King G6
King wow thank you first oh that's
that's back in that Fortress that was
the Fortress we wanted and then she had
rejected it she get sir King to F7
King goes to F7 right and Rook takes EA
King takes you think you have a Tempo no
you don't I have a check
oh pardon me I can just take the Rook
that's even simplest yeah I apologize
that's the simplest of all taking the
Rook but now
Anna has achieved
another Fortress yes with the King on F7
uh defending the bishop The Rook will be
able to come behind and I don't think
you'll be able to break that one
by the way is
if I take the if I go Rook here and
consecutively I take that's another
theoretical end game another thing yes
that will be uh
uh oh there was some uh fast fast hands
there C4 check kicking the king
I was about to say somebody uh was
worried about their clock
at last
Rook check
King 56 56 and then King gives up
King
now I'll I'll end up having to bring my
Rook back to the file right she played
King B6 king of I'm I'm almost forced to
bring and then if I put my Rook on f8 by
going here and here and here black is
just going to go King here and King here
and maintain the bishop on E8 and that
should be good enough for the draw
yeah because he says hopefully
yes I think Anna knows now that she can
hold this again right
she looks more confident
so she can just play King E6 here right
and then depending where White's root
goes she goes to D7 or F7 makes to me
because heruk is cutting off White's
King so I wouldn't touch the Rook no no
The Rook is doing a great job on uh C4 I
like your king E6 very much like you say
as soon as the Rook goes to d8 I'll
bring the king back to F7 and as soon as
the Rook goes to f8 I'll bring the king
back to D7 so I love this move King E6
yes
you can also give one check for the Crux
of six doesn't do any damage
closer also keep in mind the 50 move
rule is undone every time we move a pawn
then we have to count 50 moves onwards
after a pawn move so any trades and the
50 move rule was reset any pawn moves
and the 50 move rule is reset and the
pawn was pushed to E7 on move 77. which
means you add 50.
so we wouldn't want 27 127. six seconds
three
two oh
yeah and we were just saying you
wouldn't give up The Rook on C4 because
the Rook uh she may have met with one
second on the clock no way
oh my
I mean this position is still drawn but
why oh why I thought you forgot about
time for us she may very well have uh
because going down to one second
uh
roller coaster well
at my age
they shouldn't be allowed to do this
this is uh is it that was a
hard-stopping moment there good for
Anna's Health that she is not playing
for the first
the first heat first place exactly
otherwise her heart would be exploding
right
cardiovascular I think there was there's
been some tournaments
recently where they put the heart
monitor machine and she didn't play King
E6 and King to D7 but she played King to
G6
uh
allowing white that opportunity to force
the bishop away from the E8 Square
yes and you were mentioned the
tournament I think it's in Germany
Berlin right they have this armagero
tournament right with the smart watches
where you can see the player's heart
rate
and I watched some of it and some
players heart rates went to 180.
we lost the patience we have to run so
fast
that high but chess does it by just
looking at your clock and saying five
seconds on it Bishop Alpha 7.
still a draw I think it's still a draw
or
wow still a draw holy oh my
check King G7
should be making that instantly exactly
I mean
it's actually
Super Force there is no alternative
she used to play Bishop E8 and keep the
king F7 option available
well Bishop E8
arena is going to play King d8 Bishop A4
right because in this particular case
she does have the setup to Chase the
king away from F7 and Bishop A4 you're
absolutely right that would be played
but what else is she going to play then
um and I think this is the longest day
we've had out of all nine rounds
typical maybe the last round should be
the longest game and longest round of
the tournament and it should uh
30 seconds they should be counting down
to one second and making the the move
with once and changing the evaluation
back and forth exactly every few moves
right they just uh I mean seconds again
100 move hundred Rook D6 right
nine nine seconds what
Rook wait so now we're back in the
winning position
are we Bishop F6 check
and your King has to go to H7 so you
can't have the king F7 set up anymore
right
so a king G8 rookie eight that's very
simple we have King H7 and now we don't
have the bishop E8 D4 now is winning
and we're right back to the same
variation we could have had 20 moves ago
and Bishop D4 would be a winning move
here
which makes
all the sense in the world uh that uh
Bishop D4 is the winning move I think
the way to win is to put the Rook on d8
King on D6 and then put Bishop on E5
okay
four we couldn't figure out how to block
the e-file right Amira I I I I'm afraid
to come to you and say show me a simple
win one that we can all understand and
it doesn't take some uh you know crazy
Quiet Moves or something is it
straightforward at last not yet but
that's kind of the question uh 10
seconds sorry to interrupt you eight and
seven six four
I was about to say she's going to lose
on time if you couldn't invent uninvent
one thing would you uninvent the chess
programs
actually yes because it took so much
creativity out of the game
I wanted to say mystery
yes mystery mystery out of the game
because now we look at the engines and
say yes this is a winning move and we we
constantly asked ourselves
am I winning in the adjournment is it a
draw am I winning and now there's no
adjournments because there's no mystery
to them
um
Petrov in Berlin
yeah we will make those illegal
uh rip the d8 okay so she's on the right
traction it's still bring the king back
and Bishop on E5 should do it
so now Bishop has to move exactly and
then next move Bishop E5 exactly and
then rookie four king D6 and that's it
or even e
oh wait we are living age four pound
hanging
and we know that it's winning but Irina
doesn't know exactly because she doesn't
have time to calculate that it's a
Checkmate now I have a simple variation
for you after Bishop F7 if white plays
Bishop E5 here yes and then if you take
on H4 yes yes which seems logical now
you play Rook f8 do you beat the bishop
oh King G6 and now you take on F7 and
you play King D7 thank you that is what
I was looking for something very clean
and that's that that's very pretty as
The Rook is actually wrong footed but
Irina only has one min find all this
move
not easy
because in this variation when you play
Rook f8 you can't play Bishop G6 because
the Rook h8 made this is the whole idea
yeah that's why I would never want my
king on the H file we saw a number of uh
variations where the pattern of
checkmating patterns were available
because the King was on H6 at a certain
while and now with the King on H7 so
this move
rookie four
Jesus because I believe she thinks if
she loses H4 Pawn she's not women she's
afraid yeah that wouldn't be that
wouldn't be the case what that would be
the case but this move Rook f
8 no it was Bishop E5 pardon me Bishop
E5 Rook E4 cage four Cafe yes this one
is really nice uh Bishop F6 on the board
Let me refresh
Anna played
King so now Irina needs to come back
Bishop D4
or Bishop she's going to G5
yes
that's exactly what I've been looking
for because I'm getting so tired because
I went through the moves because I
wanted to see if Anna can eventually
claim a three four three-fold repetition
right but there have been so many
changes with the Kings on uh systems
but yes the bishop was on G5 already but
would not be the King on C7
ah
it is no but when the King was on C7
then The Rook was not on V8 that was
completely crazy yeah claiming
three-fold repetition based on position
is very difficult so you have to have
every single piece on the exact same
square exactly she doesn't have time to
figure that out right
check and King C6 so we're anticipating
that we're gonna have to put the Rook on
e4 should we yeah toss in another check
or two why not check
and
well Arena has built up our time
a minute and a half two minutes
too much time right
so if
Rook C4 what do we do okay
four and then we have rookie four
I don't see how
look C4 check I make progress
so the key to winning this position was
always to use the bishop to block The
Rook give up H4 pawn and win that end
game right we
trip on the E5 square and King will on
H7 in the Checkmate net exactly
exactly
without that Etc
they're on move 107 so I think 20 more
moves to go before 50 move claim
the commentators will run over to the
World Chess Hall of Fame and inform the
players we will make the claim for it
right
but I think the rule is Arbiter never
gets involved right the players have to
make the claim
that's right
because a faulty claim
it's that the uh
the
opponent will receive a two-minute
um
increment yes
an increase of their remaining time
rookie four on the board and
um wow
essentially we need to get this position
for arena with the bishop on E5
so that we will allow Rook takes H4 we
will make a queen we'll win the bishop
but the rook and Bishop versus Rook
ending is a win because the black king
is animating net at the start of that uh
ending
you know I almost booked my flight for
tonight but I knew I was like I've got
one forever
it could be eight so
now and I can just stand with the rookie
one back and forth make sure
no and then I can bring my Rook B5 no I
can't
put your Rook on no you we don't want to
put the Rooker King G7 it's about to say
we don't want to trade Rooks when the
king is close enough to F7 right so I
mean if our King was on D7 and we could
play Rook E3 we're happy campers
oh boy uh it feels like Championship
chess right it and I'm with you 100 if
first place was on the line uh with
Arena needing a win and and I'm eating a
draw
and every time they throw the point back
and forth to each other it would be like
a super miss right
Anna's counting him she's marking
marking the spots right the E7 move
which number that was exactly
but really they're just 16 moves away so
30 sec
what Rook
what what does that mean I think she's
doing some cheaper tricks if Rook leaves
the e-file you promote with the EAS
sweet look leaves the e-file Queen and
that's fine yes but if the bishop goes
back now
and the King goes to F7 as we've seen
before
Penny will be a draft and it will be a
draw
ask a silly question I get the correct I
mean we we can't definitely say it's a
draw because no mistakes keep happening
and
the engine keeps going from zeros to
plus three
well uh again for Anna I'm just
I'm stunned that you can go down to 10
seconds and not play Bishop E8
played rookie one
wow how wow rookie one okay
not bad but Bishop e h sure looks like
what you want a blockade
so it can go wait can I do Bishop D2 now
rookie four or rookie two yeah doesn't
matter Bishop C3 check and Bishop E5
that's the setup you want that that that
is exactly the setup you want urine has
been avoiding this because she doesn't
want to keep up the H4 poem right I
think if she wants to try to win she has
to try this there's no other way
King 57 sorry I I'm gonna refresh
no just check and then Bishop E8
well uh
Amira uh we we've been questioning uh
the play uh but it's really about the
the clock the nerves and the tiredness
of the players
um yes and here the position is once
again equal but Nazi was right there was
a small chance here to play Bishop D2
Rook E4 yep check C3 check but after
King G6 here you cannot play uh Bishop
B5 because I'm protecting the E4 square
and I can't actually take on H4 but you
need to play King D7 okay a very
important move so here let's say what
happens if I take on H4 then you give
check Rook B6 then anyway you want
actually to take the bishop so after yes
King F5 you take the bishop and after
King G5 you have Bishop F6 yeah oh nice
and so here you have to play
well King age seven but still Rook F6
and I think that we get in exactly the
same position where you can sacrifice
well your rook and promote exactly
and let's have a look just a second
because okay if you don't take
um
here was this King G7 where was this yes
King Bishop C3 King G6 King D7 so you
can you cannot take on H4 you have to
make a move here let's say King F5 but
here the same idea wins you play Rook B6
right and you play Rook F6 once again so
you can run with your king to this phone
but maybe now that your king is so far
away you can play Bishop F6 and
king of five Bishop G5 wow so maybe this
is a set of although I'm not sure
anymore
wow uh the players if you're not sure
you have the uh the Oracle uh you can
imagine the players uh as they're
because I'm still thinking what they
throw D4
and we do have a rook on D1 this is uh
to my way of thinking ideal for black if
if Annika put her Bishop on E8 and just
keep that blockade
I mean that's and a moment ago she had
the white king
cut on the sea file at the moment she's
got the white king cut on the D file
how many more moves
14 moves left still Anna can claim and
draw 50 more repetition I mean
well sure she knows that she was marking
these courses one of the things that I
would encourage people to do
and again your penalty for being wrong
as your opponent gets two minutes is
sometimes make a claim that you're
pretty certain
it's not good it's not valid whether it
be a 50 move claim or a three move
repetition claim and you gift your
opponent to and it's big deal the
information that you get is so powerful
oh I need six more moves yes to claim
the 50 move thank you Mr Arbiter and now
you know wand and so uh as long as the
punishment isn't that they deduct two
minutes that's right that's right as
long as it's not a deduction
then it's okay 15 seconds
for arena Rook C6 an indication no
improvements have been made that she
doesn't really know
what's her ideal setup right
right okay there should be eight now is
asking to be played definitely like just
uh again that even comes with the tempo
which means that after Bishop E8 will
have moves like Rook D7 check as well as
king G8 King F7 on our agenda
if white plays Rook D6 here we can just
say because our King is close enough to
come to F7 precisely
that's that's really the dream come true
right that would actually end the game
exactly
so Bishop E8 on the board Rook A6 on the
board
and again I'm I would be very very uh
inclined to toss in the check here
because you have to in this case go to
the eighth Rank and King C8 yeah yes
she's done it
Circle moves I can guess
King C8 right
and just Rook D1 back yep
I think so
the animal is left
for the commentator's sake yes
well I notice when you asked Almira how
many moves do they have left our
producer immediately had the answer
he was Johnny hit the spot boy
Tom's going to run over the world Jess
Hall of Fame and say you got 12 more
seconds to go come on
uh nine moves nine moves you can do it
ladies
King G8 good move should just went down
to six seconds did
playing with the playing with fire right
uh I think I've asked you this
uh but I've had it in my mind for a
number of years that you go down to
three seconds on your clock and I just
decide at that exact moment to make the
most hellacious sneeze heard around the
world and it shocks you so much that
your time oh I'm sorry oh boy I have bad
news for you your time someone needs to
try that
oh my goodness there's nothing against
the rules you're doing I sneezed nothing
even technically unethical right right
it just it just suddenly came over me
this horrifying need to sneeze
um Bishop G5 okay I can see that arena
is looking to sneak in some Rook F6
business but that shouldn't work either
because of rookie seven for the moment
so the king and just step back to G7
five seconds three
was it two it was two
32 seconds
right Rook F6 Bishop F7
but boy this does he even anticipate
I mean aren't you ready at a certain
moment you say to yourself if my
opponent plays this I'm ready with that
she probably over things looks for other
options and then forgets about the time
it looks and it's like oh I gotta make a
move gotta make a move yeah
so here and then at that moment often
you forget what was your move so
prepared again Rook F6 since Rook f8 is
such an overwhelming threat to move
Bishop F7 is an only move so immediately
right that's what I'm thinking that okay
she took what was it ten couple seconds
yeah to make an only move and they are
eight moves away
from a draw
we know that yeah now I do believe the
Arbiters will not step in at 50 or 55 or
60 but I do believe the something about
75.
75 moves then they step in and say okay
you must stop
so this is move 120 they're on the third
score shits now the third score sheets
but now she
now she checks
the way and Rook Rook check wow looks
before Rook D4 back and forth that's
really compelling
get a series of checks in there
just don't touch that Bishop right now
by the way you're alone Bishop E6 would
be okay my longest game was when I was
nine years old nine what I was playing
European Championship under 10.
Mommy and Daddy happy with you as a
nine-year-old I had six out of six and
that game went on for eight and a half
hours wow I was converting queen versus
two Rooks I had some pawns too good for
you and it was 180 something moves I
expect
and won the championship two rounds
ahead wow
180 moves that was a really spectacular
you Almera your longest uh Tournament
game well I don't even remember but
actually When I Was preparing against
an opponent I think it was Marcela
frimsky during the European Club cup I
went through her games and I think her
longest game might as well be the
longest chess game that I've ever seen I
think it went on for 200 something so if
I'm not mistaken I I well I was really
shocked so
I don't even know how many hours did it
last but overall the most difficult game
that they had it's lasted for
eight hours almost eight hours and I
played against Michael Adams and I had
the Fortress and he was trying to break
it So eventually I survived but I saw
that I was probably going to die
of the way from
Anna Bean able to claim the draw exactly
so in this moment after King D6 uh
foreign
we're still
aspiring to that moment that we can play
Bishop to F6
Rook Jack Bishop to E5 and get our Rook
back in shape on uh
the eighth rank
oh actually I have uh announcer I think
the longest tournament chess game ever
to be played was nikoli charcovich in
Belgrade at 1989 and it lasted for 269
moves and took 20 hours and 15 minutes
to complete the Drone games I assume it
was a Jordan yes me too yes
nice nice
[Laughter]
Yeah Anna has a couple more checks in
the back so right
King if I broke D5
that's that's nice when you can do a few
more checks and all you're trying to do
is make this 50 move rule mm-hmm
we still have that painful memory of
plain honor exactly in the US Women's
Championship in the rookie Bishop
against rook and the bishop and I
relaxed a bit too early got checked
media on move 49. oh
that's uh
that is pain
well it sure looks like Anna is about
ready to make the claim Arbiters uh at
the ready Judith as and Chris bird
watching on
and
again Anna's got like a minute on her
clock and again I I would be of the mind
that I would move my rook and make the
claim just so that I would know that
it's three more moves that I need to to
to have to make
yes and here after
King Euphoria she can just move the Rook
really anywhere anywhere that doesn't
blunder The Rook exactly just get it out
of the way
and then if you move the rook and again
if you if Arena
I toss in a check but those of you want
to play Bishop E8 so that you could meet
Rook d8 with King F7 you'd get my uh
vote Rook A5
by the way two moves left two moves
before she can claim the drop
and again I just find it confounding
that you would put a rook on the dark
square like why would you do that
you could
I remember uh
um players uh Boris Goku telling me a
story that he was playing a blind man
who had a braille chess set and it was
rook in three versus bishop and three
all and the three pawns were on the same
side of the board and he had the rook
and he was played like Rook to B1 and he
watched his opponent suddenly with the
Braille set and there was a light
squared Bishop on G6 so he took the Rook
I don't know right and Boris uh golco
said I wonder who was blind
I wanted her eye
I see
Rook to A5
it's left
F6 okay that stops the design I don't
have the Rook checks okay four right
another one and she can claim exactly
and once again even though I I'm aware
it's a faulty claim I would make it I
would play Rook a four check and just
27 seconds
rookie for a check
here we go this is it right this is the
50th move next move is the 50th move
Anna Anna has to make another check
and I mean just to be sure she'll
probably make a few more moves and then
climb the Drone
but I hope she kept the other score
sheet so she can see when we still asked
E7 move so she can count exactly King
five but like you said there's no
downside for her especially when you
have 50 seconds yeah
there is quite a pile of squishies
Rook check did not claim the draw
I love how I think on leeches it
automatically fixed the drop because it
was 50 moves so it says draw as if the
game ended it yes exactly uh our game
has ended but uh as you can clearly see
the clocks are ticking
uh time for some more checks
Hannah keeps thinking maybe she
is not aware
they've reached 50 moves well again I
found it a little bit confounding
because we did see her uh checking
carefully that the score sheet and you
know circling the move number be sure
marked the wrong number
she's expecting that she'll have to play
10 more moves instead of uh making the
claim
I guess you can take the Rook now right
oh but that would change the position
right yeah but oh no she can't trade it
she can't right do it in this moment
because there's no Bishop E8 and King F7
thanks so you have to give a check
thanks to Irina for playing King D7
right not allowing The Rook exchange
exactly
so again especially as both players are
building up time on their clocks I would
be making the draw claim and the Arbiter
can disallow it my opponent would get
two extra minutes and I'd say fine enjoy
yourself and I'd know where I'd stand
how many moves he had left
it's not really planning on claiming the
draw yet you seems so
conspiring against us
I mean no one's more tired than these
two players
Chuck
ah There She Goes finally she says I am
going to claim a draw I will play Rook
A8 and I'm claiming a draw and the
Arbiters and former you could have done
that
quite some time ago and uh it would have
been accepted
and the game has finished a very very
big effort by Arena that fell short at
various moments she did have a win but
it involved her giving up the h-bond
right we could have unders we understand
why she shied away from that knowing
that rook and Bishop versus Rook is a
drunk and Anna finishes the tournament
undefeated the only player who has not
lost a single game
fantastic fantastic effort by Anna Anna
comes into the tournament the lowest
rated player and leaves the tournament
number one
Almera How Sweet It Is
defibrillator
I was thinking that Anna doesn't even
look tired you know she I think she
could have played for an hour or two
right
she's just so happy that she's just on
fumes of euphoria yeah and the arena is
definitely disappointed because this
draw didn't allow her to catch Alexandra
right and by the way let's point out
that uh draw by about Victory by
Alexandra did give her the second prize
uh clear second prize and here is a
breakdown of our Prize winners
wins the tournament and takes home 45
thousand dollars Second Place Alexander
kostenyuk taking home 35 000 and shared
in third and splitted the prices fell
off at Philly and Irina crash with 22 22
and 500.
in Clearfield taking home fifteen
thousand dollars very very nice uh and
here is our champion one let's look at
Anna zatonski and as a Tennessee just
won the 2023 Karen's cup
and earned the GM norm and gained a lot
of raiding and will it be invited back
for uh next year's Edition and for those
of you who don't know we've got a summer
of Chess as a lot of tournaments coming
up
uh next tournament will be super United
rapid and Blitz in Zagreb Croatia from
July 3rd then will be U.S Juniors U.S
girls seniors championships in St Louis
July 13th and then in September
uh Fisher chest yes Fisher 9lx uh
September 7th through the level and in
October U.S and U.S women's
championships in St Louis exactly don't
go to my high school reunions but those
senior championships sure feel like a
reunion for me Amira closed the show
final thoughts well so I have the whole
nurse yes
wins the third Karen's cup and she
becomes the first American winner of
this event and this is by far the
greatest achievement in her career and I
think that this this result is simply
incredible but we have witnessed some
Fighting Chess throughout the tournament
and well I'm looking forward to next
events of course and just call me I will
be waiting in Paris
thank you Elmer you bet uh stay stand by
your phone you're gonna get uh lots of
calls it was great no seriously no uh
Nasi uh every day I was coming here was
really looking forward to the broadcast
thank you so much thank you so much
thank you all for joining us uh we
really enjoyed your company hope you
liked the shows and we'll see you for
the grantchester we'll see you in July
thank you so much bye-bye everyone
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited